GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY SOMEONE
HEARING ON APRIL ELEVENTH.
AND BEFORE I BEGAN I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A TERRACE PREROGATIVE AND
THANK SOMEONE WHO IS A
TREMENDOUS WRITER AND DOESN'T
GET ENOUGH RECOGNITION.
BUT BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA
THOUGH HAS BEEN SOMEONE WHO OUR
OFFICE.
REALLY LEANS ON AND REALLY
WANTED TO SHARE A SPECIAL THANK
YOU WITH HIM FOR. EVERYTHING
THAT YOU SEE HERE ON THIS
AGENDA.
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUE ONE
BUT I KNOW IN ONE
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS FOR ENTERTAINING
THIS ITEM THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT MY REQUEST TO
INCREASE FUNDING.
FOR THE DEAF ACCESS PROGRAM.
FROM FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET.
TWO EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION.
WHICH REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION FOR THE
PROGRAM.
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE DEAF
ACCESS PROGRAM IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY.
TO PROVIDE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING INDIVIDUALS.
WITH THE COMMUNICATION SERVICES
THEY NEED.
TO ACCESS THE STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS
TO WHICH THEY ARE LEGALLY
ENTITLED.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM REACHED
HOWEVER FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
WAS CUT DURING THE RECESSION.
AND REDUCED AGAIN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AS A RESULT OF FEDERAL
SEQUESTRATION.
OVERALL THE DEATH ACCESS PROGRAM
HAS LOST A TOTAL OF ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN.
THIS IS LEFT THE PROGRAM AT ITS
CURRENT FUNDING LEVEL OF FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION.
IN ADDITION TO RESTORING THE
FUNDING
THE PROGRAM HAS LOST.
I'M ALSO REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TO ALLOW AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO WHAT ARE CALLED
LINGUISTICALLY. ISOLATED
HOUSEHOLDS
WHICH CURRENTLY ARE NOT
RECEIVING SERVICES DUE TO A
FUNDING SHORTAGE.
A LINGUISTICALLY ISOLATED
HOUSEHOLD. REFERS TO A HOUSEHOLD
IN WHICH NO ONE FOURTEEN YEARS
OR OLDER SPEAKS ENGLISH QUOTE
VERY WELL.
ALONG WITH THIS FUNDING REQUEST
I AM PROPOSING BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW CONTRACTS
THAT DEAF ACCESS PROGRAM
AGENCIES OPERATE.
TO BE RENEWED EVERY FIVE YEARS
RATHER THAN ANNUALLY.
THIS WILL GRANT THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES FLEXIBILITY
IN THE CONTRACT RENEWAL PROCESS.
AND IT WILL RELIEVE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT
AGENCIES FACE WHEN RENEWING
THEIR CONTRACTS EACH YEAR.
I MYSELF AM HEARING IMPAIRED.
AND THIS ISSUE IS VERY PERSONAL
TO ME THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR
WORKING TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
THIS DEAF ACCESS PROGRAM. I AM
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING INDIVIDUALS
HAVE FULL ACCESS.
THE COMMUNICATION SERVICES THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR UNDER STATE
LAW.
I HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY
MICHELLE BRONSON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING SERVICE CENTER IN
FRESNO.
AND LIZA RAFI KEY A CONSUMER OF
DEAF ACCESS PROGRAM SERVICES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND YOU MAY
HAVE NOTICED WE HAVE A NUMBER.
OF SUPPORTERS AND ADVOCATES WITH
US A AS WELL IN THE AUDIENCE
TODAY FROM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. UP OF VISITING OUR
STATE CAPITOL TODAY AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND.
I WOULD LIKE IF I CAN TO REMIND
YOU. HOW EXCITED I WAS TO PUSH
THIS FORWARD THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR AND?
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE ALL
RAISE OUR ABILITIES TO BE HEARD
HERE IN OUR CAPITOL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUE
DISCUSSION WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR WE DID NOT.
GET IT IN THE FINAL BUDGET
DOCUMENT BUT I BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE YEAR THAT WE. WILL DO SO.
THANK.
RACHEL BRUNSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHELLE
BRONSON I AM THE EXECUTOR ACTOR
FOR THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
SERVICE CENTER WE STE.
SERVE THAT CENTRAL VALLEY
HEADQUARTERED IN FRESNO I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF AGENCIES SERVING
THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING. AS
WELL AS DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
LATE DEAFENED DEAFBLIND
COMMUNION NUMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
FROM THE REST OF MY PRESENT HIT.
SPEECH I WANNA USE STAFF IT'S
ALL INCLUSIVE I AM WE ARE ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BUDGET
AUGMENTATION SINCE DOC WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY.
THE IT'S BEEN INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE QUALIFIED
SERVICES WITH THE DECREASING
BUDGET.
HI HER PRIMARY GOAL IS TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO COMMUNICATION
ACCESS.
AND TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO ALL
THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING TO
WIND THEY A SISTER AGENCIES. WE
PROVIDE THE DIRECT SERVICES TO
THE ARKANSAS OUR COMMUNITY. ALSO
WE WORK WITH DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING. INDIVIDUALS WHO MOVE
HERE AS IMMIGRANTS. AND WHO WANT
TO COME TO AMERICA AND LEARN HOW
TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES AND WE
TEACH A STALL WHETHER IT'S
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE OR
ENGLISH ON ICQ MOST OFTEN IS THE
THIRD OR FOURTH LANGUAGE.
AND.
AS HUMANS WE RELY AS DEAF
INDIVIDUALS RELY ON VISUAL
COMMUNICATION IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO RECEIVE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE OR SERVICES. FROM
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE THEY ARE
DEAF AND THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND A
FURNACE OR. OUR LANGUAGE.
I SAT DOWN WE DO ALL OF OUR
STAFF OR DIRECTORS ARE ALL DOUBT
WE WILL HAVE THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES DEAF PERSON IN OUR
WORLD.
WE HAVE THE PHILOSOPHY OF
DARPA'S OF BY AND FOR DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING AND WE'VE HONOR
THAT COMMITMENT SINCE OUR
INCEPTION.
IN ALL OF OUR SERVICES.
MAMA WE FACE OUR POPULATION FACE
DISCRIMINATION EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES ANY MEANS THAT YOU
WOULD NEED WORK CONSISTENTLY
BATTLING BUSINESSES WHO.
EITHER DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
PROVIDING INTERPERSONAL SAYS OR
REFUSAL TO PROVIDE THAT
COMMUNICATION ACCESS. AND WILL
NOT.
I DON'T HAVE TO WORK EXPAND ON
THE INFORMATION WHAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THEN THE DEAF INDIVIDUAL BUT
WE TAKE ON THAT ACT BUT WE CAN'T
DO THIS ANYMORE FOR GONNA. HAVE
EFFORT TO CLOSE OUR OFFICES
BASED ON CUT ON THE CUTS.
WE CAN'T SEVERAL AREAS REDUCING
STATURE AND KIDS AND THAT MEANS
THAT ARE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING AND ESPECIALLY A
LINGUISTIC ISOLATE HOUSEHOLD WHO
BOUGHT.
CRITICALLY NEEDS THE SERVICES
ARE NOT GOING TO GET THOUGHT.
THE CASELOAD OF THE EIGHT
SISTER AGENCIES INCLUDE MANY
SERVICES IT'S ADVOCATING FOR HER
PARTNERS AHMET MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS DOCUMENT
TRANSLATION SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
MAKE THEIR CORRECT HEALTH CARE
CHOICE FOR THEMSELVES ADVOCATE
FOR CPS ONE CPS SHOWS UP FOR A
HOME VISIT AND THEY DON'T
PROVIDE INTERPRETER. OR CASE
MANAGEMENT BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
STAFF TURNOVER.
PROVIDING COUNSELING BECAUSE OF
ANGER AND DEPRESSION ISSUES
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS ARE
HEARING IN THEIR PARENTS DON'T
COMMUNICATE AND SIGNED WITH THEM
AT HOME. EMPLOYMENT PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES EDUCATING
SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES AND
BUSINESSES OF THEIR LEGAL
OBLIGATION RESPONSIBILITIES
PROVIDE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS.
AND ALSO TEACHING THEM BUDGETING
SKILLS BECAUSE LOT OF HEARING
PARENTS TAKE THEIR SET AT THAT
FIGHT CHECKS AWAY FROM THEM AND
THEY MAKE ALL THE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS. OF THESE I'M CLIENTS
THAT WE WORK WITH THE CLIENTS TO
LET THEM UNDERSTAND AND AND KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A CHOICE. TO MAKE
THE DECISION AND NOT THEIR
PARENTS.
AND OR OUTSIDE PROFESSIONALS
THAT THEY CAN'T AS ADULTS THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO.
TO MAKE THOSE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS WE ASK YOU TO.
SUPPORT OUR REQUEST FOR THE FOUR
POINT ONE MILLIONS.
AUGMENTATION SO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE.
.
SERVICES AND ALL THOSE OF.
MINORITIES OF THE LINGUISTIC
LIMITED HOUSEHOLDS BECAUSE WE.
AS IN OUR COMMUNITY YOU DEPEND
ON AUDITORY ACCESS
BUT VISUAL LANGUAGE IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO AND WE PROVIDE THAT
TRACK SERVICE.
SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES AND NOT
JUST BURKE CURRENT CASELOAD BUT
FOR ALL THOSE WHO MOVE HERE FROM
ANOTHER COUNTRY FOR A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEMSELVES. PLEASE
CONSIDER TO SUPPORT OUR GAP AND
IT MEANS THAT WE CAN IMPROVE.
OUR OUTREACH.
TO DEATH IMMIGRANT FAMILIES.
AN OUTREACH TO OTHERS
AND TO TRAIN AND DEVELOP
TRAININGS SO FOR TRILINGUAL
INTERPRETERS TO SERVE THE
SPECIFIC POPULATION.
AND THE LINGUISTIC DEMANDS IS
INCREASING.
SO WE NEED YOUR HELP.
SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW OUR
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS.
ON THROUGH TAP.
AND TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AND
PROVIDE ACCESSIBLE SERVICES TO
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND I WILL ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU HAVE A COPY OF MY.
MY TESTIMONY THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
AND MISS BRONSON IF I MAY. AT
SOME POINT WHEN WE'RE BACK IN
FRESNO MORE CONSISTENTLY I'D
LIKE TO COME INTO OUR YOUR
FACILITY IF. YOU'D BE WILLING TO
SHOW ME AROUND SO I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU.
YEAH ALWAYS WELCOME.
YES YOU'RE ALL VERY WELCOME BE
HAPPY TO GIVE YOU TWO EVER
AGENCY. IT WOULD BE THE SAME FOR
ALL SISTER AGENCIES THAT WE SIR
ALL CONSTITUENTS AND STATE
CALIFORNIA THANK.
NEXT WE HAVE LEASE OVER A FEW
KEY.
HELLO.
MY NAME LISA.
REFUGEE.
MANY HAPPY TO BE HERE TO MEET
THE CAPITAL. AND YOU MEMBERS.
MY FATHER.
MOVED TO AMERICA.
THREE YEARS AGO.
MY FATHER AFGHANISTAN ARMY WITH
AMERICAN ARMY AND WORK WITH.
AMERICAN.
MILITARY.
MY FATHER.
WAS ASKED
TO COME TO AMERICA.
FROM THE ARMY.
AND THE I LOST HIM AND HE CAME
HOME TO TALK TO MY FAMILY AND I.
WE ALL.
MAIN AGREEMENT.
SAY YES WE COME TO AMERICA.
WE ARE SO THANKFUL.
MY FATHER.
PREPARED AND PLAN.
WE COME TO AMERICA.
I WITH GO TO HIGH SCHOOL.
I BIG AYE WITH HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR.
I HAVE NOT ENOUGH ENGLISH OR A A
THAW.
SO I WAS NOT READY TO GO ON TO
COLLEGE.
SO I SAY HIGH SCHOOL.
TWO MORE YEARS.
AND THEN I LOWER WENT ON TO
COLLEGE.
AFTER FINISH HIGH SCHOOL.
COUNSELOR TELL ME NO I NEED TO
IMPROVE MY ENGLISH AND AIR SAU.
MY READING AND WRITING.
IN ORDER TO GO TO COLLEGE.
SO.
I WAS HAPPY I FOUND NOR CAL
SERVICES.
FOR DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING.
WHERE I CAN GO?
I WENT TO TRAINING PROGRAM.
LEARN. READ AND WRITE.
LETTERS AND THROUGH THE DAMP
PROGRAM I CAN LEARN ENGLISH AND
ATHOL.
AND JOB READY.
AND HELP ME TO GET A JOB.
THIS PROGRAM IS WONDERFUL.
SUPPORTING FOR ME.
SIX MONTHS NOW FINISH I HAVE
IMPROVED A LOT
IN MY SIGNING SKILLS AND
ENGLISH.
I AM THINKING NOR CAL.
MANY FURTHER SERVICES.
MY DREAM SOMEDAY.
THAT I WILL OWN.
A BAKERY.
MAYBE SOME DAY YOU WILL COME AND
BUY.
CAKES FROM ME.
PLEASE SUPPORT NOR CAL.
AND ALL DEAF AGENCIES.
BECAUSE.
DEAF PEOPLE LIKE ME.
WE NEED THEM AND WE THINK.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE DIRECTOR LIKE PORN.
WE CAN GIVE UNLESS BY.
LET'S FUND MEANTIME THOUGH.
ALL BEEN WELL LIKE CORN DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA.
SERVICES. ARE. YOU.
OBVIOUSLY ARM WEEK YOU KNOW
WE'VE PROVIDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE SPONSORS NORTH
IS OFFICE.
ON THE OF.
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
ARE VERY HIGH QUALITY. WE RELY
ON THEM YOU KNOW GREATLY WE ARM
AGREE WITH THE.
.
RECITATION OF SURVEY HISTORICAL
FUNDING ARM YOU YOUR COMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE A
NUMBER OF PRIORITIES IT'S GOING
TO CONSIDER BUT HOW MUCH WANT TO
EXPRESS. OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY ON THE AND
THE GAP AGENCIES THAT WE FOR.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA A.
SEEING NO.
BERMAN FINE.
YEAH WE WOULD A PARENT FINANCE
THAT WE HAVE MET WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS TO TALK ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL. AND WE ARE FORTUNATE
DOS MEET WITH SOME OF THE.
AB REPRESENTS FROM THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THIS MORNING TO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
MAJOR CONCERNS AT THE MOMENT ME
IT'S.
IT'S JUST THAT I. LIKE TO GO
BACK TO HIS PRIORITIES.
AND.
NOW WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE ONE.
EVELYN I'LL HASN'T DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WERE CROSS
DISABILITY ORGANIZATION.
WE SEND THEM A LETTER OF
SUPPORT LARGEST HERE IN PERSON
TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL WOULD
HELP IN ANY WAY THAT WE CAN.
I THINK YOU MEANT.
AND.
I'VE BEEN.
ALL OF.
AND.
BUDGET CUTS
VERY DIFFICULT PART BUT.
PROVIDING SERVICES.
ALL OF THE OFFICES ARE.
SUFFERING FROM THESE BUDGET CUTS
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT.
AND WE WHEN THE BUDGET PASSES
THIS.
NEXT FEW MONTHS
IT IS COULD BE VERY HARD FOR THE
NEXT FURTHER AGENCIES WHO SERVE
THOSE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING.
COMMUNITIES AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE IN
SUPPORT AND I LOOK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS PROPOSAL AS
WELL.
THIS IS BECOMING A CRISIS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE NOW LIABLE FOR FAILED
SERVICES TO THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING.
PEOPLE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO. I AM A MEMBER OF AN
AUDIENCE HERE AND I WANT TO SAY
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAUREEN
THOMPSON I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHARITY ACOSTA
AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRITNEY WATER
SOON AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GIVE.
MY NAME IS JEFF BURCHELL I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CASEY PORTER I
HELLO MY NAME IS HUGH. AND I
REALLY DO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THINK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALICE MCGILL
AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT THE
AUGMENTATION.
HELLO MY NAME IS DUSTIN NOT AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
AUGMENTATION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS OF JORDAN LOW
PARENTS AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA.
CYLINDER PERRY. AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE DEAF
COMMUNITY SERVICES IN SAN DIEGO.
WE ARE REALLY.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF YOU
CONSIDERING THIS AUGMENTATION.
WE HAVE A LARGE.
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE POPULATION
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND THIS
COULD REALLY BENEFIT FROM THIS
AUGMENTATION SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
RAYMOND ROGERS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TO CARA SERVICES FOR
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING IN THE
BAY AREA AND THE NORTH COAST.
WE RECEIVE A LOTS OF IMMIGRANT
CLIENTS IN THE BAY AREA
INCLUDING THE HOMELESS.
SO IT'S A SEVERE SITUATION AND
WE NEED YOUR HELP THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN NGUYEN.
WORD AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AS WELL.
I WAS DEAD.
BUT THIS
VIEW
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS SANDY.
PARKS.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIAH.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIS.
HELLO. MY NAME IS CRUZ TH.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS MARGIE.
THE LOW AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN THIS BILL SLICE.
EPA WORK WITH. NOR CAL SERVICES
ALSO DONE WORK FOR VERY GLAD.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHERRY FARINA.
I'M THE CEO OF NOR CAL SERVICES
FOR DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING OUR
REGION COVERS TWENTY FOUR
NORTHEASTERN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA.
I WON I THINK YOU ALL. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I WANNA THANK THE
COMMUNITY FOR SHOWING UP TODAY.
AND THANK YOU CHAIR.
FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE FOR AND ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE. WE ARE PLEADING IT
WE IMPLORE YOU FOR YOUR HELP TO
GET THIS A BUDGET ITEM MAKE THIS
A PRIORITY.
THANK YOU BECAME.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS IS MONEY FISHER.
AND I'M ALSO SUPPORT THE
AUGMENTATION.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
TELL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THAT WE MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE. I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
I COULD NOT THINK OF A BETTER
ADVOCATE THAN MY SEAT MATE.
AND.
IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME I JUST
WANTED TO ALSO SAY.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO.
THANK YOU SIR.
NO ONE TO ESTABLISH A FORUM AS
WERE TRANSITIONING. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA PRESENT HARPER BUT
MATHIS RUBIO.
WOULD.
QUORUM
WE HAVE TO ADDITIONAL SEATS
THAT.
THE PRESENTING TABLE AND IF I
MAY SINCE WE HAVE SUCH A LARGE
GROUP ASK FOR FRANK MECCA. AS
WELL AS SANJANA BOUQUET TO COME
FORWARD.
AND THEN AS SEATS BECOME
AVAILABLE WE'LL ROTATE PEOPLE IN
AND OUT.
DOCTOR LIGHT BORN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ARE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PALM WILL LIKE
BORN DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND. I'M JOINED
BY GREG ROSE WHO IS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES.
AND SARAH ROGERS WHO IS THE
CHIEF OF OUR CONTINUE OF CARE
REFORM BRANCH.
ARM.
THE.
MATERIAL ON ITEM TO WHICH IS THE
CONTINUE OF CARE IS
VERY COMPLETE ARM.
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY SOME ISSUES
THAT YOU COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO
ARE GOING TO SOME DETAIL ON. ALL
OF THEM THERE ARE NOT ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE BUDGET.
IN THE IN THE PACKAGE SO.
WE DON'T TALK HAVE A.
PAIRED OUR ANSWER TO THIS NO
ANSWER TO THAT.
ALL OF THEM ARE JUST SORT OF
NOTE IN SORT OF OVERALL
PREFERENCE THAT.
CONTINUOUS CARE REFORM IS A SORT
OF.
AND INFLIGHT ARM INITIATIVE THAT
HAS BEEN UNDERWAY NOW FOR A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR. ALL IT HAS
MANY MANY MOVING PARTS THEY ARE
ALL EXTREMELY INTERACTIVE.
HOMES THEY CAN'T BE.
COMPLETELY SYNCHRONIZED IN THE
SENSE OF EVERYTHING DOESN'T
HAPPEN AT ONCE WE CAN'T FLIP A
SWITCH AND GO FROM.
THE SYSTEM THAT WAS TO THE
SYSTEM THAT WILL BE RATHER IT'S
A MATTER OF BRINGING IN. ON THE
IN IN THE BEST HOME POSSIBLE.
WAY THE COMPONENTS THAT SUPPORT
THE WORK THAT'S JUST GONE BEFORE
IN THE WORKED JUST ABOUT TO
HAPPEN.
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU CAN SORT OF SAY
WITH COMPLETE CERTAINTY THAT I
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WEEK AFTER NEXT.
ON THE WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT
THE SORT OF THE TEAM WHO HAS
WORKED
ON IMPLEMENTATION BOTH OF THEM
FROM THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THE
STATE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT OF THE GOOD WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES ON DAY
PROVIDER COMMUNITY VIA. THE
ALLIANCE ON HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
ATTENTIVE AND SORT OF MEETS ON A
SERVER WORKS ON US INTERACTIVELY
A SEMI CONSTANT BASIS.
THAT WHICH IS LAUNCHED IS
QUICKLY ADJUSTED AND
ALL HOME FINE TUNED. ALONE AND
THE.
I I THINK THE PARTNERSHIP WILL
THOUGH IT FACES MANY CHALLENGES
MANY HURDLES ON IS OUR RESOLVING
THEM ONE AFTER THE OTHER AS AS
THEY PRESENT THEMSELVES SO
WITHOUT A SORT OF THE. PARENT
REDUCTION I'VE GOT ASSUME YOU'RE
NOT WITH CCR ISN'T WHY WE'RE
DOING IT.
ALL AND RATHER ALSO TO SEE IF
THERE ARE PARTICULAR AREAS THAT
THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO ON
EXPLORE.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
FRANK MICA.
THANKS MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAC
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND.
.
CCR IS A HUGE AUDACIOUS EFFORT
AND ONE THAT WERE QUITE PROUD
OF.
AND FULLY COMMITTED TO IN FACT
OUR STAFF.
CO CHAIRED THAT. GROUP THAT MADE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS MANY OF
WHICH EAD TO ULTIMATELY TO CC
ARE.
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS BUILT ON
A LOT OF PROMISING PRACTICES
THAT WERE IN PLACE LEADING UP TO
CCR.
ARM AND AS THE AGENDA DESCRIBES
CCAR'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS IT'S REALLY NOT ONE
REFORM. IT'S ACTUALLY NO FEWER
THAN SIX REFORMS EACH ONE OF
WHICH.
IT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT EFFORT
IT'S AN EXPANSION OF INTENSIVE
SERVICES FOSTER CARE.
THE COMPLETE RECONSTRUCTION OF
THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT AND
EXECUTE CONGREGATE CARE. IT'S A
MAJOR CHANGE IN THE WAY WE BET
AND APPROVED FAMILIES.
HOW TO CARE FOR FOSTER KIDS?
IT'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
REFORMS TO THE WAY WE ASSESS THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE WAY WE DO CASE
WORK OTHER WHERE SOCIAL WORKERS
DO CASE WORK.
IT'S A BRAND NEW RATE SETTING
SYSTEM FOR PROVIDERS
I'M AND IT'S REALLY AN
UNPRECEDENTED DEGREE AT SORT
INTEGRATION WITH THE BETWEEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND CHILD
WELFARE.
ARM AND IT WAS ALWAYS IT WAS
ALSO PUT ON AN EXTRAORDINARILY
AMBITIOUS TIMELINE ON THE ONLY.
THE ONLY ARMED SERVICES HAVE TO
MY TAKE TO MISTER LIKE PRINCE
COMMENT WHEN HE SAID IT FEELS
LIKE WHEN IS THAT A SEMI
CONSTANT STATE OF MEETING IN
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
APPEALS LIKE IT'S A CONSTANT
STATE OF OUR ENGAGEMENT NO SAMMY
HERE AT ALL NAM AND THE THE
PARTNERSHIP HAS BEEN VERY STRONG
THIS IS A LOT OF WORK. ARM
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED FOR THE
STATE FOR THE COUNTIES FOR
PROVIDERS IN THE COMMUNITY FOR.
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AND WE'VE
MADE SOME SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
ARM IN IMPLEMENTING DOT CCR.
COM AND AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES
THERE SOME AREAS WHERE WE'VE HAD
SOME SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THE
DELAYS IN THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT ALREADY. ON
BUT THAT'S ONE OF THOSE AREAS
THAT MR LIKE PORN DISCUSSED
WHERE WE MADE MYTH MID COURSE
CORRECTIONS WE IDENTIFIED SOME
THINGS THAT WEREN'T WORKING ON
WE MADE SOME CHANGES TO. ON TO
TRY TO IMPROVE THINGS.
.
SO I MEAN OVERALL THE ARC OF CCR
IS PROBABLY WHAT WE'D EXPECT
AND WE DO WANT TO RAISE SORT OF
ONE. ARM ISSUE FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT CONSIDERATION AND I
THINK WE'LL ELUCIDATED MORON.
DIFFERENT BUDGET PROPOSALS ARM
BETTER THAT ARE COMING FORWARD.
SO THE KEY COMPONENT OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS OF CCAR'S THIS TWELVE
THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN DEADLINE.
I'M AFTER WHICH GROUP HOMES AS
WE KNEW THEM ARE NO LONGER.
AND.
CHILDREN SHOULD NEED TO BE
PLACED WITH FAMILIES OR INTO
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES THAT ARE FOR ABOUT
THERAPY NOT HOUSING.
HOUSING KITS.
THAT THEORY ASSUMES THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
BOTH S. T. R. TEEPEES PARDON THE
ACRONYM. AND THOSE INTENSIVE
FAMILY HOMES TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THE NEEDS.
OF THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED OR SO A
KID IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
I'M WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN GROUP
HOMES.
I'M
WE HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS THAT THE ADEQUATE
NUMBER OF PLACEMENTS WILL BE
AVAILABLE BY THAT TWELVE THIRTY
ONE DEADLINE.
TOM AND IF WE COULD
SERVE LAYOUT ARM.
THE BASIS FOR THOSE CONCERNS.
ARMED DATA THERAPEUTIC FAMILY
BASED SETTINGS
ON FOSTER FAMILIES THE WRAPPED
AROUND WITH A LOT OF SERVICES
ARE. TREATMENT FOSTER CARE AND
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE.
BOB WE'VE NOT SEEN THE PROGRESS
IN RECRUITING AND PUTTING THOSE
FAMILIES ONLINE THAT WE HELPED.
I'M TREATMENT FOSTER CARE IS.
CLOSE TO NONEXISTENT AND
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE.
BOB WE'RE NOT GETTING THE
RESPONSE WE'RE WORKING HARD ON
IT BUT WE'RE NOT GETTING THE
RESPONSE.
THAT
WE HOPE THAT TO SOME DEGREE THIS
IS JUST IMPLEMENTATION REALITY
THAT AYE SFC.
STATE INSTRUCTIONS JUST CAME OUT
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO SO I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT THIS IS LIKELY
TO BE A PERMANENT STATE OF
AFFAIRS.
BUT THE BUT THE SLOW START
GIVEN THAT TWELVE THIRTY ONE
IT'S NOT THAT FAR AWAY.
IS WORRISOME AND SO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT COIN IS THAT THE
RATE OF CONVERSION OF GROUP
HOMES INTO STR TEEPEES.
I THINK THE LATEST DATA SUGGEST
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED.
S. T. RTP BEDS AND I HATE THAT
TERM THEIR PLACEMENT OPTIONS
THERAPEUTIC PLACEMENT OPTIONS IN
S. T. R. TEEPEES FOR YOU.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED KIDS IN THOSE
FACILITIES NOW.
I'M WE DON'T EXPECT ALL THOSE.
GROUP HOMES TO CONVERT ES
CHARITY PEACE BECAUSE THE THEORY
OF
CCR THAT SOME NUMBER OF THOSE
CHILDREN SHOULD BE PLACED.
IN THERAPEUTIC FAMILY BASED
SETTINGS.
BUT THAT BUT THE SIZE OF THAT
DISCONNECT.
COUPLED WITH WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF RESOURCE FAMILIES
THAT WE HAVE. GIVES US GIVES US
REASON FOR CONCERN.
ARM AND I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THROUGH THIS GROSS NUMBER OF S.
T. RTP.
PLACEMENT OPTIONS
THIRTEEN HUNDRED.
BOB DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THEY ARE ALL AVAILABLE FOR
FOSTER CARE.
I AM SO FOR EXAMPLE. NAM SAID.
THE CITY HAS TO BE IN A LOCATION
THAT'S CLOSE TO THE BACK KIDS
WHO NEED.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE YOUTH FOR
EXAMPLE WE WOULD WE HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE. WE HAVE A
YOUTH WHOSE.
THERE'D THEIR TREATMENT NEEDS
IN THEIR STRENGTHS AND THEIR
THEIR THEIR ISSUES WOULD SUGGEST
A FACILITY WOULD BE A GOOD TRIP
TREATMENT FACILITY AND WILL
HERE.
ARM WE TAKE GIRLS NOT PORTS AND
THAT'S THE WAY THEY ORGANIZED
THEIR PROGRAM THAT'S THAT'S
THEIR SPECIALTY.
I'M WE ALSO KNOW THAT THAT ES
CHARITY PEAK CAPACITY IS NOT
JUST FOR KIDS IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
THERE'S THAT FACILITY THAT WE
NEVER RECENTLY TALKED ABOUT
WHERE I THINK THEY HAD SEVENTY
FIVE.
A PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITIES ONLY
TWENTY OF WHICH.
ARM OR BEING FELT BY THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THE REST WERE
EITHER PRIVATE PAY. CLIENTS OR
CLIENTS FROM THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM FROM THAT.
.
BOB SPECIAL EDUCATION SYSTEM.
ARM AND SO. NAM.
THAT WE. WE HAVE TO CONSTANTLY
SORT OF REFINE THIS.
.
PROJECTING ARE WE GONNA HAVE
ENOUGH.
PLACEMENT OPTIONS WE HAVE TO
HAVE A A MORE REFINED LOOK AT IT
AND JUST SORT OF THE NUMBERS.
WE ALSO HAVE AN ISSUE THAT WERE
COUNTIES ARE REPORTING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF S. T.
RTP THESE ARE ACTUAL GROUPON
THAT HAVE CONVERTED. WHO ARE NOT
ACCEPTING OUR OUR PLACEMENTS
WILL CALMNESS WILL LAY OUT A
NEED ENOUGH SAY THAT WE THAT
THAT CHILD DOESN'T DOESN'T MEET
OUR PROFILE OR THEY'LL REJECT
EGX REJECTS?
THE TERM WE USE.
ACROSS NINE CENTRAL VALLEY
COUNTIES THAT WE SURVEYED.
SINCE JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR
FORTY ONE CHILDREN WERE EITHER
REJECTED OR EACH ACTED BY THOSE
FACILITIES.
.
THAT IS NOT TO SAY THAT EVERYONE
OF THOSE OBJECTIONS ARE
REJECTIONS WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
BUT IT IS TO SAY AS WE REALLY
THINK ABOUT DO WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY.
TO BE COMFORTABLE THAT WARM
TWELVE THIRTY ONE HIT.
TOM WE HAVE THE TREATMENT
CAPACITY WE HAVE TO REALLY DIG
DEEPER.
INTO INTO THE NUMBERS AND SO.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE CONCERN FOR
US IS THAT.
.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY.
POR EITHER IN INTENSIVE FAMILY
BASED SETTINGS OR IN GOOD HIGH
QUALITY STR TEEPEES.
KIDS COULD BE PLACED OUT OF
STATE THEY COULD STAY LONGER IN
TEMPORARY SHELTERS WHICH IS
CERTAINLY NOT IDEAL. IF WE TRY
TO PLACE THOSE CHILDREN WITH
FAMILIES WHO DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE
SUPPORTS.
WE COULD BURDEN AND BURNOUT
THOSE FAMILIES AND RESULT IN
PLACEMENT MOVES THAT.
BREACH FROM THAT RE TRAUMATIZE
THE YOUTH.
OR IF THE COURTS
A AND THE LAW ALLOWS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO USE GROUP HOMES THAT
DON'T CONVERT. I'M INTO STR
TEEPEES WE'D BE DOING SO WITHOUT
ANY FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT WOULD
BE LOSING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WOULD DRAIN THAT WOULD THEN
DRAIN RESOURCE AWAY FROM OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE SYSTEM.
SO SORT OF.
BOTTOM LINE CONCERN FOR US
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO MONITOR WITH THE
STATE AND WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
TOM IS THAT WE DON'T DO HARM.
AT A MINIMUM WE SHED HIPPOCRATIC
STANDARD AND CCR.
AND.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM IS
COMPLETELY COMMITTED TO THAT
GOAL ARM.
FROM THE FRONT LINES THE PEOPLE
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM AT THE
FRONT LINES ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE IN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SS.
WE THINK THERE'S REASON.
FOR US TO EXAMINE
AND START TO THINK ABOUT.
WHAT CONTINGENCY PLANS WE MIGHT
MAKE IF?
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FACILITIES
AND HIGH QUALITY FAMILIES
TO PREVENT CHILDREN FROM
UNWITTINGLY AND UNINTENTIONALLY
BEING WORSE OFF BY CC ARE NOT
BETTER.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WE HAVE SANDRA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE ON SUNDAY BEGAN A
HUMAN SERVICES DIRECTOR IN KINGS
COUNTY. AREN'T KINGS COUNTY IS A
MEDIUM SIZE ON VALLEY COUNTY
WITH A POPULATION OF ABOUT
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND AND WE'RE
BORDERED BY FRESNO. TULARE AND
KERN COUNTIES.
AND CURRENTLY IN OUR COUNTY WE
HAVE ABOUT.
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
KIDS IN CARE AND THAT'S THE
COUNTY WE HAVE TRULY EMBRACE ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CCR AND
PUT FRANKLY WE'VE DONE RATHER
WELL SO FAR. WE WERE ONE OF THE
EARLY RFA IMPLEMENTERS SO I'M
GONNA.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE ACRONYM UP.
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL SO
BEASTLY STARTED WITH FOUR OTHER
COUNTIES IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
ESSENTIALLY HAD A TWO YEAR HEAD
START ABOVE.
UP AHEAD OF OTHER COUNTIES WHICH
REALLY IS WHAT'S ALLOWING ME TO
SAY TODAY THAT FIFTY THREE
PERCENT OF OUR KIDS ARE PLACED
IN OUR FACE.
AND EVERY FORMER FOSTER HOME AND
A RELATIVE.
HAS BEEN CONVERTED TO AN RFA
PLACEMENT. PART OF OUR SUCCESS
WAS ALSO THAT WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED OUR
ALLIANCE IN GROUP HOMES TWO
YEARS AGO KINGS COUNTY HAD
TWENTY SIX KIDS IN GROUP HOMES
AND TODAY WE HAVE SEVEN.
AND PART OF THE SUCCESS WAS
REALLY THE NUMBER OF EFFORTS
THAT WE'VE DONE WE'VE.
EMBRACE THE CALIFORNIA COURT
PRACTICE MODEL WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SAFETY ORGANIZED
PRACTICE WHICH REALLY HAS GIVEN
US A GOOD FOUNDATION ON THE SIDE
OF CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM
MEETINGS. WE'VE IMPROVED OUR
FAMILY FINDING AND.
IT WAS THERE ARE IF OUR IT WAS
THE CCR RESOURCE OF VAPORS THAT
REALLY ALLOWED FOR THAT.
AND WE WORKED WITH OUR LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE PAST YEAR TO IMPROVE
OUR APPS SERVICES.
BUT DESPITE ALL OF THOSE
SUCCESSES WE'VE.
CONTINUE TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTING CCR
AND PART OF THAT IS THAT WE
STILL STRUGGLE WITH PLACEMENT OF
ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF OUR
POPULATION. WE HAVE OVER THE
PAST YEAR AT ANY GIVEN TIME
SEVEN TO TEN KIDS IN GROUP HOMES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO STEP
DOWN. WE HAVE ABOUT TEN KIDS
THAT ARE EITHER FREQUENT RUN
RUNAWAYS OR A BALL AND ABOUT
FIFTEEN KIDS THAT. IN OUR COUNTY
WE HAVE.
WORKED THROUGH MULTIPLE MOVES
BECAUSE WE'RE UNABLE TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT SERVICES TO STABILIZE
AND THEIR CURRENT SETTING. AND
PART OF THIS FOR A COUNTY REALLY
IS THE LACK OF SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
AYE SFC HOMES AND I COUNTY OR
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE HOMES IN
OUR COUNTY.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES THEY HAVE A
FEW BUT THEY'RE FULLY UTILIZED
BY THOSE COUNTIES.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS AND
NINE CENTRAL VALLEY COUNTIES OUT
OF GOTTEN TOGETHER TO REALLY
LOOK AT AND WAY OUR NEEDS VERSUS
OUR RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES TO
INTENSIVE SERVICE HOMES. AND
WE'VE COME UP WITH AN ESTIMATED
NEED A FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
HOMES AND CURRENTLY WE HAVE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN. SO WE HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
NEEDS MET AND WHEN WE LOOKED AT
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE WHEN WE
LOOKED AT SUFFICIENT S. THE RTP
IS WHEN ABOUT THE SAME.
LEVEL SO ARE. IT WOULD WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE A
PLACEMENT OPTIONS.
PART OF IT IS FOR US BEEN KINGS
COUNTY WE WERE TRYING TO PLACE A
CHILD IF WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
PLACE IN COUNTY WITH AN RFA. UP
WE ARE LOOKING IMMEDIATELY TO
FRESNO AND TULARE GROUP HOMES
BECAUSE IN OUR COUNTY WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY STR TEEPEES AND HAVE
ONLY A SINGLE GROUP HOME. WAIT
THAT SERVES VERY SPECIALIZED
POPULATION.
AND A PART OF MY CONCERN REALLY
IS WHAT THAT TRANSLATES INTO IS
WHILE WE'RE DOING THIS REALLY IN
A MULTIPLE LEVEL IMPLEMENTATION
OF.
CCR DEBTS WAY BEYOND JUST THE
PLACEMENT IS THAT AT THE MOMENT
WHEN WE'RE SEARCHING FOR
PLACEMENT WHERE PLACING KIDS IN
UP HERE IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
AND WHAT HAPPENS M. IN THOSE
INSTANCES IS WE REALLY THEN END
UP WITH MULTIPLE PLACEMENTS
WHICH WE THEN RE TRAUMATIZE. WE
END UP.
REALLY DEFLATING ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES BECAUSE WILL WE ARE
MOVING KIDS CONSTANTLY THERE'S
JUST NO THERE'S REALLY NO REAL.
CAPACITY TO KEEP THOSE SERVICES
GOING SO DELAYS OF REUNIFICATION
DELAYS CARE WE EXPOSE KIDS TO
SELF HARM AND QUITE HONESTLY
HAVE EXPOSED OUR SOCIAL WORKERS.
DID THE SAME THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THAT WE HAD A SOCIAL WORKER
HEARD BY A CHILD. IS.
WAIT HAS HAPPENED WAY TOO
FREQUENTLY IN THE PAST YEAR.
AND WHILE I THINK OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE GREAT THEY REALLY DO
NOT HAVE THE SKILL SET TO A
TIME.
UP PART OF THE OTHER ITEMS
SITUATIONS WE'VE ENCOUNTERED IS
WHEN WE UTILIZE OUR A PHASE THAT
REALLY STEP UP AND WANT TO HELP.
BUT WHEN THEY'RE NOT CAPABLE OF
TAKING CARE OF AT PROVIDING
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES WHERE THAN
DESTROYING THAT RELATIONSHIP AS
WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE REALIZING
THAT THEY CANNOT.
SERVE THE KIDS THE WAY THEY ARE.
YOU AND A STEP AWAY SO THEM LOSE
A RESOURCE THAT OURS REALLY HARD
TO FIND AND AND WE'VE WORKED
THROUGH TO PUT THROUGH AND I
THINK PROCESS.
UP AND AT THE END OF THAT OF
CERTAINLY NOT COUNTY IN A NUMBER
OF OTHERS WE'VE ENDED UP WITH
KIDS AND ON THE GROUP HOME
PLACEMENTS. THAT ARE ARTISTS THE
GROUP HOME PLACEMENT AND
CURRENTLY I HAVE COUPLE KIDS IN
THAT SITUATION. AND WHILE
THEY'RE DOING BETTER WHERE
THEY'RE AT ON I'M HAVE A HUGE
CONCERN OF THOSE FACILITIES HAVE
NOT EVEN STARTED THE TRANSITION
TO AT THE ACTIVITIES.
SO AM I DON'T WANNA SOUND WILL
ALONG I DON'T WANNA MAKE IT
SOUND LIKE SEVERELY DIRE BUT A
VERY BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD EFFORT THAT'S
HAPPENING ON ABSOLUTELY GRATEFUL
THAT WE WERE AN EARLY RFA
IMPLEMENTER BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE
CAN TURN AROUND AND REALLY FOCUS
ON. OUR OUR IF FOUR EYES THAT
SEE HOMES AND I'M REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF CDSS ARM GETTING
A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN AN OF.
RALLYING THE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO DO A STATEWIDE RFPS
AND OUR THIGHS FOR SERVICES TO
YOUTH THAT ARE OF BOTH
DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED AND HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES OR TO SIR
RC SEC YOUTH. BECAUSE AT FROM A
STATE BY PERSPECTIVE THAT
SERVICES POSSIBLE TO GARNER AT
THE COUNTY OUR SIZE WE WOULD
NEVER BE ABLE TO CREATE CAPACITY
AND KEEP SOMETHING LIKE THAT
GOING JUST WITHIN A SINGLE
COUNTY LEVEL. PART OF THE ISSUES
REALLY THE TIMING WHERE WE ARE
CURRENTLY SO THAT'S AYE AYE.
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND ECHO THAT
CONCERNED THAT WHERE WE ARE NOW
IT DOES NOT SEEM LIKE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO UP MEET
ALL THE NEEDS WE HAVE.
SO I. THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME OR
SITE AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT BEEN.
APPROVED SO FAR FOR THIS
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
PATTERSON BAR LOW ANGIE SPORTS
AND SUSANNA. NEFYN IF WE CAN
MAKE A
WE HAVE ONE EXTRA CHAIR SO
DESTINY ADAMS YOU CAN COME UP AS
WELL
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY MISS PART OF
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KRISTIN
BARLOWE AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO. SHARE
WITH YOU WHAT THE EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN SO FAR OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNTERPARTS
AND TO THE INDIVIDUALS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND JUST WANTED TO START BY
SAYING THAT THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LEADERS IN OUR
STATE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
INTENT IN GOALS BEHIND CC ARE.
WE AGREE COMPLETELY THAT TO
PROMOTE THE EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
OF CHILDREN HAVING THEM BE IN A
FAMILY LIKE SETTING WITH THE
SUPPORTIVE AND CARING ADULTS
REALLY IS AND IN THEIR BEST
INTERESTS. AS WELL AS TO ENSURE
THAT FOR THOSE AFFECTED BY
TRAUMA THAT THEY GET THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT WILL REALLY
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS.
AND ANOTHER THING WE HAVE IN
COMMON I THINK WITH OUR TRIAL
OFFER COUNTERPARTS ITS
FAMILIARITY WITH THE
UNACCEPTABLE PHENOMENON OF
FAILING UP OR FAILING FIRST IN
ORDER TO GET CARE. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HISTORICALLY IN
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WE HAVE
A CHILDREN SYSTEM OF CARE ACT
THAT GOES BACK ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS. GIVEN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WHICH GOES BACK
AROUND FOURTEEN YEARS WITHIN
THAT.
ARE REALLY GOALS AROUND KEEPING
PEOPLE INCLUDING CHILDREN IN
HOME IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND AS NORMAL A LIFE.
AS ANY ONE OF US WOULD EVER
WANT TO HAVE SO THOSE CONCEPTS
ARE CERTAINLY NOT NEW TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WE TOTALLY
EMBRACE THOSE GOALS OF THAT CCR
INITIATIVE.
THEY WOULD SAY THAT IN TERMS OF.
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS ROLES ARE CC ARE
IT DOESN'T ALTOGETHER CHANGE OUR
EXPECTATIONS FOR SERVING MENTAL
HEALTH CARE BUT IT DOES I THINK.
CREATE SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US TO PROVIDE MORE ROBUST CARE
AND MORE COLLABORATIVE CARE AND
PART WITH CHILD WELFARE IN
PROBATION AND AS YOU WELL KNOW
AND FROM THE HEARING EARLIER
THIS WEEK. THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AROUND OUR
STATE HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
ALREADY TO PROVIDE SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO KIDS
AS PART OF THEIR EP STT MENTAL
HEALTH BENEFIT IN THESE CHILDREN
HAVE MEDI CAL IS THE COVERAGE
SO.
THEY ARE OUR KIDS THEY'RE NOT
SIMPLY THAT SYSTEMS OR THOSE.
.
HOWEVER A LOT OF THE ATTENDANCE
OF CC ARE REALLY BUILD UPON
THINGS THAT THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
WAS MOVING TOWARD BECAUSE OF
ACADIE A LAWSUIT. AND IN
PARTICULAR THERE ARE THREE TYPES
OF SERVICES THAT ARE
COMPLEMENTARY I THINK TO THE
GOALS OF CCR.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
THOSE TECHNICALLY BUT.
DON'T WANNA FOR A BUNCH OF
ACRONYMS THAT YOU I'M JUST TO
SAY THAT THOSE THREE SERVICES
REALLY ALREADY BEGIN TO BUILD
THE FOUNDATION FOR EXPECTING
THAT CHILDREN GET CARE IN HOME
BASED SETTINGS. THAT WE HAVE
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE PARENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN SPECIALLY TRAINED
TO TAKE HIGHER NEED.
CHILDREN INTO THEIR HOME AND
THAT WE SUPPORT THEM NOT. LEAVE
THEM THERE AND HOPE FOR THE BEST
BUT THAT WE'RE DOING THINGS
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF SUPPORTING
NOT ONLY THE CHILD BUT THE
CAREGIVER. AND IS WELL INTENSIVE
CASE COORDINATION WHERE WE'RE
WORKING ALONGSIDE OUR PARTNERS
NOT JUST MEETING THE THERAPEUTIC
NEEDS BUT REALLY LOOKING AT A
PARTNERSHIP MODEL. SO AS A
RESULT OF CC ARE THERE ARE THREE
THINGS THAT THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE BEING
TASKED TO PROVIDE AND WE DO
SUBSTANTIALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION INCLUDED
STATE GENERAL FUNDS. IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET FOR US TO
IMPLEMENT THESE THINGS OF THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
WILL BE REIMBURSED BASED ON
THEIR CLAIMS FOR THESE THREE NEW
AREAS. ONE OF THEM IS THAT AS
I'M TO THE EXTENT WE ARE THE
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIAN FOR A
CHILD. AND THE FACT THAT EVERY
CHILD WILL HAVE A CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM WHO MEETS TO
DISCUSS.
THAT CHILD'S NEEDS THE MENTAL
HEALTH STAFF WILL BE A PART OF
THOSE MEETINGS AND I HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN TO BE A PART OF
THOSE MEETINGS.
WE ALSO ARE ASKED TO DO MENTAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS FOR ANY CHILD
PRIOR TO THEM BEING PLACED IN
ONE OF THE SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS.
AND THEN LASTLY.
AND PROBABLY AN AREA OF A LOT
OF.
LEARNING CURVING GROWTH FOR OUR
PROVIDER COMMUNITY IS MEDI CAL
CERTIFICATION SO TO ENSURE THAT
ON THE SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS AND THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES WHO ARE
OVERSEEING THESE THERAPEUTIC
FOSTER CARE HOMES.
BUT THOSE THINGS ARE WHICH ARE
MEDI CAL BILLABLE AND SPECIALTY
MINIMAL SERVICES CAN IN FACT BE
REIMBURSED WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S MATCHING FUNDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO US SO. THAT'S A
BIG AREA OF LEARNING HOW TO
DOCUMENT AND AND DO THINGS THAT
ARE.
YOU KNOW AND IN SOME CASES MUCH
MORE BUREAUCRATIC THAN WHAT WE
MIGHT THINK OF AS WHAT YOU DO TO
PROVIDE A LOVING HOME FOR A
CHILD BUT THEY ARE NOT SUCH A
NECESSARY FOR US TO MAXIMIZE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH WE CAN DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR THESE
THINGS.
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I THINK
WE WANT A HIGH LATER GOING
PARTICULARLY WELL.
WHEN WHICH I KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS HEARD ME SAY IN
OTHER VENUES SAYS HOW IMPRESSED
OUR.
DIRECTORS ARE IN THE SOUTH OF
OUR ASSOCIATION WITH THE LEVEL
OF TIME A COMMITMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS REALLY. PUT FORTH ON TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR VISION
ACTUALLY HAS A CHANCE OF GETTING
ACCOMPLISHED AND REALLY TAKING A
VERY I'M COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
DOING ONE ON ONE PHONE CALLS
WITH COUNTIES AND. THE DIRECTOR
HIMSELF.
REALLY SPENDING THE TIME ON OF
YOU KNOW BI WEEKLY BASIS WITH A
TEAM OF PEOPLE THAT INCLUDES US
I'M INVITING INTO THE DEPARTMENT
A CONSULTANT. FROM OUR
ASSOCIATION TO REALLY BE THE
EYES AND EARS OF MENTAL HEALTH
WITHIN THIS CONTEXT
AND REALLY TRYING TO
TROUBLESHOOT IN. VERY EARNESTLY
THE ISSUES THAT SOMETIMES.
ARISE AND CONTINUE TO RISE I'M
SOMETIMES DAILY.
ABOUT THINGS WE HEAR ARE GOING
WELL OR NOT SO WELL IN COUNTIES
AND REALLY TRYING TO SOLVE THOSE
PROBLEMS RATHER THAN TAKE A
PUNITIVE APPROACH.
IS REALLY KIND OF UNPRECEDENTED
AND I ALSO THINK THAT IN TERMS
OF CHALLENGES WE NEED TO YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION TO THOSE THAT
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT FROM THE
CHILD WELFARE AND PERSPECTIVE.
.
BUDGETING AND PLANNING FOR THIS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT THE PLACERS OF
CHILDREN INTO THE SETTINGS
HOWEVER WE ARE THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS WANTS THOSE PLACEMENTS
OCCUR. AND BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
QUITE SURE HOW MANY OF THESE
SHORT TERM THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
OR THERAPEUTIC FOSTER PARENTS
WILL END UP BEING RECRUITED.
IT'S UNCERTAIN YET HAS TO THE
VOLUME OF SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH THAT WILL COME ALONG WITH
THOSE TYPES OF PLACEMENTS BEING
UTILIZED.
ANDADDITIONALLY I WOULD JUST
SAY THERE ARE.
ALREADY EXISTING CHALLENGES ON
TOP OF WHICH CECE ARE OPERATES
SO AND YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AND THAT.
CCR WILL BE IMPACTED BY NOTABLY
YOU KNOW THE WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
NOT ONLY FOR SOCIAL WORKERS IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM BUT
CERTAINLY IN THE HEALTH CARE
WORLD. A LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIANS AND TO SERVE PEOPLE
AND PARTICULARLY CLINICIANS WHO
HAVE A SPECIALIZATION OF
CHILDREN OR PSYCHIATRISTS WHO
HAVE A SPECIALIZATION CHILDREN.
WE KNOW THAT WE DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH STANDARDIZE STATEWIDE
TIMELINESS EXPECTATIONS FOR WHEN
A REFERRAL.
OR APPOINTMENT IS REQUESTED OF
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AND WE ARE
MOVING TOWARD A STATEWIDE
STANDARD FOR WHAT'S CONSIDERED
TIMELY AND WILL BE STARTING TO
TRACK HOW COUNTIES ARE DOING IN
THEIR PROVIDERS ARE DOING AND.
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AND AND
HOPING THAT THEY ADDRESS THAT
WHEN WE SEE THAT THERE ARE.
SHORTFALLS AND HOW QUICKLY
YOU'RE RESPONDING TO THE NEEDED
IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
I THINK AS WELL AND I MENTIONED
THIS I'M EARLIER THIS WEEK ON
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THE EXTENT
TO WHICH.
OUR PARTNERS EXPERIENCE A
COUNTY BY COUNTY SIDE OF
VARIATIONS.
IS ALSO A CHALLENGE WERE WERE
READY TO TRY TO FIND WAYS TO
ADDRESS THERE CERTAINLY
EXPECTATIONS THAT SHOULD FALL ON
EVERY SINGLE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN THAT WE. CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND BUT THE REALITIES OF
RESOURCES WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
AND JUST PHYSICAL LOCATION.
DO SOMETIMES LEND THEMSELVES TO
UNFORTUNATE.
DIFFERENCES FROM ONE COUNTY TO
THE NEXT AS TO HOW QUICKLY YOU
CAN GET CARE AND FOR EXAMPLE
WHAT CREATIVE MODELS AND THEY
MIGHT HAVE VOLUNTARILY PUT IN
PLACE WHERE AS OTHERS HAD NOT.
FOUND.
AND THEN I THINK WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE LINKAGES THAT WE
HOPE OCCUR WHEN A CHILD WELFARE
WORKER PROBATION STAFF SEE A
MENTAL HEALTH CONCERN. MAKE A
REFERRAL TO.
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AND WHAT
HAPPENS AT THAT POINT WE KNOW
THAT SOME
ADEQUATE ENGAGEMENT. A LACK OF
CULTURAL COMPETENCY FOR THAT
CHILD'S WAS THAT STIGMA ON THE
PART OF THE CHILD'S CAREGIVER
AND NOT REALLY WANTING. THEM TO
BE IDENTIFIED AS SOMEONE WHO
NEEDS EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THERE'S
ANY NUMBER OF OF REASONS.
THAT THAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN A
BREAKDOWN SO WERE TRYING TO LEAN
IN.
AND RATHER THAN DEFEND AND TRY
TO UNDERSTAND WHEN THINGS DON'T
GO WELL HOW CAN WE PREVENT THOSE
THINGS FROM HAPPENING AN EAGLE
HERE LATER AND PERHAPS RIGHT
ABOUT NOW. ABOUT.
A PROPOSAL THAT WERE CO
SPONSORING WITH THE WELFARE
DIRECTORS IN CHILDREN NOW TO AS
WELL COMPLEMENT THIS IDEA THAT
WHEN THINGS ARE IN A CRISIS
MODE.
WITHIN THE HOME.
WE WANT SAID.
IMMEDIATELY RESPOND.
NOT HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT CALLED
BUT INSTEAD HAVE SUPPORTIVE
INDIVIDUALS THERE TO SUPPORT THE
CRISIS THAT OCCURS FOR
CAREGIVERS AND AND CHILDREN AND
TRY TO REDUCE THE. FILE LIKELY
HAD THAT THAT PLACEMENT DISRUPTS
IN THAT AGAIN WE'RE NOT FEELING
UP AND THAT THE CHILD'S
EXPERIENCE IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
PARLOR NEXT WILL HAVE MISSED
FORT.
GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ANGIE SHORTS WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE IS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN IN THEIR FIRST
PLACEMENT CHILDREN SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO BE MOVED TO A DIFFERENT
HOME IN ORDER TO GET APPROPRIATE
FUNDING AND SERVICES.
TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
HAVE TAKEN CRITICAL STOPS
TO FIX OUR BROKEN RATE SYSTEM.
CHILDREN PLACED WITH RELATIVES
NOW HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO FUNDING
AS NON RELATIVES.
AND THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW TIERED RATE
SYSTEM TIED TO THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILD.
AND TO BE CLEAR WE FULLY SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT TIERED
RATE SYSTEM IT IS EXACTLY THE
WORK WE SHOULD BE DOING.
THE PROBLEM IS THE PROTOCOL THAT
HAS BEEN DEVELOPED TO DETERMINE
THE CHILD'S TEAR. HAS NEVER BEEN
PILOTED OR STUDIED TO DETERMINE
ITS ACCURACY.
AND YET AT THIS POINT IT APPEARS
THERE IS NO PLAN TO DELAY
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION BEYOND
MAY FIRST THE ONLY THING WE KNOW
FROM A LIMITED STUDY. TO
DETERMINE THE DISTRIBUTION OF
YOUTH ACROSS THE DIFFERENT
LEVELS IS THAT ONLY ONE PERCENT
OF YOU SCORED A LEVEL FOR THE
HIGHEST OF THE BASIC LEVELS.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS THE
RIGHT ONE PERCENT AND WE DON'T
KNOW IF MORE THAN ONE PERCENT OF
YOUTH SHOULD HAVE BEEN SCORED
AND LEVEL FOR. WE DON'T KNOW IF
THE PROTOCOL CONSISTENTLY SCORES
YOUTH WITH HIGHER NEEDS IN THE
HIGHER LEVELS WE DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'D STEPPING DOWN FROM GROUP
HOME SCORING TO HIGHER LEVELS.
WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN NO ATTEMPT TO ASSESS THE
ACCURACY OF THE TOOL OR WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S WAITED PROPERLY.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TOOLS RELIABILITY CDSS CONDUCTED
A VERY LIMITED STUDY OF
RELIABILITY WERE THIRTEEN CASES
WERE SCORED.
BY TWO DIFFERENT WORKERS AND IT
REVEALED THAT THE SAME CHILD WHO
SCORED A DIFFERENT LEVEL FORTY
SIX PERCENT OF THE TIME. THEY
GIVE ME A LITTLE CONFIDENCE.
FINALLY COUNTIES ARE BEING
REQUIRED TO CHANGE THEIR
SPECIALIZED CARE PLANS BUT
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO CONFORM THE
SPECIALIZED CARE PLANTS TO THE
NEW LEVEL OF CARE SYSTEM IS NOT
FINALIZED. AND NO COUNTY IS
GOING TO BE READY TO IMPLEMENT
BY MAY FIRST AND WE NEED ALL OF
OUR COUNTIES TO BE READY TO GO
WITH NEW PLANS BEFORE WE
IMPLEMENT BECAUSE CHILDREN MOVE
ACROSS COUNTY LINES. SO WE CAN'T
BE A TIERED LIKE SOME COUNTIES
CAN BE READY WHILE OTHER
COUNTIES ARE NOT READY. GIVEN
ALL OF THIS IN JANUARY CDSS
AGREED TO DELAY STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH HAD BEEN
SET TO TAKE EFFECT ON FEBRUARY
FIRST.
INTEL MAY AND TO STUDY BOTH THE
ACCURACY AND RELIABILITY OF THE
TOOL BY ROLLING IT OUT IN FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY HOMES IN MARCH AND
APRIL.
AFTER PHASE ARE THE PERFECT
PLACE TO TEST THE TOOL BECAUSE
THOSE HOMES DON'T GET
SPECIALIZED CARE.
HOWEVER THAT MAY ONE DEADLINE
HAS PROVEN TO AGGRESSIVE DESPITE
PROMISING TO ASSESS BOTH
RELIABILITY AND ACCURACY THE
STUDY UNDER WAY IS ONLY LOOKING
AT THE RELIABILITY OF THE TOOL.
THERE IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TIME
TO DO THE MOST THE MORE ROBUST
STUDY OF THE TOOLS VALIDITY.
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION BEFORE
THE TOOL IS FULLY TESTED AND
BEFORE ALL COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
SPECIALIZED CARE PLANS IN PLACE
WILL RESULT IN BACKLOG DELAY
ERRONEOUS ASSESSMENTS PLACEMENT
DISRUPTIONS AND STRESS ON OUR
FAMILIES.
OUR FAMILIES CARE FOR REAL
CHILDREN IN REAL TIME AND NEED
TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON ACCURATE
AND RELIABLE RATES TO DECIDE SO.
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROTOCOL
INTEL IT'S TESTED FOR VALIDITY
AND RELIABILITY UNTIL
APPROPRIATE CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE AND COUNTIES HAVE TIME TO
TRAIN AND PROP STAFF ON THE NEW
PROTOCOLS ONCE THEY'RE
FINALIZED.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION OF
OUR REQUEST THANK YOU MISTER
SCHWARZENEGGER'S WE HAVE MISSED
NOTHING.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO KNOW FIRST
THE TICKET.
GOOD AFTERNOON. UP MY NAME IS
PRETTY GOLDBERG AND I LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO BEGIN MY REMARKS BY THANKING
YOU THE LEGISLATURE FOR
RECOGNIZING THE IMMEDIATE NEED
FOR INTERIM SOLUTION TO PROVIDE
FUNDING AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT
THROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TEN.
I KNOW FIRST HAND HOW CRITICAL
FUNDING SUPPORT AND SERVICES ARE
FOR CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE.
UNABLE SIX TWENTY SEVENTEEN I
RECEIVED A CALL FROM MY DAUGHTER
THE CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES
HAD MY GRANDSON AND THEY WERE
BRINGING HIM TO ME. A FEW WEEKS
LATER HE WAS FINALLY PLACE IN MY
HOME.
AT THAT MOMENT I STARTED WORKING
TO COMPLETE THE TRAINING AND
OTHER REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS.
I WAS CONCERNED THAT IF I DID
NOT FINISH IN NINETY DAYS AS I
HAVE BEEN TOLD I WOULD NOT BE
APPROVED AND SO I DID EVERYTHING
I DID. EVERYTHING I COULD
POSSIBLE TO GET APPROVED A
SWIFTLY AS POSSIBLE.
STILL IT TOOK MUCH LONGER THAN
NINETY DAYS TO GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS
THE RFA PROCESS IS COMPLICATED
AND CONFUSING.
I WAS ULTIMATELY APPROVED
ON OCTOBER TENTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT WAS A FULL SIX
MONTHS AFTER STARTING THE
PROCESS.
AND I FINALLY STARTED RECEIVING
FUNDING IN LATE NOVEMBER.
THAT WAS ONE MONTH THE FOR MY
GRANDSON WAS RETURNED TO MY
DAUGHTER.
NOT RECEIVING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SEVEN MONTHS
WHILE CARING FOR MY GRANDSON WAS
VERY HARD ON ME.
I AM BLESSED I HAVE FAMILY
FRIENDS AND CO WORKERS WHO ALL
STOOD UP AND HELP ME WITH MEALS
GROCERIES BABY SUPPLIES AND MOST
OF ALL THEIR TIME.
BUT EVEN WITH THAT HELP I
STRUGGLED
I AM AN HOURLY EMPLOYEE SO EVERY
TIME I HAD TO GO INTO WORK LATE.
OR MISS A DAY TO MEET WITH
ANOTHER SOCIAL WORKER WHO MOSTLY
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE I HAD A
CRIB.
A REPRESENTATIVE FOR ANY OTHER
SERVICE OR GO TO COURT I LOST
TIME FROM WORK LOST TIME IS LOST
MONEY.
THIS MEANS LESS OF A FINANCIAL
ABILITY TO CARE FOR MY GRANDSON.
HAVING RECEIVED NO FUNDS I WAS
AFFECTED BY AFFECTED NOT JUST ME
BUT ALL OF US AND FOR WAY TOO
LONG.
THAT'S SO I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
TAKING IMMEDIATE ACTION TO HELP
THE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WHO
ARE FACED WITH THIS FINANCIAL
CRISIS. AS THEY TRIED TO HOLD
THEIR FAMILIES TOGETHER.
AB ONE TEN TOOK EFFECT RIGHT
AWAY TO PROVIDE FAMILY STILL
WORKING THROUGH THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS
TO ACCESS FUNDING AS OF MARCH
THIRTIETH.
BY PROVIDING THAT FINANCIAL HELP
THESE FAMILIES STILL WORKING
THROUGH THE PROCESS YOU ARE
HELPING PROVIDE STABILITY TO THE
RELATIVES IN THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE.
HOWEVER WITHOUT FURTHER ACTION
BY THE LEGISLATURE THAT FUNDING
ENDS ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
THE SUPPORT IS NOW AVAILABLE TO
FAMILIES WHO ACCEPT THE
EMERGENCY PLACEMENT PRIOR TO
BEING APPROVED AS A RESOURCE
FAMILY IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE THE PROVIDE THAT
FUNDING AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT
BEYOND JUNE THIRTIETH SO THAT NO
FAMILY. EVER HAS TO GO THROUGH
WHAT I WENT THROUGH.
AND REQUIRE THAT LONG TERM
SOLUTION THAT IS ADOPTED TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO GAP IN
FUNDING WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TEN EXPIRES AND THE NEW LONG
TERM SOLUTION BEGINS.
IF THESE REQUESTS BECOME REALITY
FAMILIES WILL BE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON WHAT MEANS MOST TO THEM THEIR
CHILDREN LIKE MY GRANDSON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU ALL TODAY AND
SHARE MY STORY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
CONTINUE FUNDING AT THE TIME
PLACE.
THANK YOU MONTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
SUSANNAH NOTHIN AYE WITH
CHILDREN NOW I'M HERE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM. AND THAT IS AS HE BEACH
DAC WTA AND CHILDREN NOW.
CCR ENVISIONED THAT ALL FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR CAREGIVERS WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO MEDIA AND
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES REGARDLESS OF PLACEMENT
SETTING. UNFORTUNATELY CCR HAS
NOT YET CREATED A STRUCTURE TO
MEET THE URGENT NEEDS OF YOUTH
AND THEIR CAREGIVERS AT THE TIME
THAT AN EMOTIONAL CRISIS ARISES.
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM WOULD PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AND MEDIA RESPONSE FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES PROVIDED BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SPECIALLY
TRAINED TO PROVIDE TRAUMA BASED
SUPPORT AND CRISIS INTERVENTION.
THE CENTRAL GATEWAY TO THE LOCAL
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN RESPONSE WOULD
BE A STATE LEVEL HOTLINE TO
RESPOND TO CALLS FOR ASSISTANCE
AND A WARM HAND OFF TO COUNTY
BASED MOBILE RESPONSE TEAMS. TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON DE ESCALATION
AND SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND
CAREGIVER.
ONCE THE RESPONSES MADE THIS
TEAM WOULD THEN LINK THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY TO THE EXISTING
CONTINUUM OF LOCAL SERVICES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL
OF US TO UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN A
YOUNG PERSON ENTERS THE HOME OF
A CARE GIVER IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING FOR THEM BOTH TO
BUILD A NEW RELATIONSHIP. YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH HAVING
TO ADJUST TO A NEW HOME TO NEW
CAREGIVER TO HEAL FROM THEIR
GRIEF AND LOSS OF BEING REMOVED
FROM THEIR FAMILIES. AND TO
BEGIN TO HEAL FROM THE TRAUMA OF
THAT THE USE AND NEGLECT THAT
THEY WENT THROUGH. AT THE SAME
TIME CAREGIVERS HAVE OPENED
THEIR HOMES AND THEIR HEARTS TO
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
DESPERATELY WANT TO DO RIGHT BY
THEM OFTEN FEEL ALONE AS THEY
TRY TO DEVELOP A LEASH
RELATIONSHIP AND BUILD TRUST.
NAVIGATING TRAUMA DUES TRIGGERS.
AND THEY OFTEN FEEL ALONE IS
THEY DO THESE THINGS.
AND TALKING WITH YOU THINK
CAREGIVERS ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
OF BUILDING THIS NEW
RELATIONSHIP THEY OFTEN ASK IF
THERE'S SOMEONE THEY CAN CALL.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT OR IN
THE MIDDLE OF A TRICKY SITUATION
TO GET SUPPORT.
A TWENTY FOUR HOUR HOTLINE AND
COORDINATED MOBILE RESPONSE WILL
PROVIDE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITH THE PLACE TO TURN AND
MOMENTS OF UNCERTAINTY HELP
IMPROVE PLACEMENT STABILITY
REDUCE THE IMPORT AN APPROPRIATE
USE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO MANAGE
THE SITUATIONS. I CONNECT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
CAREGIVERS TO BENEFICIAL
SERVICES THAT WILL ALLOW FOSTER
CHILDREN TO HEAL AND THRIVE IN
FAMILY HOMES INSTEAD OF
INSTITUTIONS.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT WE WILL HILL HERE FROM
SHARON THE WAY THAT THAT'S OUR
HERNANDEZ AND LUCY SALCEDO.
CARTER
.
WHEN YOU READY SHARON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHARON
TO WAIT AND I'M A SUPERVISOR
CHILDREN SOCIAL WORKER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN LA COUNTY.
I WORK IN THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL DIVISION I AM ALSO A
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD FOR. SEVEN TWO
ONE THAT'S THE UNION AND LA
COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
BEHALF OF SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
AS WELL AS OUR CLIENTS IN
REGARDS TO CONTINUING CARE
REFORM AND THE IMPACT THAT THE
BUDGET HAS ON OUR CLIENTS.
I WORKED IN A MULTITUDE OF
CAPACITIES IN DCFS.
DUST MITES ARE CHAO PROTECTIVE
AGENCY ONE OF THOSE CAPACITIES
ARE ROLES WAS AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WORKER WHICH IDEA FOR
FOUR YEARS WHICH I WAS ACTUALLY
IN CHARGE OF INVESTIGATING
ALLEGATIONS OF CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT. AND REMOVING CHILDREN
FROM THEIR HOMES.
MOST OF THE TIMES WHEN I MEET
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF THE CHILD
WELFARE HUMAN SERVICES WORLD.
AND I TELL THEM THAT I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER THEY EITHER.
AT SHOT LIGHT WOW THAT'S WHAT
YOU ACTUALLY DO FOR A LIVING. OR
SOME OF THEM ACTUALLY GET ANGRY
WITH ME AND THEY STEP AWAY
BECAUSE I'M AS YOU KNOW LIKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CHAO PROTECTION
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE THE BEST
REPUTATION. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
SPEAKING ABOUT BEING A SOCIAL
WORKER.
BUT MOST OF MY FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS WOULD USUALLY BE CUT BE
CONCERNED AN AX ME ISN'T IT A
DANGEROUS ROLE IN A DANGEROUS
JOB.
FOR ME IT WAS IN A DANGEROUS
JOB JUST BECAUSE I LOVE THE KEY
IT SO MUCH AND I REALLY PUT A
LOT OF LOVING CARE TO WHAT I DO.
BUT I DO REMEMBER A STORY OF A
CHILD NAMED LITTLE TEA AT WHICH
IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS I HAD EVER BEEN IN MY
LIFE.
IT WAS A REFERRAL FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IT WAS AN IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE REFERRAL.
IN WHICH A NEIGHBORHOOD JUST
CAUGHT IN A NON AS WE HAVE SAID
THAT THE MOTHER WAS BEING BE.
ANY DOES A ONE SENTENCE ON THE
REFERRAL THE MOTHER IS BEING
BEAT AND I HAD TO ADDRESS.
SO WHEN I RESPONDED TO THE AT
HOME I INTERVIEWED LITTLE T. WHO
WAS NINE YEARS SO.
AND HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT MY
FATHER GETS OUT OF JAIL HE'S
GOING TO BEAT UP MY MOTHER'S
BOYFRIEND AND I SAY WELL WHY
WOULD HE DO THAT. ANY SAID
BECAUSE MY MOTHER IS BEING BEAT
EVERY NIGHT.
AND HE SAID ANDTHERE'S NOTHING
I CAN DO ABOUT IT BECAUSE I'M
TOO LITTLE.
AND SO I SPOKE TO THE MOM AND I
SPOKE TO THE BOYFRIEND AND IN
THAT ENVIRONMENT I WAS
TERRIFIED.
I CAN'T REALLY DESCRIBE JUST
THE BOYFRIENDS AGGRESSION
TOWARDS THE MOM AND THE BEHAVIOR
AND I WAS THERE BY MYSELF I
DIDN'T HAVE THE POLICE.
AND SO.
EVEN EVEN THOUGH APARTMENT
NEIGHBORS WERE RUNNING THROUGH
ME SAYING PLEASE HELP THIS
LITTLE BOY BECAUSE HE SOMETIMES
KNOCKS ON OUR DOOR FOR FOOD.
ALLMAN HE SOMETIMES KNOCKS ON
OUR DOOR SAYING CAN YOU SPEND
THE NIGHT BECAUSE HIS MOM IS
BEING ABUSED.
I'M HIS MAMA SOMETIMES PASSED
OUT AN APARTMENT FROM BEING
KNOCKED OUT BY THE BOYFRIEND.
AND SO BECAUSE I DID NOT HAVE
EXIGENCY TO REMOVE THAT SHOUT IN
THAT SITUATION BECAUSE DANGER
WAS NOT HAPPEN AT THAT MOMENT
EVEN THOUGH I FELT A FREE. I'M I
ACTUALLY HAD TO GET A WARRANT
REMOVAL ORDER TO COME BACK WITH
THE POLICE.
IT'S REMOVED THIS CHILD.
I ACTUALLY HAD A INTER WITH ME
ALSO SO THAT IT CAN BE A
LEARNING EXPERIENCE WITH HER AND
I HAVE ONE LAW WHOM I HAD A
POLICE OFFICER WITH ME.
THE BOYFRIEND JUMPED OUT OF A
TWO STORY WINDOW WHEN HE'S HEARD
THE POLICE KNOCKED ON THE DOOR.
AND WHEN WE WALKED INTO THE
APARTMENT THE MOM WAS ALREADY
PACKING THE CHILD'S BANKS
BECAUSE THE NEIGHBORHOOD CAUGHT
TOLD HER THAT WE WERE COMING TO
TAKE HER SON.
WHEN I SPOKE THE WORDS THAT I AM
REMOVING YOU FROM YOUR MOTHER
AND YOUR GOING TO BE PLACED IN A
FOSTER HOME.
THIS CHILD SCREAMS SO LOUD NO
SOUND CAME OUT OF HIS MOUTH.
I WILL NEVER FORGET IT HIS HEART
BROKE.
INTO A MILLION PIECES.
WHEN I LOOK BACK AT MY INTERN
SHE WAS IN TEARS.
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE POLICE OFFICER THAT WAS
WITH ME ACTUALLY STEPPED OUT OF
THE HOME BECAUSE HE WAS ALSO
CRYING.
THIS IS THE POLICE OFFICER.
I COULD NOT CRY AND I TOLD
MYSELF NOT TO CRY.
BECAUSE AT THAT TIME I HAVE TO
PROVIDE THE CHILD WITH THE
SUPPORT THAT HE NEEDED IN THE
COMPASSIONATE HE NEEDED I
COULDN'T BREAK DOWN MYSELF.
THE MOTHER HAD NO AFFECT.
HE GAVE ME HIS CLOTHES SHE DID
NOT HURT HIM SHE DID NOT KISS
HIM.
SHE DID NOT TAKE THE FOSTER
PARENTS PHONE NUMBER TO CALL
HIM.
AFTER I REMOVED HIM SHE NEVER
SHOWED UP TO COURT.
SHE DID SHOW UP TO OUR OFFICE
AND AFTER WE HAD LEFT THE
BOYFRIEND CAME BACK AND
SPLITTERS GOLD OPEN.
SO SHE HAS STITCHES ALL IN HER
SCALP.
THEY SHOUT AT THE GO TO COURT
FOR SIX MONTHS.
AND EVERYTIME HE WENT TO COURT
HIS MOTHER WASN'T THERE.
TO SAY THE LEAST.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME EVERY
DAY IN MY AGENCY.
AND IS THE IMPACT
LAST MONTH JUST THE MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. EIGHT HUNDRED
CHILDREN WERE DETAINED FROM
THEIR PARENTS CUSTODY IN LA
COUNTY ALONE.
EIGHT HUNDRED.
GO THROUGH WITH THE SHOT WENT
THROUGH.
SO I SAY THAT AND I GIVE S. THE
WORRY JUST BECAUSE THESE KIDS
HAVE BEEN SO TRAUMATIZED FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THEY NEED SO MUCH CARE THEY NEED
SO MUCH SUPPORT.
THERAPY.
ARMED MENTORS
CEO OF TEAS
IT TAKES SO MUCH TO GET THEM IN
A PLACE TO WEAR THEIR STABLE I
FOR SOME OF THEM LIKE THE SHOUT
UNFORTUNATELY HE ENDED UP IN THE
PROBATION SYSTEM.
AND THEN ENDED UP IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM.
BECAUSE HE JUST COULD NOT YOU
KNOW.
RECOVER FROM THE TRAUMA THAT HE
HAD EXPERIENCE AND ABANDONMENT.
AND I ALWAYS THINK BACK TO HIS
SCREEN.
SCREEN WASN'T NECESSARILY ABOUT
ME TAKING HIM.
HIS SCREAM WAS ABOUT.
EVERYTHING THE HE HAD BEEN
THROUGH HIS LIFE THEY LEAD UP TO
ME TAKING HIM.
HE HAD HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
MOTHER BEING ABUSED ALL THAT
TIME AND THIS WAS LIKE THE FINAL
BLOW NOW YOU'RE BEING REMOVED
AND TAKEN TO A PLACE. WHERE YOU
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
GOING?
NOT ONLY DO WE REMOVE A LARGE
QUANTITY OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT NOW IN MY COUNTY THERE ARE
FIVE HUNDRED KEY IT'S WITHOUT
PLACEMENT AS OF APRIL NINTH
THERE IN LIMBO.
THEY ARE EITHER A WALL IN
SHELTER CARE OR IN A ON APPROVED
RELATIVE'S HOME.
WHERE THE RELATIVE WAS ACTUALLY
DID NOT BY OUR IF FATE BUT
THERE'S NO WHERE ELSE THE PLACE
THEM SO THEY'D BEEN LEFT THERE?
WHAT I'M ASKING TODAY AS A
SOCIAL WORKER THE PERSON WHO
CONNECTS THE CHAO TO ALL THAT
THE SERVICES THE PERSON TO
SCHEDULES THIS SEA OF TI'S
CONNECT THEM THE REGIONAL
CENTER?
CONNECT THEM TO THERAPY CONNECT
THEM TO THEIR MENTOR
SHOW UP TO COURT WHEN THE PARENT
DOESN'T SHOW UP TO COURT.
WE'RE ASKING DAY.
YOU GUYS INVEST BEFORE FIFTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT CCR IF YOU WANT
CHILDREN TO HAVE A SAFE HOME
WITH THE SUPPORT OF FAMILY. AND
UNDERSTAND IT TAKES RESOURCES TO
ACHIEVE THAT.
THAT RESOURCE INCLUDES MORE
SOCIAL WORKERS
THAT RESOURCE INCLUDING MORE
SERVICES FOR YOUTH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM FEAR POWERFUL.
NEXT WE HAVE MINISTER HERNANDEZ.
THINK KILL.
AS A HIT SIT HERE AND LISTEN.
I GET A LITTLE.
FLUSTERED I ALSO GREW UP IN
FOSTER CARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE STORIES.
THEY JUST SHARED IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT MY MEMBERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
IN MY CURRENT ROLE.
I WORK WITH KERN WARMER PASTA
IT'S A.
STEVE.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO BE ON.
I THINK THE.
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING IN
THE MIDDLE OF COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING AND.
IN THE POLICY WORLD.
I THINK IT.
I'M GOING.
OKAY. I'D LIKE TO HAVE COLLECT
MY THOUGHTS THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M MY NAME IS LUCY SALZEDO
CARTER I'M WITH THE YOUTH LAW
CENTER.
I'M WE ADVOCATE TO TRANSFORM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS THAT ALL
CHILDREN CAN THRIVE.
AND I DO WANT TO TAKE US BACK TO
FOR A MINUTE.
TO SOME OF THE WHAT THE
RESEARCHERS SAY. ON BECAUSE I DO
THINK WHEN THE GOING GETS TOUGH
IT'S GOOD TO REMEMBER WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS.
AND I'D LIKE TO JUST DO A
COUPLE OF SHORT QUOTES FROM THE
CONSENSUS STATEMENT ON GROUP
CARE FOR CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS
WHICH CAME OUT OF THE AMERICAN
ORTHO PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION.
I'M IN THE FIRST QUOTE IS.
GROUP SETTINGS SHOULD NOT BE
USED AS LIVING ARRANGEMENTS.
BECAUSE OF THEIRINHERENTLY
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON THE
HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN.
REGARDLESS OF AGE.
I'M AND THE SECOND ONE IS
HEALTHY ATTACHMENTS WITH THE
PARENT FIGURE.
ARE NECESSARY FOR CHILDREN OF
ALL AGES AND HELP TO REDUCE
PROBLEM BEHAVIORS AND
INTERPERSONAL DIFFICULTIES.
AND THE THIRD ONE IS GROUP CARE
SHOULD BE RESERVED FOR
THERAPEUTIC TREATMENT IN
CHILDREN. ONLY WHEN CLINICALLY
NECESSARY.
AND THE GOAL SHOULD BE.
RETURN TO FAMILIES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
SO I I JUST WANTED TO GROUND US
IN THAT RESEARCH BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S FUNDAMENTAL TO WHAT CCR
IS ALL ABOUT.
I AM AND THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO SAY IS THAT I'M.
CCR IS.
IS A MAJOR REFORM AND AND WE'VE
BEEN UNDERTAKING AT FOR SEVERAL
YEARS.
EXISTING PRACTICE HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A HUNDRED YEARS.
IT'S HUGE CULTURE CHANGE AND WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND YET.
WE KNOW.
THAT WE CAN GO BACK
THE DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS OF.
OF THE SYSTEM THE WAY IT WAS ARE
JUST TOO GREAT.
I AM AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO TO
POINT OUT THAT. AMONG THE HARMS
OF GROUP CARE. AND ARE THE
UNNECESSARY CALLS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT LEAD TO
DRAMATIC CONTACT WITH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THAT
CRIMINALIZE ABUSE AND NEGLECT OF
CHILDREN.
SO. NOW THAT WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF CCR WE CAN SEE THAT
IT'S GOING TO COST MORE.
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE MORE TIME
THAN WE ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED.
BUT IT'S WORTH IT TO GET IT
RIGHT.
BECAUSE THE ISSUES RELATED TO
SEE SEE ARE SO COMPLEX
BECAUSE WE FACE ADMINISTRATIVE
CHANGES SOON.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY UNKNOWNS
AS WE FORGE AHEAD.
WE DO NEED TO PUT SOME
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE IN THE
SHORT TERM.
PROTECTIONS THAT MAYBE INTERIM.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND AND BUILD SOLID PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AND I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
FOR A MINUTE.
.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT
PERFORMANCE MEASURES FOR THE
CONVERSION TO STR TEEPEES.
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THOSE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES ARE AT THE
HEART OF WHAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THROUGH CCR.
THEY'RE THE BASIS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AS WE GO THROUGH THE CONVERSION
PROCESS
AND THEY ARE ALSO GOING TO
GROUND THE LEVEL OF CARE SYSTEM
THAT IS IN DEVELOPMENT.
I'M SO THAT WE CAN BE SURE THAT.
CHILDREN'S NEEDS ARE MET.
I AM.
SO WHATEVER IS IMPLEMENTED NOW
AS AN INTERIM. MEASURE.
WE WOULD LIKE IT TO BE REVISITED
TO ENSURE THAT IT IS ALIGNED
WITH THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
WHEN THEY ARE DEVELOPED WE
REALLY FEEL LIKE. PERFORMANCE
MEASURES IN SOME WAYS SHOULD BE
DONE FIRST BECAUSE THEY THEY SET
THE PRECEDENT AND REALLY.
.
OTHER CLARIFY WHAT THE GOALS ARE
FOR THE WHOLE REST OF THE WORK
BUT THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT'S
WORKING.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT.
I'M WHATEVER'S PUT IN PLACE AN
INTERIM FASHION IS REVISITED.
WHEN THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
ARE IN PLACE.
AND I DO WANNA JUST REMIND
PEOPLE THAT THE CURRENT RATE
STRUCTURE IS DYSFUNCTIONAL AND
IT'S HARMFUL TO CHILDREN.
IT'S
IT'S NOT WORKING.
WE HAVE CHILDREN WHO NEED
SERVICES AND AREN'T GETTING
THEM.
WE HAVE CHILDREN BEING
COMMODIFIED IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE
TO GET A CERTAIN RATE.
AND IT'S NOT FOCUSED ON QUALITY
OF CARE.
SO AS WE LOOK FORWARD ON.
I REALLY HOPE THAT THE FOCUS
STAYS ON QUALITY OF CARE AND
THAT WE DON'T PATHOLOGY EYES
CHILDREN IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THE RATE STRUCTURE.
.
AND WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS DISRUPTIVE.
TWO USER.
A CURRENT TERM OF IT IS BIG
CULTURE CHANGE AND CULTURE
CHANGE IS HARD. I'M BUT WE HAVE
TO STAY FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING A
STRUCTURE THAT STRENGTH BASED
AND THAT WILL HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
THRIVE.
SO I'M.
WE PROPOSE THAT CERTAIN INTERIM
STRUCTURES LIKE LEVEL OF CARE BE
PUT IN PLACE NOW AND STOP GAP
MEASURES.
BUT SEE THEM AS TWO TO THREE
YOUR PILOTS THAT ARE REVISITED
WHEN THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES A
FINALIZED SO WE WOULD ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COMMIT TO
REVISITING THE STOP GAP
MEASURES.
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR LONG TERM
ALIGNMENT WITH THE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AND HAPPENS.
SO THAT THIS CCR REALLY RESULTS
AND TRUE POSITIVE CHANGE AND WE
GET THE GREAT OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
S. GARDENER.
REMEMBER IF YOU'RE READY. EIGHT
YOU. AND SO IN THAT MOMENT ON I
WROTE DOWN MY LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAMES.
.
I WORK WITH YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND.
THE HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY IN LOG
PASSION FOR THESE TOPICS.
THEY ARE CHRIS HERNANDEZ FROM
SHASTA KILLING JONES.
KILLER BELIEVE RICARDO GENESIS
GINA KAYLA KATERINA ENCLOSURE.
.
AS I MENTIONED OTHER YOUNGER
ENERGETIC THE PASSIONATE AND
pTHEIR VOICES CAN CHANGE THE
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN OF
MULTIPLE CCR CONVERSATIONS I'VE
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS NOW.
ARIS WE ENGAGE IN THE TOPICS ON
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL ARE MEMBERS OF MY MEMBERS
CONTINUOUSLY ASK ME IN ENGAGE.
HOWARD THESE SYSTEM CHANGES
CHANGING THE DATA DAILY LIVES OF
THEIR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
CARE.
THIS MANY TIMES OUR CONVERSATION
FLOWS THE WHAT IS THE DATA DAY
IMPACT FOR MY BROTHER AND
SISTERS.
I'M OUT ALSO FORMER MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CONNECTION I GREW UP
IN FOSTER CARE BETWEEN THE AGES
OF FOURTEEN TO EIGHTEEN WHEN I
AM MANSA PETERED.
WHEN I EMANCIPATED I'D VERY
LITTLE SUPPORT OR FAMILY IN MY
CORNER.
AND SEE WAY SEE HELPED ME FIND
MY VOICE AND MORE THAN ANYTHING
A HELP TO FIND MY COMMUNITY.
.
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE BEEN
HEARING RECENTLY AND THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND WITHIN THE SEATS ARE REFORM
IS WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
MAJOR CULTURE SHIFT.
WE'RE ALSO HEARING SOME OF THE
STRUGGLES AND THE BARRIERS THAT
WORK THE SCENE AND TO WE URGE
FOLKS TO HAVE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
AND KEEP. PERSEVERING.
OVER A WE'D LIKE TO CHALLENGE
THIS DOMINANT NARRATIVE THAT
THERE ARE SOME USE THAT ARE TOO
HARD TO PLACE.
MANY OF YOU HAVE SEEN AND
ENGAGED MY MEMBERS DIRECTLY.
MY MEMBERS ARE SMART THEY'RE
PASSIONATE AND AND THEY ALL HAVE
POTENTIAL.
AND AND THEY HAVE ALL
EXPERIENCED ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
THIS YEAR WE'RE WORKING ON OUR
CAMPAIGN FOSTER STABILITY WHICH
WILL CREATE A YOUTH CENTER
PROCESS FOR STABILITY IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM THIS
INCLUDE STABILITY EMPLACEMENT
STABILITY AND WELLNESS STABILITY
IN RELATIONSHIPS IN EDUCATION.
AND STABILITY IN ALL ASPECT OF
THEIR LIVES.
AS THEY HAVE GROWN IN.
EXPERIENCE A REFLECTED THEIR
TIME IN CARE.
STABILITY IS THEIR NUMBER ONE
HOUSE.
AS WE.
REVIEW THE PROGRESS IN THE
DIRECTION OF CCR.
AND WE CONSIDER VARIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS IN THE MULTITUDE OF
EFFORTS.
WE APPROACH EACH CONVERSATION
WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
WILL THIS EFFORT TRANSFORM THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND WILL IT
FOSTER STABILITY AND AUTHOR ALL
ASPECTS OF THEIR LIVES.
IN REGARDS THE VISION AND THE
PROMISE OF CCR WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE THAT YES THIS WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIVE WE BELIEVE THAT
CHILDREN YOU SHOULD BE RAISED IN
A LOVING COMMITTED HOMES AND NOT
IN CONGREGATE CARE SETTINGS.
SPECIFICALLY THERE A FEW PIECES
THAT MY MEMBERS ARE SPECIALLY
I'M EXCITED ABOUT AND THE HAVE
THE MOST POTENTIAL THIS INCLUDES
TOM FAMILY TEAMS THE YOUTH
SATISFACTION SURVEY AND THEN
ONGOING. TRAINING AND SUPPORT
FOR RESOURCE PARENTS THESE THREE
COMBINED. WILL BE A SYSTEM THAT
THEY HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED
THEMSELVES.
IN REGARDS TO THE STR TP
CONVERSATION OUR MEMBERS FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ADDRESS ON BOTH FRONTS
SUPPORTING YOUNG PEOPLE AS THEY
TRANSITION OUT OF GROUP HOMES.
BUT ALSO FOCUSING IN ON LIMIT IN
THE ENTRY INTO.
AND OR FEELING UP INTO GROUP
HOMES
TRAUMA INFORMED TO PRACTICE AND
COMMON FORMED SYSTEMS ARE JUST
FOR US FOLKS ASK WHAT HAS
HAPPENED. NOT WHAT DID YOU DO
YOU THINK US CHARITY PIECE.
AND GROUP HOMES INCURRING GROUP
HOMES ARE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCE MULTIPLE PLACEMENT
CHANGES
ON AVERAGE THEY'VE EXPERIENCED
BETWEEN FOUR AND FIVE PLEASE
MAKE CHANGES BEFORE THEY GET TO
A GROUP HOME.
WE WANT TO CHALLENGE
WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES AND WORK THROUGH THEM
AS PARTNERS AND WE WANT TO
CHALLENGE THE DOMINANT
NARRATIVE.
THAT NO YOUNG PERSON IS TOO HARD
TO PLEASE
AND I EACH YOUNG PERSON HAS
POTENTIAL.
IN REGARDS TO.
THE TRADUCTOR YEAR OF THE A
LEVEL OF CARE ASSESSMENT.
WE ASK THAT THERE IS ALSO A
SIXTY DAY DELAY.
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION SOMETHING
WE'D LIKE TO BE HAVE CONSIDERED
IS THAT THIS LOC TOOL BE
COMBINED IN A CONVERSATION WITH
HOW THE CAN CAN'T ASSESSMENT
TOOL AND THE SCR ALSO ROLLED
OUT.
IT OCCURS TO US THAT I A YOUTH
CENTERED AND FAMILY CENTERED
SYSTEM. IS NOW ASKING FOR THREE
SEPARATE EVALUATIONS AND THREE
SEPARATE ASSESSMENTS WOULD LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND HOW ALL THREE OF
THEM ARE COORDINATED AND ARE NOT
COORDINATED.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ASK THE SYSTEM
THAT IT CONTINUES TO BE YOUTH
CENTERED AND FAMILY CENTERED
BEFORE CONSIDERING ANY OTHER.
EFFORTS THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MS HERNANDEZ FOR YOUR
COURAGE IN EFFICACY.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ALEJO
.
SO WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ELLIOT
AND DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN IF I MAY
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BONDS TO. BURN ON
THE PANEL BEFORE WE TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
BUT THEN WILL FOLLOW THAT WITH
PUBLIC COME.
MINORITIES. I JUST BRAINSTORMED
FINANCE SO I THINK WE'LL START
OFF WITH IS SKINNER JUST
ADDRESSING THE PROPOSALS WERE
PUT ASIDE. SO THEY ARE FEE
PROPOSAL ON.
LOOKING FOR A LONG TERM
SOLUTION SOMETHING THAT WOULD
FOLLOW ALONG WITH ON WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
WORKED WITH AN AB ONE TEN.
W ARE.
LOOKING INTO YOU ARE WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS INDIA AND
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
ON A A DEVELOPING A LONG TERM
SOLUTION. TO ADDRESS THAT
IMMEDIATE FUNDING UPON PLACEMENT
AS WELL AS LOOKING INTO THE
CURRENT BACKLOG.
WOULD ASSOCIATE WITH THE
RESOURCE SIMPLY A PROVOCATIONS
SADDAM IN REGARDS WITH THE.
OTHER THAN THE REMAINING
PROPOSALS ARE INCLUDE AND.
.
AT THIS TIME.
IF FINANCE THREE OPPOSED ANY
ACTION TAKEN ON ON THIS
PROPOSALS BECAUSE WHERE I AM
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
TO RIDE JUST TO LOOK INTO THIRD
EVALUATING A LOT OF CONCERNS
THAT ARE BEING ADDRESSED TODAY
ON TO THE EXTENT THAT AFTER
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE CONTINUING
OUR GO THROUGH. AND.
EVALUATIONS ARE DETERMINED
SOMETHING MAY BE INCLUDED IN THE
MAIN REVISION TO PROVIDE TO
LEGISLATURE.
BUT WE DO WANT ITS ARE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HAVING THIS
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE BEEN HEARING
THIS CONCERNS.
AND TIME WILL CONTINUE TO GO ON
WITH THOSE TO THE EXTENT. THAT
ANY OF THESE PROPOSALS.
INTO BEING A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WERE. MORE THAN
WILLING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE MOVING FORWARD ON
THOSE AS WELL. THANK YOU SIR.
BOB BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA OUT.
WE DID CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS OF
THE GOVERNOR CCR PROPOSAL AND
SHARED AND MANY OF THE FINDINGS
THAT WERE PRESENT IN THE AGENDA
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
HERE WE PROVIDE A STATUS UPDATE
THAT'S LARGELY CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT MANY OF THAT MUCH OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS ALSO.
THAT OCCURRED BEFORE ME I AM I
AM I JUST FOCUS THEN ON A FEW OF
THE SORT OF BUDGETARY ASPECTS
AND SO FORTH AND SO. UP IN TERMS
OF HOW HOW HOW THINGS ARE GOING
AND WE. WE PROVIDE A STATUS
UPDATE IN WHICH WE FOCUS ON SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES BUT WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSES AND YOU KNOW A GREAT
DEAL OF GUIDANCE GET.
COMING OUT OF DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES COLLABORATION
WITH THE BEHAVIORAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND DH YES AND SO
FORTH AND SO WE DO WANNA YOU
KNOW RECOGNIZE PROGRESS THAT'S
MADE WHILE ALSO NOTING THE
CHALLENGES AROUND RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL. OF CONCERNS
AROUND THE LEVEL OF CARE
ASSESSMENT AND SO FORTH WE DO
NOTE SORT OF.
THE SIR THE SLOWER THAN
ANTICIPATED CASELOAD MOVEMENT
OUT OF GROUP HOMES AND INTO UP
BOTH THE SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
INTO LOWER LEVEL PLACEMENTS. AND
THE IMPACT THAT THIS HAS HAD ON.
SORT OF MULTI YEAR PROJECTION
OF WHAT THE COSTS OF CC ARE
GOING TO BE A GOING FORWARD SO
THERE ARE HIGHER COSTS UP
PROJECTED IN BOTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. OVER PREVIOUS
PROJECTIONS UP LARGELY AS A
RESULT OF THE SLOWER CASELOAD
MOVEMENT.
AND ULTIMATELY WE FIND THAT
THAT UPWARD REVISION DE ISRAELI
REASON FORD TO.
YOU KNOW WE RECOGNIZE AB ONE
TEN AND THE SUCCESS THAT THAT AD
SPACE POTENTIALLY BRILLIANT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUT
THAT TO KNOW THAT THAT WAS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT COMES
AROUND THE TIME OF THE MAY
REVISE THEIR.
AND THEN.
JUST ALSO A WRECK AND YET AND
SO FINALLY THEN JUST STOP
RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE CLOSELY
MONITOR HOW THE RESOURCE FAMILY
PROVOKE PROCESS IS SPEEDING UP
GIVEN. NEW IMPLEMENTATION
GUIDELINES AND SO FORTH.
AND WHETHER ANY BUDGETARY OR OR
POLICY FIXES ARE IN FACT
NECESSARY SO HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THANK YOU SIR.
DOCTOR LIKE PORN.
THE PROBLEM THAT YOU PUT PRIVATE
NOBODY CAN GET YOUR NOW THAT'S
AT THAT POINT THANK YOU THANK
YOU A DOCTOR ON THE. ARM.
OBVIOUSLY A VARIETY OF ISSUES
WOULD COME UP AND FROM ALL FROM
PEOPLE MY OF UTMOST.
THE DEEP WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH.
AUTUMN.
A COUPLE POINTS ARM.
THE ASPECT OF SORT OF THE
AVAILABILITY FOR EXAMPLE ALL OF
THE STR TP.
CHAIN WELL WE CURRENTLY HAVE
HOME TWENTY SEVEN. PROVIDERS
APPROVED THAT'S WITH MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS BUT THERE ANOTHER
SIXTY IN THE QUEUE.
THAT WERE WORKING FOR NOW.
FIRST SOME OF THOSE ARE PROBABLY
NOT AS BIG AS SOME OF THOSE
READY PROVIDE. APPROVED BUT THE
OTHER THING WHICH I THINK IT
SORT OF POINTS TO A LITTLE BIT
THIS IS A.
CRITICS OFTEN BUT LET'S SAY IT.
IS THERE IS AN ELEMENT OF
DENIAL.
ARM LET'S SEE IF THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO HAPPEN SO WE HAVE SOME.
PROVIDERS WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
HANGING BACK.
OF WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW IS
EMPHASIZING VERY VERY CLEARLY TO
THE PROVIDERS MEANT TO ALL THE
OTHER PLAYERS.
THAT NO WE'RE THIS IS MOVING
AHEAD AND THAT HOME.
IT'S TIME TO.
IF THE APPLICATIONS AND
FINALIZED ETCETERA ALONG THE IT
WOULD LIKEWISE SORT OF YOU KNOW
PART COLLEAGUES A DHC HACER NOW
OUT IN THE FIELD WORKING WITH
COUNTIES AROUND.
MEDICAL CERTIFICATIONS AND
BASICALLY SAYING VERY CLEARLY
THE COUNTIES YOU HAVE TO TELL US
EITHER YOU. LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ARE GOING TO DO
CERTIFICATION OR WE WILL DEFAULT
AND GO IT BECAUSE THAT'S.
THE RULES PER PROVIDE FOR SO
THESE ARE THE SORTS OF THINGS
THAT ARE NOW INTENSIFYING AND AS
I WOULD EXPECT.
HOME.
THE.
I I KEEP RUNNING TALLY GOING OUT
WE GOT TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE DAYS BEFORE. FOR A DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST
SO IT'S SORT OF YOU KNOW WE'RE
GETTING UP TO THE MIDDLE OF THE.
WHOSE FIRST SEMESTER MAYBE
HALFWAY INTO THE SECOND
AND WHERE YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THOSE
PUPILS WERE HAVING A TOUGHER
TIME AND GIVE THE MORE ATTENTION
AND WE DON'T GIVE UP ON ANYBODY.
ARM BUT WE SORT OF START PULLING
PEOPLE ACROSS BOTH WE ALSO DON'T
LOWER THE STANDARDS
ON THE STANDARDS HAVE TO STUDY.
WHAT IT IS WE WOULD SET UP WE'VE
WE'VE SORT
COLLECTIVELY DREAMED ABOUT? ON
THE THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESSES.
ALEJO'S NOTED.
HOME DEFINITELY SORT OF BECAME A
BIT OF A CHOKE POINT
THE SYSTEM.
ARM.
AND AND IT WAS IRONIC IN IT'S
OWN WAY BECAUSE IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT THAT WAS THE PEACE THAT
WE HAD DONE A ONE YEAR PILOT ON.
AND WORTH.
ALL SET TO GO IT WAS GOOD
EVERYBODY WAS GUT AND THEN IT
TURNED OUT THAT IT WAS JUST
DIFFICULT IN THE TRANSITION. TO
COUNTIES THAT HADN'T YET
ENTERED INTO IT AND PREPARE.
SO WE'VE STUMPED YOU KNOW WE
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS IS
GOTTEN OUT HOME.
MOVING I THINK QUITE A LOT
FASTER COUNTIES REPORTING THAT
IT IS GOING A LOT FASTER BUT IN
ADDITION THANK YOU AB ONE TEN
HAS DEFINITELY SORT OF AVERTED
WHAT WAS A. LOOMING CRISIS
AUTUMN AND IS AS FINANCES
INDICATED WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM FOR WHAT WILL BE THE GO
PAST JUNE THIRTIETH.
OWN SOLUTION FOR PAYMENT OF
PLACEMENT. WON'T BE THE OTHER
AREAS WHICH THERE'S BEEN SORT OF
REFERENCE TO HIS IS THE LEVEL OF
CARE.
RATES AND THE THE THE
INSTRUMENTS
THE PARTICLES. ARE AYE AYE AYE
CIRCLE PLANS AND THEN MAYBE HAVE
SERVER OR GREGSON ELABORATE
ANYTHING AMISS. DE.
THERE ISN'T A TOOL OUT THERE
THAT WE CAN GO AND SHOP FOR AND
SAY LET'S DO A REAL NEEDS BASED.
INSTRUMENT FOR FOSTER USE
ARMED. MEN TO THE STATES THAT
HAVE.
RATES ANYWHERE COMPARABLE TO
OURS ALL DO WHAT WE ARE LEAVING
WHICH IS AN AGE BASED RIGHT TO
GET ONE RIGHT.
WHEN YOU'RE THIS AGING ANOTHER
RATE OF THAT IT IS NOT CONNECTED
TO. WHAT THE INDIVIDUALS NEEDS
ARE?
COUNTIES HAVE
TO HAVE.
THEY IN A SENSE COMPENSATE FOR
THE OUT OR MITIGATE THAT.
WELL HOME DEVELOPMENTS OF
SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENTS THE
STI SUPER FURTIVE. THAT VARY
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY ARM MOST
COUNTIES HAVE THEM BUT NOTABLE.
ARM AND THE ATTORNEYS ARE TO
HAVE THE OPTION OF DO THEY PAY.
THEIR RATE WHEN THEY PLACE IN
ANOTHER COUNTY OR DO THEY PAY
THE OTHER COUNTIES RIGHT ON
MINUTES.
PRETTY COOL.
HERE'S THE POINTS I'D LIKE YOU
TO TOOK.
BE CLEAR ON ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
CARE.
TIERED RATES.
THE LOWEST RATE THE LEVEL OF
CARE ONE RATE
IS HIGHER.
THEN THE RATES.
THAT EXISTED PREVIOUSLY.
SO NO ONE GETS A REDUCED RATE.
FROM THE FOSTER CARE PAYMENT
RIGHT.
THE QUESTION BECOMES IS THERE A
POSSIBLE DISADVANTAGE THAT
SOMEBODY MIGHT NOT GET A
SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENTS
BECAUSE OF THE. LEVEL OF CARE
INSTRUMENT
ON
SOLUTION WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES TO DO IS TO SAY. ARM.
IF YOU'RE SPECIALIZED CARE AND
COMMIT RATE IS LOWER THAN THE
TEARS IN THE LEVEL OF CARE RATE.
YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA ADVANTAGE
THE FAMILY BY USING THE LEVEL OF
CARE.
THAT. THEY WILL PROBABLY BENEFIT
IF YOUR ASCII RATES ARE HIGHER.
THEN THE OPTION IS ALL STAY WITH
THE SCR UNTIL YOU'VE SUBMITTED
YOUR REPLIES PLAN WITH US IT
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
STATEWIDE AND IT NEVER.
REALISTICALLY WAS GOING TO BE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES DON'T DO.
THINGS AT THE SAME TIME.
MOM AND WE YOU CAN'T WAIT TILL
THE FIFTY EIGHTH BECAUSE YOU
NEVER START.
AUTUMN
SO THAT IS I THINK HA HA IT.
FERNANDES IS QUESTION ABOUT ARM.
WHO THE INTERACTION BETWEEN THE
LEVEL OF CARE RATE MCCANN'S
INSTRUMENT?
WE VERY DELIBERATELY DON'T WANT
THEM CONFUSED.
THE LEVEL OF CARE IS DETERMINING
A PAYMENT.
TO THE CARE GIVER.
FOR WHAT ISN'T.
UNDERSTOOD TO BE THE NEEDS THE
CARE GIVERS GOING TO HAVE IN
PROVIDING FOR THE START.
IT'S NOT COMPENSATION TO THE
CAREGIVER.
IT'S MEETING THE.
SUPERB KERINCI PROVISION COST.
THE KARENS INSTRUMENT IS
DETERMINED OF SERVICE NEEDS FOR
THE CHILD.
OR WHAT WILL BE TRIGGERED
THROUGH EITHER MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS OR. OTHER SYSTEMS
AND.
ONE WOULD NEVER WANT TO CONFUSE
THE FUNCTIONING
SO THAT I COULD THINK.
THIS WAS LOOSE WHAT LUCY WAS
ALLUDING TO THE COMMODIFICATION.
OF A CHILD'S ASSESSMENT
WE NEVER WANT TO PUT A DOLLAR
VALUE ON DETERMINING WHETHER
THERE ARE A CHILD HAS EMOTIONAL
ISSUES ARE NEEDS OR OR WHATEVER
THAT'S.
NOT WOULD TOTALLY CONFUSE THE
FUNCTION AND BE
I THINK VERY UNFAIR TO THE
CHILDREN. ARM.
SORT OF MORE BROADLY TO THE
MIDDLE.
REFLOATING ANXIETY ABOUT TIME IS
SHORT AND CHALLENGES A GREAT YES
WE ARE FULLY AWARE OF IT AND
WALLEM.
THE FOR THE FIRST
ELEMENT RIGHT NOW IS REALLY
WORKING AT A GRANULAR FASHION
COUNTY BY COUNTY. PALM.
SERVICE ERRORS GROUP ARE DOING
SORT OF REGULAR CALLS WITH ALL
THE COUNTY SAYING.
HOW MANY BEDS DO YOU NEED WHERE
ARE YOU WHAT PROCESS IS
UNDERWAY?
AND FINALLY FOR THE ISSUE OF
RECRUITING OF THE NON SD RTP BUT
STAY HOME BASED FAMILY BUT CARE.
BASED
THE.
WHO?
REALISTICALLY FOR THOSE YOUTH
WHO WERE NOW INNER GROUP CARE
WHO AREN'T GOING TO STAY HONESTY
RTP CARE FOR WHILE BUT ARE GOING
TO GO TO HOME BASED CARE.
THE REALITY IS THEY WILL
LARGELY.
B. CARED FOR BY FAMILY BY PEOPLE
THEY ALREADY KNOW.
AND IT ISN'T A MATTER OF GOING
OUT RECRUITING AND ABSTRACT.
PERSON TO SAY WOULD YOU BE
AVAILABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
SOMEBODY AND WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT
LATER IT WILL BE. WERE STARTING
FROM THE LENS OF THE CHILD AND
SAYING.
WHO DIDN'T KNOW WHO LOVES YOU
WHO'S AVAILABLE WHO IF WE
ENGAGED? WELL AND SUPPORT THEM
AND PROVIDE SERVICES.
WHO WILL STEP UP BECAUSE THEY
KNOW YOU MEAN THAT YOU ARE PART
OF THEM?
IT WOULDN'T WORK WHEN ARM.
DID THE KERN COUNTY EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AUTHORED A
WILSON WE'VE WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A
WALLS IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM PRIMARILY FROM GROUPS.
HOME BUT THE QUESTION I WAS
ACCOMPANIST PEOPLE WHEN CHILDREN
A WILLING IS ARE THE.
IS SHE RUNNING FROM SOMETHING OR
TO SOMETHING.
THE DIFFERENCE IS VERY IMPORTANT
IN THE CITING.
AND.
IF IT IS.
IF.
DOES THE CHILD OVER THE
WANNABES.
AND CAN WE WORK WITH THEM.
FIND THE.
APPROPRIATE PLACE THE RIGHT
PLACE.
THAT THEY WANT TO BE NOT
SOMEWHERE WE PUT THEM
BECAUSE THAT WAS.
AND HOW WE USE TO DO IT.
SO WITH THAT I WILL NOW MOVES TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ISSUE TWO.
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND.
TAKE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAC
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THEIR NUMBER OF SPECIFIC.
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT THAT
WE.
US SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE.
ASSOCIATED WITH NEW WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH CCR THAT'S NEVER
BEEN FUNDED WE'VE HAD A VERY
GOOD RELATIONSHIP VERY
PRODUCTIVE IMPAIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON FAIR
FUNDING FOR CCR. THE LOC
ASSESSMENTS IN THE KANSAS
SETTLEMENTS ARE NEW WORKLOAD AND
WE PUT AN ESTIMATE OUT TO YOU IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ON WHAT WE
THINK THAT WORKLOAD IS.
AND.
WE ALSO PUT A NOTE REQUEST FOR%
FUNDING TO REDUCE THE BACKLOG OF
OUR A FAIT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON WHAT MIGHT BE IN
THE MAY REVISION BUT THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT.
I'M FUNDING FEATURES AND WE
POINT OUT THE FOR ELLA SEA IN
CANS. THOSE ARE THOSE ARE NOT
SERVE OPTION ALL SORT OF THINGS
THAT WOULD BE NICE THERE
ACTUALLY. MANDATES UNDER PROP
THIRTY THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
CCR.
THE LAST PANEL REALLY US ALSO
BOMB STRUCK.
THAT.
VERY SORT OF SYMPATHETIC AND AT
AT COURT THAT WORKER BOMB THE
NASA DO YOU FLOSS CENTER. ALL
SAID.
KIDS NEED TO BE WITH FAMILIES
THEY NEED TO BE SUPPORTED THEIR
TRAUMA NEEDS TO BE IDENTIFIED
EARLY AND THEY NEED TO BE WITH
FAMILIES.
AND WE COMPLETELY AGREE AND
WE'RE PROUD TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH. AB TWENTY FORTY THREE IN
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE BILL
TO KEEP KIDS WITH FAMILIES AND
TO KEEP PLACEMENTS FROM BEING
DISRUPTED BECAUSE WE AGREE THAT
ALL KIDS.
BOB SHOULD BE WITH FAMILIES.
AND FINALLY JUST LIKE TO SAY.
ARM.
THAT FROM THAT STANDPOINT OF THE
COUNTIES.
OUR CONCERN ISN'T THAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
WORK THAT'S TOO HARD FOR US.
AND.
ARE CONCERNED ISN'T THAT WE
DON'T KNOW THE THINGS THAT THE
DIRECTORS POINTED OUT ABOUT.
HOW TO ENGAGE KIDS RIGHT THE
QUESTION IS DO WE HAVE THE TIME?
AND.
OUR THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE MADE
WHEN WE WERE MAKING IT UP.
WHERE THE ACCURATE AND COULD WE
UNWITTINGLY DO SOMETHING WORSE?
ARM BECAUSE OF THE HOPE.
THAT ON TWELVE THIRTY ONE
EVERYTHING WILL BE IN PLACE.
TOM AND I WOULD JUST I WOULD
JUST RESUBMIT THAT THAT IS AN
INCREDIBLY VITAL AND IMPORTANT
POINT AND I THINK IF WE DISMISS
IT.
AS.
THE CONCERNS OF AN ANXIOUS
BUREAUCRACY AND NOT THE PEOPLE
WHO RUN THE PROGRAM WHO
UNDERSTAND THE KIDS.
UNDERSTAND THE YOUTH UNDERSTAND
THE PROVIDERS
THEN WE RUN THE RISK OF.
DOING WORSE AND AND THAT'S JUST
NOT ACCEPTABLE TO US.
THANK YOU SIR.
I JUSTIN GARRETT WITH A
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES DOWN COUNTIES REMAIN
STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
IMPLEMENTING CCR IN ACHIEVING
THE AMBITIOUS AND WORTHWHILE
GOALS THAT ARE.
UNDERTAKEN WITH THIS REFORM
EFFORT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP IN THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE.
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE PARTICULARLY ON THE
RECENT NAM FUNDING PROVIDED AB
ONE TEN.
COME SEE SACK IS CO SPONSORING
ON THE PROPOSAL FOR FIFTY FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION.
FOR. OUR IMPLEMENTATION.
FUNDING TO CONTINUE WITH THAT.
CCR IN TERMS OF.
IMPLEMENTING THE RFA THEY'LL
SEE IN THE KANSAS HARASSMENTS
I'M A PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THAT
WAS HE DOUBLE GATE SEIU IN THIS
A REALLY ASSIST I'M COUNTIES IN.
AND FURTHER IN IMPLEMENTATION
EFFORTS IN ACHIEVING HIS GOALS
AND ADDITIONAL WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE UP PROPOSAL
I'M IN THE FUNDING FOR. THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND OF THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM THANKS.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI ANGIE SHORT FOR THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AGAIN AND
JUST IN RESPONSE TO WHAT THE
DIRECTOR WHY PORN. STUD ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A SMALL
OR LARGE RISK OF THE LOC TOOL
BEING IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT ANY
TESTING OR STUDYING WE BELIEVE
IT TO BE A VERY LARGE RISK MY
ORGANIZATION DOES MOSTLY DIRECT
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE MEANING WE REPRESENT.
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN IN
BENEFITS CASES EVERY SINGLE YEAR
WE ARE WELL VERSED IN THE
SPECIALIZED CARE TOOL AND WE
HAVE STUDIED THE LEVEL OF CARE
TOOL AND WE DON'T THINK THERE IS
A SMALL RISK. THAT CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO BE ASSESSED PROPERLY
UNDER THE LEVEL OF CARE TOOL AND
THERE'S A LARGE RISK THAT THEY
WILL LOSE SPECIALIZED CARE AS A
RESULT OF THIS NEW SYSTEM BEING
ROLLED OUT. AND THAT'S
ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN WE'RE
MAKING THE COUNTIES CHANGE THEIR
SPECIALIZED CARE PLANS WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THOSE SPECIALIZED CARE
PLANS ARE GOING TO BE AND THOSE
ALSO HAVE NOT BEEN VALIDATED
ALONG WITH THE LOC TOOL. THIS IS
NO SMALL UNDERTAKING AND OUR
KIDS AND FAMILIES SHOULD NOT BE
THE GUINEA PIGS BY WHICH WE
FIGURE OUT IF WE GOT THE RATES
RIGHT OR WRONG.
HEY.
I'M ROWLAND HEIGHTS CAO.
AND.
IT BIG AT.
I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THE
COUNTY SINCE
MAYBE.
LIKE HIM TWO THOUSAND SEVENTY
FOUR REGRET THE OTHER.
I HAVE BEEN ABOVE AND BEYOND
WITH THE COUNTY IT IS BECAUSE OF
HIGH IMPACT OF FAMILY.
HEART ACHES STRESS PAINFUL FOR
MY WHOLE FAMILY AND OR WITH THE
IN THEN CHILD WELFARE ACT IT IS
REALLY GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND AND
I CONTACTED THE DIRECTOR. AND
THERE HAS BEEN NO OVER A MORE
REMARK NOTHING SO I'M HERE
TODAY.
THAT ALMA.
MY GRANDCHILD HAS BEEN APPROVED
FOR ALMOST A YEAR NOW WITH THE
ART OF A CASE.
AND.
I THINK THEM THE LEVEL OF CARE
TOOL SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
BEFORE EVER HAVE VALIDATION.
AND THERE IS NO REASON FOR THIS
TO BE GOING ON TOO MANY FAMILIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
ACUMEN YEAH.
I MY NAME'S CARL EILENBERG I'M A
FOSTER PARENT IN MARIN COUNTY
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS NOW. AND I'M
JUST HERE TO SUPPORT.
GETTING FUNDING UPON PLACEMENT
TO EXTEND PAST JUNE THIRTIETH
FOR ALL CAREGIVERS. I ALSO FEEL
LIKE THE LOC TOOL SHOULD BE.
TESTED AND MADE SURE THAT IT'S
GONNA GO INTO PLAY CORRECTLY AND
NOT HAVE TO BE.
ADJUSTED EVERY MONTH.
BEFORE IT GETS IMPLEMENTED. AND
I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. HELP FOR
FOSTER PARENTS WHEN THEY HAVE
KIDS AND TRAUMA. THANK YOU THANK
HIM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RICHARD NGUYEN
OF OR SOME HAVE THE URBAN KINDS
OF CALIFORNIA HERE TO US ON.
IN SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY FOUR
POINT MILLION DOLLAR QUEST BY
CBA SEE SACK ASKS ARE YOU FOR
THE INFORMATION OF CCR WHICH AS
YOU'VE HEARD. IS EXTREMELY
NEEDED FOR THESE KIDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE.
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROPOSAL THE LEVEL OF CARE
ASSESSMENT PROPOSAL AND THE
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS ASSESSMENTS PROPOSAL.
WE THINK INVESTMENTS A WORKLOAD
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURING THE BEST OUTCOMES
POSSIBLE FOR KIDS IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THE COUNTIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT. OF THE TIME.
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM PROPOSAL AS WELL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREA ROGERSON
FROM MARIPOSA COUNTY I'VE BEEN A
FOSTER PARENT FOR AROUND TEN
YEARS. AND HAD TO ALSO HEAR THAT
THE LEVEL OF CATTLE BE TESTED
BEFORE IT IS IMPLEMENTED.
OFF THE M. RFA PROCESS IT COULD
BE VERY CONFUSING TO ADD
SOMETHING ELSE IF IT'S NOT
READY.
TO GET.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
YES MY NAME IS MISS BERNIE
WALKING FOR FRESNO CALIFORNIA
PART OF BRING A BROKEN
NEIGHBORHOODS BACK TO LIFE AS
WELL. PRINCES VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE.
ASSOCIATION PROSPEROUS
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER FIVE.
ABOUT A FALSE A PAIR OF ABOUT
TWO YEARS.
AND I SUPPORT.
THAT THE FUNDING BE PLACED WHEN
A CHILD.
IS PLACED IN THE HOME.
ALSO THE LFC BE VALIDATED BEFORE
IT IS PUT INTO ACTION.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS CHERYL LEGAL S. B.
AND I AGED OUT OF FOSTER CARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE FACT THAT
THE YOU STEP DOWN FROM GROUPS
HOMES. IS EXTENDED I WAS PUT
INTO A GROUP HOME AND AFTER THAT
PLACED INTO. PLACEMENTS THAT
FELL APART AND WAS SEXUALLY
ABUSED SAW IS STRONGLY ADAMANT.
THAT YOU TAKE YOUR TIME AND
FINING THOSE GOOD QUALITY HOMES
FOR THESE VULNERABLE YOU.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE BROWSE Y.
REPRESENT THE BOARD.
RIGHT MARIN COUNTY BOARD A
FOSTER CARE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT OUR FAMILIES
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET FUNDING WHEN THERE
HAVE A CHILD PLACED IN THEIR
HOME IT PUTS AN EXTREME HARDSHIP
ON THEM. AND ALSO THE LEVEL OF
CARE IS TESTED BEFORE ABDOMEN.
THEY CAME.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREA YATES
SOME OUT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AYE AND THE FOSTER PARENT OF MY
COUSIN. I HAVE BEEN APPROVED FOR
THE ARE A THREE OF FOR ABOUT SIX
MONTHS NOW.
I FULLY SUPPORT PLANINA
PLACEMENT BEYOND.
JUNE THIRTIETH AND ALSO THE
LEVEL OF CARE TO TO BE TESTED
BEFORE IS IMPLEMENTED STATE WHY
THINK THINK HUMAN.
HEIM JOINTS HEMORRHAGE FROM
CINEMA COUNTY PRESIDENT OF
REDWOOD EMPIRE FOSTER PARENTS
ASSOCIATION AND FOSTER PARENT OF
SIXTEEN YEARS. I AM I AM HERE TO
FULLY OFFER SUPPORT THAT ALL
CAREGIVRS SHOULD KEEP HIM ON
PLACEMENT OF ANY CHILD IN THEIR
HOME.
AND ALSO THE.
LEVELED NAM OF CARE TO BE
TESTED BEFORE IMPLEMENTED THINK
IT FREEDOM THINK EGGMAN.
HELLO MY NAME SINGLE TATUM FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN
FOSTERING ON AS A FOSTER PARENT
FOR OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS. M. I
CHIU BELIEVE. AND TEN THE
FINDINGS SHOULD BE.
FOSTER FOSTER PARENTS SHOULD BE.
FUNDED UPON THE PLACEMENT ALSO
BELIEVE. THAT THEY SHOULD TRULY
TEST THEM THE LOC T. TOOL. AND
THAT'S VERY CRUCIAL AND ALSO ON.
THE FUNDING SHOULD BE EXTENDED
AS WELL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME ES SELENA ALVAREZ AND
I'M A FOSTER PARENT OF THREE
CHILDREN. AND I LIVE IN YOLO
COUNTY HIM UP I'M SORRY LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUT THE CASES
FROM MILLER COMING.
AND IT TOOK I FINISHED MY
PROCESS AND ABOUT.
A FEW DAYS AND IT TOOK THE
COUNTY SIX MONTHS TO PROVE
MYSELF AND MY WIFE SO I FULLY
SUPPORT MERGING SEE FOSTER. CARE
MONEY FOR EMERGENCY PLACEMENT
AND TO EXTEND IT PASSED JUNE
THIRTIETHTHANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M PATRICIAN NAY GUESTS
AND I'M A FOSTER PARENT FOR
FORTY YEARS I'VE HAD OVER FIVE
HUNDRED CHILDREN.
AND I'VE.
SUPPORT THE FUNDING AT THE TIME
OF PLACEMENT WE HAVE.
SO MANY FAMILIES THERE'D JUST BE
AND DEVASTATED BY THIS.
AND I ALSO THAT LEVEL OF CARE
TOOL SHOULD BE VALIDATED BEFORE
WE TRIED OUT ON OUR FOSTER CHIP
FOSTER PARENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO. I'M CHERIE WHETHER ALL.
I AM A GRANDMA MAMA AT THIS
LOVELY LITTLE GROWTH TASK.
JASMINE I IT HAS BEEN MY CARE
SINCE SHE WAS TWO DAYS OLD.
I ACCEPTED HER AS THE SURPRISE
EMERGENCY PLACEMENT.
I AM STRONG ADVOCATE OF FUNDING.
APPETITE REPLACEMENT FOR
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS BECAUSE THE
STRESS THAT CAN CAUSE ON AN
INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILY. IS
UNKNOWN AT THE TIME ESPECIALLY
IF THAT CHILD HAS SPECIAL NEEDS.
SUCH AS JASMINE DID. IT TOOK ME
RELATIVELY CLOSE TO TWO YEARS TO
GET.
THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR HER
I SHE IS A CHILD WITH CEREBRAL
PALSY. SHE ALSO HAS EPILEPSY.
AND SHE'S HAD HEART FAILURE AND
HAS SUFFERED NUMEROUS OF
DISABILITIES BECAUSE OF THAT.
HER OUTCOME AT THIS POINT IS
POSITIVE. BUT I STRONGLY DO
ADVOCATE AND SUPPORT OTHERS WHO
ARE IN MY SITUATION.
FIND THEMSELVES AS GRANDPARENTS
AND RELATIVES TAKING ON
EMERGENCY PLACEMENTS.
OF CHILDREN AND I ALSO AM HOPING
THAT SOME STRICT ATTENTION BE
PUT PAID TO THE LOC. TOOL IN
THAT IT IS TESTED BEFORE
PLACEMENT.
SO THAT FAMILIES DON'T HAVE TO
SUFFER THE SEESAW CHANGE
DURING THE TESTING PERIOD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TIME THANK YOU
MEANT.
HI I AM JACQUI RESIZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND WE REPRESENT
ADOPTION AGENCIES AND FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES AS CHARGE BEASON
GROUPON'S. SO WE ARE THE GROUP
OR ARE THERE GROUP THAT
REPRESENTS A LOT OF THE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES THAT ARE TESTING
THE LOC. DIDN'T PAY JUST TO MAKE
ONE CORRECTION FOR THE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY FAMILIES THEY
ACTUALLY DID TAKE A LOWER
STIPEND TO ON.
PARTICIPATE IN CCR WHICH WE
STRONGLY STRONGLY.
WANT TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF CCR
AND THE ONE WORD I REALLY
HAVEN'T HEARD TOO MUCH CITIES
PERMANENCY.
WHEN YOU'RE REDUCING THE GROUP
HOMES INTO ESOTERIC PEAS AND
YOU'RE MOVING SRTP YOUTH INTO
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
IN THE FOSTER FAMILIES.
IT'S REALLY STILL ALL ABOUT
PERMANENCY AND SO JUST WANT TO
THANK THE DEPARTMENT YOU'VE DONE
AN EXCELLENT JOB WORKING WITH
ALL THE ADVOCATES AND HEARING
WHAT WE ALL HAVE TO SAY AND
WORKING THE DEPARTMENT OF CARE
SERVICES. AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS ARE DOING
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY JUSTICE
COOKED UP IN A CARE. GIVER FOR
FIFTY PLUS YEARS.
I'M IN FAVOR OF FAN FAMILIES BE
UNFUNDED AT TIME OF PLACEMENT
HOWEVER.
SO I BUT I'D LIKE TO SAY YOU
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR YEARS FOR
SIXTY ARE TO COME DOWN WHERE
FAMILIES WOULD GET CHANCES TO
TAKE THEIR KIDS ALL BUT LOVE
ALONE IS NOT GOING TO DO IT.
WE NEED.
FOR YOU TO GET THE EXPERIENCE
PEOPLE TO LOOK BACK AND SEE WHAT
YOU CAN DO TO KEEP THEIR LOC.
INTACT AND.
ROLL IT OUT IN A WAY THAT IT
DOES NOT CAUSE ANYBODY ANY HARM
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I AM NICOLE TREMBLE FROM LOS
ANGELES I AM A FOSTER PARENT FOR
SIX CHILDREN. ALL OF WHOM CAME
TO MY HOUSE
WITH NOTHING.
JUST THE CHILD DIFFERENT I WAS
OF THE NIGHT HIMSELF FOR THAT
REASON I AM IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF
FUNDING.
THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
MY STORY FOR OUR FAA APPROVAL AS
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN OTHERS
LIKE I WAS APPROVED IN LESS THAN
SIXTY DAYS HOWEVER I DID RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR SIX MONTHS.
AND SO FUNDING AT THE TIME OF
PLACEMENT NOT ONLY AS SUPPORTS
THE MORE THAN SUPPORTING THE
PROVIDER IT SUPPORTS THE
CHILDREN. AND I AM ALSO ASKING
THAT BEFORE WE ROLL OUT THE LOC
TOOL. THAT IT IS FULLY TESTED
AND VALIDATED THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY CARDINAL
FROM LOS ANGELES I'M A FOSTER
MOTHER TEN YEARS. I HAVE A
SIBLING SAID.
THAT HAS BEEN THROUGH.
CHUMP JUST DRAMATIC. WITH THEIR
FAMILY THEY WERE IN A SHOOT OUT
THE LITTLE BABY WAS FOUR YEARS
OLD SHOT.
I HAVE NOT RECEIVED PLATES ITEM
FUNDS.
AND IT'S HARD BECAUSE THESE KIDS
NEED THERAPY THEY SEE CERTAIN
CARS AND A DUCK.
SO I AM IN ALL SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDS BEING PLACED.
WHEN YOU RECEIVE THE CHILD.
AND PLEASE IMPLEMENT THE TOLL.
WHEN IT COMES OUT AND I THANK
YOU FOR HEARING ME THANK YOU
THINK MEN.
HI MY NAME'S NANCY TOURISM I'VE
HAD MY NEPHEW FOR ABOUT TEN AND
A HALF MONTHS I STILL HAVE NOT.
RECEIVED ANY PAYMENT TO OUR FAA.
OF. I ASKED THE. LEVEL OF CARE
TO BE VALIDATED BEFORE IT'S
IMPLEMENTED. AND ALSO I SUPPORT
FUNDING THE CONTINUE PAST JUNE
THIRTIETH AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
SEASON THE MY NEPHEW TEXTED ME.
TO SAY ON HIS BEHALF.
HE SAID ACT HE CAN YOU PLEASE
TELL THEM THAT I SHOULDN'T FEEL.
A BURDEN ON YOUR ANYBODY BECAUSE
FUNDING AND NOT COMING THROUGH.
AND.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SACRIFICE.
FOR ME TO BE TAKEN CARE OF.
HE ALSO SAID THAT.
HE SAID I SHOULDN'T FEEL
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT THE ADULTS
THAT HAVE FAILED ME AND NEITHER
SHOULD YOU.
THAT'S A TEXT FROM MY SEVENTY
YEAR OLD NEPHEW WHAT PATH.
THANK YOU. BECAME.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S AB LEMLEY
AND WOOD JUMPER ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH AND I'M HERE TO. AYE ONE
ADEPTLY ALSO UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF FUNNY AT THE TIME
THE PLACEMENT I THINK THE POINT
THAT JUST REYES IS REALLY
CRITICAL IS THE CHILDREN WHO ARE
BEING CARED FOR UNDERSTAND. THAT
THEY ARE A FINANCIAL BURDEN
UNTIL THIS PAYMENT STARTS I KNOW
WE ALL SHARE THAT GOAL. ON BUT
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
ADDRESSED.
AND THAT THERE ARE NO MORE GAPS
IN FUNDINGS FOR THESE CARE
GIVERS AND THEN ALSO JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THE POINT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THE LEVEL OF CARE
TOOL DOES ACHIEVE THE GOAL. AND
THAT DOES IS YOU KNOW FULLY
VALIDATED AND TESTED AND IT
SYNCS UP WITH OUR SPECIALIZED
CARE COMMENCE ON ON A COUNTY
LEVEL SO THAT AGAIN IT DOES
ACHIEVE THE GOAL WE WANT IT TO
WHICH IS TO GET CARE GIVERS TO
RESOURCES THAT YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO DILEMMA CURRICULA
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
CALIFORNIA.
OUT WE REPRESENT OVER THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTIES.
AND I APOLOGIZE.
NOT IS NOT THE WITH MY CLIENT.
I AM NOW POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH
THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER BUT IT
WAS A CASE CARRYING ATTORNEY FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
AND I WISH I COULD SAY THAT WAS
A ONE OFF BUT IT'S NOT I STOOD
IN COURT AND WATCH CHILDREN
REMOVED FROM RELATIVES WHO CARED
SO DEEPLY FOR THESE. CHILDREN
BUT CAN NO LONGER PROVIDE CARE
BECAUSE FUNDING DIDN'T COME
THROUGH. I HAD A THREE YEAR OLD
CLIENT WHO WAS REMOVED FROM HER
GRANDMOTHER THE ONLY CARE GIVER
SHINYA BECAUSE THE GRANDMOTHER
GOT AFFECTED AND SHE HAD WAITED
OVER YOUR FOR FUNDING. SO I
REALLY ASK THAT YOU EXTEND.
FUNDING I'M THAT EXTENDS PAST TO
JUNE THIRTIETH IT'S SO NEEDED
THESE CHILDREN DESERVE IT.
AND THAT THE LOC IS NOT
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL HAS BEEN FULLY
VALIDATED THINK YOU THINK MEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
FIRST TO JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
TO DIRECTOR OF LIGHT BOARD FOR
THE WORK AND. THE DEDICATION YOU
PUT INTO IMPLEMENTING CCR AND
ALL THE PEOPLE HERE IT IS
SOMETHING WE STRONGLY BELIEVE IN
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO GET
DONE.
BUT THERE IS A HUGE WORKLOAD
ISSUE AND HOW ARE DIRECTOR BOBBY
KEGEL HAS TAKEN THE TIME TO MEET
WITH OUR LEGISLATORS TO EXPRESS
THE NEEDS.
OF ART SIGNIFICANTLY LARGE
COUNTY.
AND TO EN YOU HEARD FROM THOSE
IN ON THE WITNESSES TODAY ON THE
IMPACT THIS HAS ON OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS HONOR FAMILIES.
WE HAVE DEDICATED.
THE PAPERS FUNDING IN AS A WAY
TO PROVIDE ARM. IN IMMEDIATE
RESOURCE TO OUR FAMILIES.
AS A SOCIAL WORKER AND A
THERAPIST I HAVE PROVIDED
TREATMENT AND SUPPORT FOR A
FOSTER CHILD WOULD FOSTER
CHILDREN REMOVED FROM THEIR
HOME.
THE COMPANY.
AND THAT FOSTER FAMILY HAS A
STEP UP TO THE PLATE.
AND PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT.
ONE THROUGH FOSTER CHILD WAS
TAKEN OUT OF HOME.
HELLO HER PHYSICAL INJURIES.
AND WHEN THAT FAMILY NEEDS TO
TAKE IN THAT CHILD THEY MAY NOT
RELY ON JUST THE MEDICAL SUPPORT
THAT THE DOCTOR THEY HAVE TO GO
BACK AND GET.
YOU KNOW MEDICAL ON CARE FOR THE
CHILD'S WE NEED THAT MONEY
STRAIGHT UP FRONT.
AND WE WERE AT LEAST ABLE TO
HELP THOSE FAMILIES BUT
IT HAS GONE WELL BEYOND THE
NINETY DAYS THAT WE PROVIDE TO
THE RESOURCE WE HAD LIKE SEVENTY
TWO PERCENT OVER. THE NINETY DAY
PROCESS.
AND OUR SOCIAL WORKERS AS I KNOW
AS A SOCIAL WORKER EXPERIENCE
SECONDARY TRAUMA SO WHEN WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WHEN WE'RE TALKING TO
THE FAMILIES. WHERE WE'RE DOING
THE CANS IN THE YELLOW SEA? IT'S
CHALLENGING AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DO IT RIGHT.
SO WE ARE JUST ONE OF THAT YOU
KNOW THAT IS IT'S GONNA BE VERY
CHALLENGING FOR US TO DO THAT.
THAT'S WHY IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT YOU HAVE TO GET THE
FUNDING WE NEED FOR THE ARE FAIR
APPROVAL PROCESS OUR BOARD IS
TAKING THIS ON AS A PRIORITY TO
MAKE SURE THIS GETS DONE.
STREAM THE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
WORK YOU HAVE DONE THROUGH AB
ONE TEN.
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEANT.
COOLEY COLBY FROM CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES I'M ALSO A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND A FORMER AND
CARE GIVER. ON BOTH AS A
RELATIVE AND AND IT'S AN
INTENSIVE TREATMENT FOSTER
PARENTS. AND I'D LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
WE SUPPORT FUNDING AT THE TIME
OF PLACEMENT.
AND ON THE WORK BEING DONE TO
PROVIDE STABILITY IN THAT THE
WORK THAT CIC IS DOING TO PUSH
FOR STABILITY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
IN CARE.
ON.
WE ARE THANKFUL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING ON
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
AND TRYING TO GET. THE SERVICES
IN THE FAMILIES WHEN IT'S
NEEDED.
THAT ON AND AND WERE SUPPORTIVE
OF TWENTY FOUR SEVEN URGENT
RESPONSE IT MINES FOR FOSTER
PARENTS.
AND.
THAT AS AND. AS A AN
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE.
A CASAS ACROSS THE STATE ON
ALMOST EIGHT THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS
WORKING WITH ALMOST.
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH
AND THEY'RE SEEING. ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF CCR
IMPLEMENTATION AND I KNOW THERE
ARE SO MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DREAM BECOMES A REALITY. ON AND
I THINK ALL OF YOU WHO ARE
WORKING ON THE DIFFERENT PIECES.
AND AND AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE IMPLEMENTATION IS EFFECTIVE
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT ON MAKING
SURE THAT THE LOC. IS AN
ACCURATE INVALIDATED AS AS
YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING IT BUT ON
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND AND LET'S
CONTINUE. THINKING
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DOUG JOHNSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE TO TELL THE
FAMILY SERVICES WE HAVE A
DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONS WAS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID. ARM I WORK
WITH THOSE OF OUR MEMBERS WHO
OPERATE GRUPOM SUGGEST YOUR
TEEPEES.
I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF
ENSURING THAT THAT COUNTIES HAVE
FOR THE CHILDREN WITH REALLY
CHALLENGING NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE STR TP
BEDS WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED.
I'M.
THAT'S A REALLY CRUCIAL GOAL
THAT WE HAVE TO ACHIEVE FOR THAT
SMALL SUBSET OF CHILDREN WHO
NEED IT FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
HOWEVER I DO NOT THINK THAT.
GIVING UP WATER GOAL OF MAKING
THE TRANSITION.
FROM GRUPOM TESTER TO BE BY THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR IS A
GOOD IDEA.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO FORGE.
THROUGH THAT PROCESS NOW ABOUT
TWENTY OF OUR MEMBERS.
ABOUT OF THE TWENTY SEVEN THAT
HELP OF A WE OWE MISTER BE
LICENSES ARE OUR MEMBERS. WE
HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS IN THOSE
SIXTY PERCENT OF SIXTY AGENCY
QUEUE TO GET THE REST YOUR TO BE
LICENSES OTHERS ARE WORKING
THROUGH A COUNTY APPROVAL
PROCESS.
ANYTHING THAT SLOWS THAT DOWN IS
A MAJOR PROBLEM WE HAVE A NUMBER
MEMBERS WITH US YOUR TO PEACE
ARE NOW CARRYING SIGNIFICANT
VACANCIES.
THEY'RE NOT FULL.
AND IF WITH FIXED COSTS THAT IS
DRAINING THEIR RESOURCES FAST IF
WE DON'T PUSH FORWARD WITH THIS
QUICKLY.
TO FRUITION
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE WAS GOING
TO GIVE US MORE TIME AND MORE
RESOURCES LATER. IT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY KILL SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE NOW
BUILDING.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE TO THINK
BE VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THAT
AND WE GET THE ALLIANCE ARE VERY
MUCH INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY PLACING AGENCIES AND
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO EXPEDITE THAT PROCESS
SO THAT WE ALL GET.
THE END OF THE DAY THE RESOURCES
WE NEED FOR THOSE HIGH INCOME
KIDS HIGH HIGH NEEDS KIDS AND
ALSO SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT
TRANSITION FOR THOSE KIDS. OUT
OF FOSTER CARE OUT OF GROUP CARE
AND TOWARDS HOME AND PERMANENCY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELA SOME
HAVE.
AND I'M A GRANDMOTHER FILES.
EIGHT CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
WHICH FIVE WERE PLACED IN MY
HOME.
ALL HAVE BEEN MEDICAL
DISABILITIES HOME BEING
TRAUMATIZED.
BY BEING PLACED IN FOSTER HOME
MORE REMOVED FROM ALL.
MY PROBLEM WITH THIS PROGRAM
IT'S BECAUSE.
I MONTROSE FINANCES BECAME A
GROUP PARLIAMENT FROM DAY ONE
WITHOUT THE KIDS INVOLVED IN MY
HOUSE.
I HELP THREE D. RATES IN MY
HOME.
AND THE OTHER TWO OF MEDICATIONS
ONE IS A THREE YEAR OLD IS NOT
MY BIOLOGICAL BUT BECAUSE HE'S A
PART OF THAT FAMILY IS MY TH
GRADE CHILD AS WELL.
I TOOK DOES KITTEN IN GOOD
FAITH.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAD SOME
STABILITY IN THEIR LIFE AND I
HAVE BUSTED.
MY BUT.
SEEM TO GO THERE KEEP GETTING
THEIR NEEDS MET BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS. HAS NOT
DEPEND FOR THEIR.
I HAD TO GET MY GRANDDAUGHTER A
NINE YEAR OLD WE MOVED OUT OF MY
HOUSE LAST THURSDAY.
BECAUSE OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT I COULD NOT TAKE CARE OF BY
MYSELF AND I PLEADED FOR MONTHS.
TO GET SERVICES FOR HER THAT
WOULD HELP HER IN THAT.
AREA WHICH NEVER HAPPENED.
I DID GET ANY REIMBURSEMENTS
THEY DISAPPROVE MY HOUSE IN
DECEMBER.
I CAN'T TAKE FIVE KIDS IT A
NISSAN SENTRA TO THEIR SITE
APPOINTMENTS
BECAUSE.
YOU CAN'T TRANSPORT THAT MANY
KIDS IN ON THE SATS ENTRY.
SO THESE FUND OF THE VERY
NECESSARY FOR ANYBODY THIS
BUILDING WITH KIDS AND THREATEN
ME IN MY SITUATION HELP FIGHT
WHEN TRYING TO GET ALL EIGHT
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN IN THE
SYSTEM SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE. AND THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
TOGETHER UP UNTIL THEY GOT BACK
WITH ME.
SO THAT WAS MY PURPOSE AND GOAL
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THOSE KIDS
BECAME A FAMILY AGAIN.
AT I'LL THE ANSWERS HELP. AND
THAT'S WHAT ABOUT KITTY.
SO BANKS FOR YOU GUYS PUT PATH
THAT BE GO UNFORTUNATELY ARE TO
DEBT BILL DIDN'T QUALIFY FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME BECAUSE IT'S JUST
COMING OUT BUT I'M THE WAITED
NEEDED MOST BECAUSE I HAVE FIVE
KIDS. THAT NEED MY HELP AND I'M
NOT GOING TO GIVE UP FOR THEM
AND LET HIM GO JUST BECAUSE I'M
NOT GETTING FRIENDLY BUT AT THE
SAME TOKEN. THEY NEED THOSE
WORDS BECAUSE THEY HAVE DOT
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT I HAVE TO
ASK PEOPLE TO COME TO MY HOUSE
AND. HELP WE TRANSPORT THEM.
YELLOW LATEST OUTSIDE
MEDICATIONS THAT THERE ARE YOU
KNOW IT'S A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT I'M DEALING WITH IT ONE OUT
AND I BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE OUR
MARIN GRUPO.
I DON'T GET PAID GROUP HOME I
DON'T EVEN GET PAID FOSTER CARE
FEES
SO THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
SOON VERY SOON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SUZANNE AND DEFEND MY CHILDREN
NOW HERE TO SPEAK ON THE LEVEL
OF CARE ISSUE AND FIRST IS ONE I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT FOR MOVING
TO A LEVEL OF CARE SYSTEM. AYE
DETERMINING AYE RATES BASED ON
THE NEEDS OF A CHILD IS AMAZING
THE PROBLEM IS IF YOU DON'T TAKE
THE TIME TO GET IT RIGHT. AND TO
VALIDATE THE TOOL AND TO MAKE
SURE IT'S GONNA WORK AND THEN
YOU DON'T TAKE TIME TO
IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY YOU
ACTUALLY DO MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
WE'VE JUST S. B. AWAY TO GO
THROUGH AN RFA PROCESS THAT WAS
RUSHED AND CHAOTIC AND THOUSANDS
OF FAMILY SUFFERED NEEDLESSLY
FOR A YEAR BECAUSE OF THAT AND
YOU'RE HAVING TO FIX IT NOW.
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING THAT YOU NOT
DO THE SAME THING WITH LSE THAT
YOU SLOW DOWN THAT YOU VALIDATED
THAT YOU GET IT RIGHT THAT YOU
WORK WITH REACHES RESEARCHERS.
THAT YOU MAKE SURE BEFORE YOU
ROLL IT OUT OF THESE FAMILIES
YOU KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT THEM. A HAVING A GOOD
GOAL OR A VISION ISN'T ENOUGH
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY WHAT'S DOING RIGHT FOR
THESE FAMILIES DON'T ASK THEM TO
SUFFER. WHILE YOU FLY THE PLANE
AND FIX IT AT THE SAME TIME
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
SUFFER. AND THAT JUST SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN SOME ASKING FOR A DELAY
UNMASKING FOR TRUE VALIDATION OF
THE TOOL BEFORE IT MOVES FORWARD
BIG. THANK YOU MA'AM.
A LUCY STILL SEE THE CARTER YOU
PLUS CENTER I'M JUST A COUPLE OF
THINGS I WANTED TO ADD.
THAT ONE IS WE'RE REALLY.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
RESOURCES FOR.
RESOURCE PARENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE WHAT THEY NEED.
AND IN THE LEVEL OF CARE
CONVERSATION.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FOCUS REALLY DOES STAY ON
THE NEEDS OF THE CHILDREN.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING IN
THINKING ABOUT SYSTEM REFORM.
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE AN
ITERATIVE PROCESS.
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE. A BIG
STEP FORWARD AND.
SOME MID COURSE CORRECTIONS SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S.
REALISTIC TO EXPECT AND AND WE
AGREE THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE CHILDREN ARE
THE FAMILIES.
EVER.
BUT WE DO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT ISN'T ENTERED OF PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE TO I'M GOING TO
BRING IT BACK UP TO THE DYESS
TWENTY QUESTIONS WE MAY HAVE.
AND I'M GOING TO BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVIEW.
.
THERE'S SO MANY QUESTIONS BUT I
THINK THE FIRST THING THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS THAT. I'VE
SAID IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO SIT UP
HERE AND TALK ABOUT.
A.
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
LIKE FOR THEIR BUDGET LINE
ITEMS AND I THINK THAT'S GOING
TO THE THE MOST FRUSTRATING
THING FOR ME. THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF IS THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
.
KIDS AND ADULTS WITH NEEDS AS IF
THEY'RE LINE ITEMS AND I CAN
APPRECIATE THE. THE.
OVERWHELMING.
JOB THAT THE DEPARTMENT HOUSE
BUT IT'S DIFFICULT TO.
TALK ABOUT A WILL WE'RE NOT
GOING TO FUND IT THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA FIND IT NEXT YEAR AS IF.
KIDS ARE. WAITING.
A.
AROUND EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE ON
HOLD AND THERE'LL BE NO ISSUES
IN THE MEANTIME AND I'M. I'M NOT
TRYING TO.
TO SAY THAT THAT THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
BUT BUT I KNOW THAT THE THE JOB
THAT YOU HAVE TO DO IS. IS.
TREMENDOUS
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE SO MUCH ON
YOUR TABLE BUT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT KIDS AND I HEAR THE
STORIES ABOUT REAL.
LIVES THAT ARE BEING AFFECTED
IT'S IT'S HARD FOR ME TO FIRST
OF ALL EVEN UNDERSTAND HOW
YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB I CAN
IMAGINE. A.
HOW?
YOU CAN YOU KNOW GO DAYS TODAY
WITHOUT HAVING THE THE STRESS.
IT THE STRESS.
THAT I'M FEELING RIGHT NOW THAT
WE FEEL ON A DAILY BASIS AND I
GET TO DO THIS YOU KNOW TWICE A
WEEK.
AND YOU NEED TO DO THIS EVERY
DAY AND SO I I WANT TO TELL YOU
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT WORK BUT
I NEED.
WE NEED SOME HELP
BECAUSE THESE KIDS ARE FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND THE
FAMILIES ARE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND I KEEP. I THINK YOU
ALREADY KNOW MY STORY BY NUYS
SAY THAT EVERY TIME A TEACHER.
I ON TOP OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE AT HOME.
I WOULD THEY'RE EXPECTED TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND LEARN.
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO BE
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
WHEN WHEN.
THE STORY ABOUT THE THE THE MOM
BEING BEAT AND THE KID BOTH
CHILD WITNESSING THIS EVERY DAY
AND HE STILL HAS TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
AND I ED AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
STRESS THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
UNDER.
BUT.
SOME POINT.
WE NEED AND LIKETHAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS OVERSIGHT HE.
IS THAT WHAT DO YOU NEED
FROM US SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THIS.
I DON'T KNOW FASTER I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHERE TO BEGIN ON WHAT WE
NEED BECAUSE WHAT I HEARD TODAY.
I'VE I'VE HEARD.
FINDING THE APPROVAL PROCESS.
AT THAT THE LOCK OF PROTOCOL ALL
OF THESE ISSUES BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY THEM LONGER WE TAKE.
TWO TO TO FIGURE THIS OUT
THERE'S KIDS THAT ARE BEING
AFFECTED ARE YOU WHAT WAS THAT
THE OTHERS EIGHT HUNDRED KIDS
AND LA COUNTY WITHOUT PLACEMENT.
I THE HOW IS IT THAT.
WE.
I HAVE.
MONEY AVAILABLE AND IT'S TAKING
SO LONG FOR SOME OF THESE
PARENTS AYE ULCER I WAS TOO LONG
TOO MANY THINGS TO TAKE NOTES ON
I WAS TRYING TO KEEP UP BUT. THE
OTHER THING THAT I HEARD WAS.
.
THE.
THE KIDS ARE BEING REMOVED
FROM HOMES.
BECAUSE OF WHATEVER ISSUES AND
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT WAS
MADE WAS WE ARE SCOURING THE
KIDS.
BUT THEN WHAT ABOUT THE FAMILIES
THAT ARE WILLING TO TAKE THESE
KIDS IN BUT YET ARE REMOVED
THERE I'M SURE THEY HAVE TO BE
DISCOURAGED AND WON'T TAKE
ANOTHER CHILD AND.
BECAUSE NOW IN THIS PROCESS
DIDN'T WORK SO NOT ONLY ARE WE
HARMING THE CHILDREN BUT WE'RE
LOSING FAMILIES THAT CAN BE
POTENTIAL.
A CAREGIVERS FOR THESE KIDS AND
I'M NOT TALKING. DARK DON'T LIKE
PORN PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT I'M
NOT TRYING TO PLACE BLAME ON
ANYBODY.
BUT AT SOME POINT.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO ASSIST YOUR DEPARTMENT AND
ALL OF THESE. TO DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES IT'S HEART BREAKING.
AND AGAIN I CAN APPRECIATE THE
STRESS YOU'RE UNDER BECAUSE I
TRY.
TO.
OF.
BE HERE TODAY AND TRY TO MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ISSUE TOMORROW
BECAUSE IF I SIT.
AND AND THINK ABOUT THIS ALL THE
TIME I WOULD BE A MESS
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND I CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE IF MY KIDS. WERE
UNDER IN THE SYSTEM I CAN'T.
MY DAUGHTER SICK RIGHT NOW AND
I'M THINKING MY GOD WHAT AM I
GONNA DO BUT THANK GOD I HAVE.
BUT HELP I HAVE A CARE GIVER. I
HAVE MEDICAL INSURANCE.
SHOT TO GO TO THE DOCTOR
YESTERDAY AND I WASN'T ABLE TO
GO WITH HER AND MY MY SITTER
TOOKER. TOOK CARE OF THE
MEDICINE BROUGHT SO THAT I CAN
DO WHAT I DO HERE. AND SO I'M
LUCKY.
I FEEL BLESSED IN THAT RESPECT
THAT I AM ABLE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE I CAN STILL HAVE MY KIDS
WITH ME BUT THERE'S FAMILIES
HERE.
THAT.
ARE COMING TO US ENDS.
LITERALLY SCREAMING FOR HELP.
THE IT IN TERMS OF THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY ON ARM AS TO WHAT CAN
WE DO FOR YOU.
FIRST YOU YOU DID A VERY BIG
THING WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB ONE
TEN DOT REALLY HELPED RESOLVE A
LOOMING PROBLEM.
THE.
THING WE WILL THEN ASK YOU TO DO
IS WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU IN
THE MAY REVISION WITH OUR
PROPOSAL FOR CRITICAL AT THE
LONG TERM. SOLUTION RIGHT BUT
BUT MAY I COME IN THERE AND JUST
A SECOND SO YES WE PASSED THE
BE.
UP WHEN TEN BY.
THE FAMILIES ARE TESTIFYING THAT
IT'S TAKING SIX MONTHS FOR THEM
TO GET ANY KIND OF FUN.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK WITH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES THAT THEY'RE
COMING FROM BECAUSE THE THE
RESOURCES OF THEIR.
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S UP THIS
ORGANIZATIONAL LIFTS UPSET OR
THAT THEY'VE THEY'VE GOT TO WORK
TO. PUT PART OF THAT SORT OF.
WE.
MANY NOT MANY SOME ISSUES.
OUR FOR PRE DATING.
CONTINUOUS CARE REFORM SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
SOME COUNTIES ALWAYS MADE A
PRACTICE IN THE PAST WHEN A
CHILD WAS PLACED THEY WOULD MAKE
A THE MEDIA PAYMENT THROUGH
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE OR CAL
WORKS OR WHATEVER.
SOME COUNTIES DIDN'T MAKE
THAT.
PAYMENT IMMEDIATELY THEY WAITED
UNTIL THEY'VE APPROVED.
THROUGH THE FOSTER CARE APPROVAL
PROCESS.
WHICH NOW THAT THAT WOULD DIDN'T
CREATE THE CRISIS HOWEVER THEN
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T TAKE OF LAW.
WHEN WE WENT TO THE RFA PROCESS
WHICH EVERYBODY DID BECAUSE IT
WAS A GOOD THING TO DO BECAUSE
THAT WAY YOU ARE ESTABLISHING AT
THE BEGINNING. THAT POTENTIALLY
THIS IS A HOME THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE PERMANENTLY FOR
STABILITY.
IF
REUNIFICATION DOESN'T WORK.
HOWEVER IT ADDED TIME TO THE
PROCESS AND SO THAT'S REALLY
SORT OF THE FIX.
YOU DID. ARM.
PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO SORT
OF MOVE THROUGH A I MEAN IT JUST
WENT INTO EFFECT. IN MARCH
SO IT MADE WERE IN APRIL.
SO.
WOULD WANTED AFFECT ABLE FIRST
WORD PEOPLE ELEVEN SO THERE
THERE PROBABLY IS A LITTLE BIT
OF THROUGHPUT TIME HERE.
ARM BUT.
THAT WILL BE SORT OF THE SHORT
TERM SOLUTION THAT AS I SAID
WILL COME TO YOU IN THE MAY
REVISION RIGHT WITH A LONG TERM
THANK YOU BUT.
AND AND I SAID THIS IN MY SAY
THEM.
I AM A LOT OF COMMITTEES THAT I
SIT ON AND I'M SAYING I SAID IT
ON MONDAY.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT AND COMPLICATED THE
PROCESSES YET WE'RE THE ONES
THAT CREATE THE PROCESS.
SO I MEAN IF WE CREATE A PROP
THEN WHY DO WE MAKE IT SO
COMPLICATED. AYE THAT'S MY RIGHT
YOU KNOW IT WE GO AGAIN BACK.
YOU KNOW WHO WE FELT FEET A SET
I THINK BURKE IF SHE WAS WHAT
WAS HAVE THE WORDS OF IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL IS A CULTURE
CHANGE HERE. AND BOTH TAKE A
LITTLE BIT AYE AYE EDITOR LIKE
THEM AND ACTOR LA AND LIKE ONE
BUT BUT FOR ME AND AND I. AM NOT
GOING BACK TO MY TEACHING
ANALOGY IS THAT IF I CREATE A
TEST.
AND THEN COMPLAIN THAT THE KISS
FAILED THE TEST BECAUSE IT WAS
TOO HARD WHILE I CREATE AT THE
TEST.
AND SO SO. YOU KNOW AND I THINK
THAT'S THE THE EVENT IS NOT JUST
FROM YOU I HEAR IT FROM THIS
WHOLE PLACE IS THAT. THIS IS A
COMPLETE IT'S A COMPLICATED THIS
IS COMPLICATE WILL OF COURSE WE
ARE CREATING IT AND IF IT'S AT
SOME POINT HOW DO I.
ENCOURAGE OR HOW DO YOU
ENCOURAGE YOUR DEPARTMENTS OR
THE COUNTIES TO PUT A HARD INTO
WITH THESE PRODUCTS A FEW
THERE'S A THERE'S A BIG HEART.
IT EVERYWHERE ELSE BUT THEM THEN
WHERE IS THE URGENCY.
I DON'T SEE ANY URGENCY BECAUSE
LET ME TELL YOU WHEN MY DAUGHTER
WAS SICK I WAS ON THE PHONE AND
AND IT'S. IT'S A REALLY SMALL.
YOU KNOW A A EXAMPLE BUT I WAS
ON THE PHONE CALLING MAKING SURE
THAT SOMEBODY COULD TAKE HER TO
THE DOCTOR THAT SOMEBODY CAN YOU
KNOW ALL THESE THINGS BECAUSE IT
WAS. PERSONAL BECAUSE I WAS LIKE
FREAKED OUT.
THAT THAT I WAS HERE AND I CAN
BE WITH MY DAUGHTER.
SO THE BET NEXT BEST THING WAS
TO CALL SOMEBODY TO HELP ME AT
SOME POINT WHERE IS THAT URGENCY
HOW CAN WE.
A INJECT THE URGENCY.
TO.
SOME OF THE FOLKS AND LOOK THAT
IS NOT BE. A.
.
BLIND TO THE FACT THAT THERE'S
SOME WE CALL THEM COUNTY
EMPLOYEES THEY'VE EMPLOYEES ARE
CITY EMPLOYEES WHATEVER YOU
WANNA CALL THEM THAT WE JUST
KNOW THAT THE THE NORMAL. A A
PIECE
OF THOSE COUNTY EMPLOYEES IS
LIKE AND WILL LET ME GO GO LET
ME GO LUNCH I'LL BE BACK WITH
YOU JUST FILL OUT THIS FORM.
AND THAT REPUTATION ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT WEAK CREED THAT
REPUTATION WAS CREATED BECAUSE
OF THE RESULTS BECAUSE OF WHAT
WE SEE ON A DAILY BASIS AND I I.
I DON'T KNOW AND I FEEL
FRUSTRATED.
AND I TRIED TO HOLD BACK BUT I
YOU KNOW THAT'S FIRST OF ALL
THAT'S NOT MY STYLE.
AS YOU ALL HAVE SEEN BUT
SECONDLY I DON'T WANT IT ATTACK
AND BLAME YOU FOR ANY OF THIS
BUT THEN.
WHERE IS THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
THE URGENCY OF WHAT THESE
FAMILIES AND? THE FAMILIES BUT
THE KIDS THAT THE KIDS NEED TO
WHERE WE STEP IN AND HELP THEM
ABSOLUTE.
I I HOPE I'M NOT SOUNDING
DEFINATLY WHEN I SAY THIS.
I THINK MISTER JOHNSON FROM THE
ALLIANCE MADE THE POINT WHEN HE
GOT UP HERE
WE CREATE THE URGENCY BY SAYING
THIS HAS GOT TO GET DONE.
THAT'S WHAT WE GET THE URCHINS
START THAT DIRECT LIGHT BURNED
THIS HAS TO GET DONE RIGHT.
I'M WITH YOU.
YES I'M.
I MEAN. IF I COULD GET ONE MORE
VOTE ROAD HERE.
I MEAN DON'T RUN RAMPAGE WE'RE
TOLD THEM THE SAME PAPER ON THE
SAME PAGE RIGHT NOW SO SO.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
HEARING ME AND LIKE I SAID IT'S
FRUSTRATION NOT BECAUSE OF OF
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS WHAT'S
NOT GETTING DONE AND YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY. THAT'S WHY EUROPE
EUROPE BECAUSE THAT'S WHO YOU
ANSWER TO AND TO ME I CAN'T GOAL
AND AND DIRECT YOU KNOW LOCAL
COUNTIES AND GO YELL AT A STAFF
MEMBER BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT DOING
THE PAST THAT. YOUR IT. I MEAN
THIS IS WHERE I YOU KNOW I CAN.
EXPRESS MY FRUSTRATIONS SO I DO
HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT.
IT
I I KNOW WE ARE ALL GOING TO
TALK ABOUT BUT THE THE THE LOCK
TOOL THAT'S ALSO BE CONCERNED.
HOW IS IT AND IF I DON'T KNOW
ALL ABOUT IT SO IF YOU CAN HELP
ME THE LOCK TO WAS DEVELOPED BY
WHOM?
IT WAS DEVELOPED IN A
CONSULTATIVE PROCESS WITH COUNTY
FARM CHILD WELFARE FOLKS AND OUR
DEPARTMENT OF SOME ADVOCATE SAT
IN ON THE PROCESS I DON'T WANT
TO CLAIM THAT THEY BLESSED TO
KNOW NONE BECAUSE THEY MAY NOT
OKAY SO THAT'S MY QUESTION
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS
SIMPLE. ACTS
I UNDERSTAND THAT. THERE WERE
THERE WERE WRITTEN
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE THAT WERE
NOT FOLLOWED.
AND THAT THE BILL SOMETIMES
HAPPEN AYE THE BILL NO NO NO NO
NO RIGHT TO IT WHICH I'M NOT
GONNA VERSION OF A BILL SOMETIME
HAPPEN WE'RE EXPECTED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NO.
AND THOUGH SOMETIMES HAPPEN IS
NOT A GOOD ENOUGH ANSWER BECAUSE
IT THIS IS SUPPOSED TO DETERMINE
THE LEVEL OF CARE FOR CHILDREN.
BOWLS DOT SOMETIMES HAPPEN IS
NOT A GOOD ENOUGH ANSWER THE
THAT THE COUNTY TEAM THAT WORKED
ON DEVELOPING IT BASED ON WHAT
THEY CONSIDER TO BE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL SPECIALIZED CARE.
INCREMENTAL TOOLS.
IN USE IN THE STATE THAT'S
PROBABLY AS GOOD A STANDARD AS
ONE CAN GET IN ADVANCE NO I
FULLY GET THIS NOTION OF. WELL
HOW DO YOU TEST IT WELL HOW DO
YOU TEST IT HOME WELL. I USE THE
EXAMPLE OF RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL WILL BE THAT OF YOUR
LONG PILOT FOR COUNTIES AND IT
SEEMED TO BE GOING GREAT AND
THEN YOU GO TO THE NEXT PLACE.
AND THERE'S A HICCUP
SO. AT SOME POINT HERE'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO.
START
AND AS WE GET THE RESULTS IN IF
THERE ARE INCONSISTENT FIRST.
NO ONE WHO CURRENTLY HAS A
SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENT LOSES
THEIR SPECIALIZED CARE
INCREMENT.
AS THE LOC IS IMPLEMENT
THAT'S AN ABSOLUTE.
THANKS TO THE BACK OF DONE.
SECOND.
THE LOC RATES.
WITH THE EXCEPTIONOF FOR THE
OLDEST KIDS IN AFRICA IS THE LOC
RATES ARE HIGHER THAN ALL OF THE
PAID RATE SPREE LOC.
SO.
THEY'RE IF THEY'RE NOT GETTING
THE PAYMENT
WHAT.
AB THAT WHILE THEY'RE DUMB
DUMBER WHICH WAY IF WE DO THE
ALIVE AND I MEAN WE CAN HANDLE
NIGHT SO WHAT WE'RE ASSUMING
THAT IT WENT INTO EFFECT APRIL
FIRST THE MONEY'S GOING TO GO
THROUGH. NOW THE QUESTION IS
WHAT FEMA.
AND THE.
WITH THE YELLOW SEA TOUR.
EVEN AT THE ALOSI ONE LEVEL THE
BASIC LEVEL
ARM THERE'S. THERE'S NO HARM.
THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HAVE S.
C. EYES DON'T LOSE THEM NOW
THERE IS A QUESTION THAT THE
ADVOCATES POSE IT'S A VALID ONE
WHICH IS WHAT IF.
IN THE PAST.
THEY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN AN S. C.
I..
ABOVE THE OLD RATE
HOW DOES THAT GET WORKED IN THE
FUTURE AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS
SAYING BEFORE WE CAN BE WORKING
WITH THE COUNTIES TO SAY.
IF.
SOMETIMES HAVE VERY SMALL ASCII
RATES YOU KNOW.
THIRTY BUCKS HUNDRED BUCKS TWO
HUNDRED BUCKS.
THE CHANCES ARE THE LOC GOOD
EXCEED THAT OVER THE GATE.
SOME COUNTIES NOTABLY I MEAN ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST COUNTY HAS SOME.
VERY HIGH A LOT ASCII RITZ.
ALL THERE BUT THAT ARE
DESCENDING IS THEIR PLAN TO
CONTINUE DOING THEIR S. C. AYE
SYSTEM UNTIL THEY HAVE REVISED.
AND.
AGAIN.
IN ESSENCE
THERE IS NO HARM CERTAINLY NO
HARM TO ANYBODY WHO'S CURRENTLY.
I MEAN
THEY CAN ONLY GET.
A HIGHER AMOUNT.
AND THEN.
IF.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THERE IS
EVIDENCE COMING IN THAT SAYS
SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN ON.
IT INCREMENTAL INCREASE A BOLD
THAT AND FOR SOME REASON DIDN'T
THEN THAT'S WHAT WE ARE JUST
GOING FORWARD BUT IF WE STOP AND
SAY NOPE WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
THING.
I LOOKED EIGHT DECIMAL PLACES.
ACCURATE BEFORE WE START WE HAVE
IN STOCK.
THAT'S JUST THE TRUTH.
OKAY.
THIS IS
YEAH WE SHOULD HAVE A DAY LONG
MEETING.
MEETINGS ARE HOSTILE TO BE
HONEST I'M NOT I DON'T KNOW AND
I ALREADY SHADE UPON SHADE THAT
BUT RIGHT OUT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
I SAID I APPRECIATE.
THE AMOUNT OF STRESS THAT YOU
MUST BE UNDER THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU'RE NOT COMING HERE IN AMMAN
SITTING UP THERE NOW. UNITS
ITEMS BUT.
BUT AGAIN THE FRUSTRATION IS
THAT THE THESE ARE KIDS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH TOTAL YOU
KNOW AND AND AND THEY'RE NOT
GETTING WHAT THEY NEED. THE
FAMILIES ARE NOT RECEIVING THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND THEN
THE THE THE.
LET ME SWITCH TO NOW THE GROUP
HOME RIGHT SITUATION UP MORE
TALKING ABOUT.
.
GETTING THESE KIDS OUT OF GROUP
HOMES BUT YET THE.
FAMILIES.
ARE NOT GETTING WHAT FAMILIES.
THAT EVEN TRUST THE
SYSTEM TO EVEN PARTICIPATE IN IN
IN BEING FOSTER PARENTS SO HOW
IS IT YOU KNOW IT.
IT SOUNDS ALL GREAT AND LET ME
TELL YOU WHAT I HEAR THIS IS
WHAT I HEAR. THIS IS GREAT. UP
WE HAVE A.
BOTH THE WORDS AND I HAVE TO BE
REALLY HONEST WRAPAROUND
SERVICES JUST SOMETIMES TO SOUND
LIKE A WORD.
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A PROPER
ROB WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR
THESE FAMILIES AND THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO AND ON PAPER IT'S
BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S AMAZING.
THE I A IF YOU PRESENTED AND
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PLANT BUT
REALISTICALLY IT'S NOT.
IMPLEMENTABLE.
IF THAT'S EVEN A WORD BUT
BECAUSE.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO? CLOSE DOWN
THESE GROUP HOMES WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE ADEQUATE UP ARE A PROCESS
NUMBER ONE TO GET THESE FAMILIES
APPROVED WHICH I HOPE THAT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID THEY WERE
WORKING ON.
BUT WE'RE GONNA PUT THEM.
SO WE'RE CLOSING THESE GROUP
HOMES BUT YET WE'VE GOT NO
FAMILIES TO TAKE THESE KIDS AND
THEN.
THESE ARE NOT.
BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL OF TRAUMA
THAT THEY'VE HAD MOVING AROUND
THIS IS NOT. YOU KNOW YOU.
THEY ALL COME AND TAKE THIS KID
ALL OF COURSE WE'VE GOT NO
ISSUES NO PROBLEMS THESE ARE
KIDS WITH. REALLY SERIOUS TRAUMA
IN THEIR LIVES AND. IF WE DON'T
FIND. THE RIGHT PLACEMENT FOR
THEM THEN WE'RE DONE BUT THEN.
THE RIGHT PLACEMENT THAT'S
AVAILABLE WE'RE NOT DOING WHAT
WE.
CAN FOR THEM SO BLOW RIGHT
POLICEMEN MAY NOT EVEN WANT TO
BE A FOSTER PARENT BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT DOING RIGHT BY THEM EITHER.
AND SO I CAN'T RECONCILE. IN MY
MIND HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS.
CLOSE THE GROUP HOMES OR. MOVE
THEM INTO YOU KNOW FAMILY
THE FAMILIES AVAILABLE SO HOW IS
IT THAT THIS IS GOING TO AND
THEN IT'S SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN
I'LL BE BY DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST.
I.
LITTLE WHILE AGO WE AGREED THAT
WE GOTTA GET IT DONE NOW RIGHT
OKAY AT THE ANSWER OKAY. BUT BUT
BUT YES
SO WHAT I WILL I WILL.
LEAVE IT AT THAT FOR NOW.
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT WE HAVE
TO DISCUSS BUT THE THE FUND BE
THE TAKE AWAY. FROM ME THAT I
WOULD LIKE YOU TODAY'S WE GOT TO
GET IT DONE NOW NUMBER ONE IF
YOU NEED HELP.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST YOU
BUT SO THAT YOU CAN ASSIST THE
COUNTIES IN DOING THIS BECAUSE
THAT'S I I DON'T WANNA BE HERE
NEXT YEAR AND WE ARE HAVING THE
SAME CONVERSATION I'VE SAY IT
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND THE FAMILIES THEY CAN THANK
YOU FOR SPEAKING UP THANK YOU
FOR COMING YEAR I MEAN THE
BRAVERY FROM THESE THESE LADIES
TO TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO US
ABOUT IT. BUT THEY'RE DATING
COME JUST TO SPEAK.
BECAME FOR SOME RESOLUTION
BECAME FOR SOME RESULTS AND SO.
FOR NOW BECAUSE I KNOW I'M.
INTO A I WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT
BUT I DO EXPECT
THAT THE CONVERSATION THAT WE
HAD WAS WE GET TO IT WE HAVE TO
DO IT TODAY THAT I WILL GET SOME
FOLLOW UP.
FROM YOU OR THE DEPARTMENT AS TO
WHAT HOW WE'RE DOING AND HOW.
REALLY THAT'S THE LOCK PROGRAM
IS GOING TO BE TESTED.
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE
THE DEADLINE OF TWELVE THIRTY
ONE FOR ME TO BE HONEST I THINK
WE SHOULD. A DELAY IT UNTIL WE
ARE SURE A HUNDRED PERCENT SURE
EVEN NINETY PERCENT SURE THAT
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
IF WE'RE NOT EVEN AT THAT LEVEL.
IT WERE GOING TO DRAMATIZE AND
RE TRAUMATIZE MORE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
I SHARE IN YOUR DESIRE TO GET
THIS DONE.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
ENSURES THAT WE GET IT DONE
RIGHT.
CAN WE DO WELL BY FAMILIES.
AND SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS AND FOR
SPECIFIC AREAS. FIRST I WANTED
TO FOCUS ON THE RFA.
I.
THINK THAT MANY OF US CAN AGREE
THAT THE DELAYS WE'VE SEEN ARE
UNACCEPTABLE AND DO WANT TO SEE.
WHAT THE YOU HAVE IMPLEMENTED
HOW WE HAVE INCREASED AND
STREAMLINED AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO
ASK IS FOR YOU TO? REPORT BACK
TO US THE BACKLOG AT THE TIME OF
THE MAY REVISION TALKING GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
YOU'RE DOING WHAT THE RFA
PROCESS.
IN TERMS OF FUNDING AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT.
I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO DO AS
GENEROUS OF A PROPOSAL AS
POSSIBLE.
AT MAY REVISION TO BEGIN ON JULY
FIRST.
I'VE HEARD THE FAMILIES AND
REALLY BELIEVE IN WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING AND NEED. US TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE WE CAN DO THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF CARE
TOOL IMPLEMENTATION.
GIVEN THE CONCERNS THAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY IN THE CONSTRAINTS
OF THE PILOT.
AND OUR DESIRE TO HAVE A YIELD A
GREAT TOOL.
IS IT POSSIBLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER A
SIXTY DAY DELAY.
OR HOW CAN WE INSURE THAT WE GET
IT IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY.
NOT ARAMBULA WITH WITH RESPECT
AYE I CAN'T ASSURE A SIXTY DAY
DELAY WHEN I CAN ASSURE IS A
NUANCED VERY THOUGHTFUL
VERY REFLECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION
IF ANYTHING IS.
PRODUCING.
RESULTS.
THAT WOULD IN A SENSE.
MIMIC A PILOT THAT SHOWS US THAT
WE'RE GETTING.
FALSE NEGATIVES OR FALSE
POSITIVES.
ALL WE WILL ANSWER EXCUSE BUT
WHAT YET WHY CAN'T WE DO A SIXTY
DAY DELAY IF YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT TOO BECAUSE IT.
IF YOU'RE WE ARE IN A WE ARE
COMMITTING TO.
GETTING THINGS DONE.
KLAY WE HAVE TO START.
WE HAVE TO START IF WE DELAY. A
WE DELAY BE IF WE DELAY BE WE TO
LACI.
THESE ARE SORT OF GIVENS
AND I WOULD RATHER.
START AS I SAID IN A NUANCED
REFLECTIVE MODE WITH THE ABILITY
TO. CORRECT STOP OR WHATEVER
NGUYEN RESULTS ARE COMING IN IF
WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO VALIDATE
WHAT ABOUT IT WHERE WE'RE GONNA
FIND WE CANNOT PICK SOME PLACES
TO START.
BUT WHAT IT MEANS
ARMED.
THAT'S EFFECTIVELY WATER IS A
GRADUAL START WEBER WHAT WE'RE
STARTING WITH.
OR THE. OR THE CHILDREN COMING
INTO CARE NEW.
AFTER A CERTAIN DATE NO WE'VE
ALREADY MADE THE PROFICIENT OUT
OF A COUNTY SAYS IT'S NOT READY
TO START.
THEY CAN NOTIFY US
AND THEY WILL GIVE THEM A
DIFFERENT DATE.
IF THEY HAVEN'T TRAINED UP THERE
STOP
THE CRANE UP.
AND THE READY TO START THEN THEY
WILL START NOT WITH HUNDREDS OR
THOUSANDS OF THESE POLICIES WE
ARE TALKING TENDS.
A DAY SORT OF THING.
I WAS THOSE.
I THOUGHT EVALUATION CONTINUES
FROM OUR OUR RESEARCH CONTRACT
WE WILL GET.
WE WON'T NECESSARILY GET
VALIDITY.
WHAT WE WILL GET IS RELIABILITY
ARE WE GETTING INTER RATER
RELIABILITY
THAT'S TESTIMONY?
AREN'T I DON'T WANNA TALK ABOUT
VERY PRELIMINARY DATA THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN ALREADY BECAUSE IT'S
SMALL BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO
FAR.
IN THE FFA TEST IS CONSISTENT
INTER RATER RELIABILITY I'M NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THE RELIABILITY
FROM WHAT I CAN SEE YET.
NOT LIKE.
TOTALLY GET LEAVE MY SELF WHEN
TO COME BACK IN A WEEK OR TWO
THAT WILL.
SORRY IF IT'S GOING THE
DIRECTION WE'RE GONNA DO SOME
DIFFERENT.
BUT AS LONG SECURING RELIABILITY
THEN THE QUESTION ABILITY STARTS
TO BE AS THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE
ALSO DOING SCR EVALUATIONS OF
DOING IT WILL SAVE.
ARE THEY DIVERGE.
IF THEY'RE DIVERGING WE'VE GOT A
PROBLEM WE'VE GOT OF POLLITT
BACK AND SEE WHERE WE ARE IF
IT'S NOT DIVERGING.
WE ARE GETTING CLOSER TO
FEELING.
FEELING THAT.
IN TO IT THAT THIS IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE NO WE COMMITTED.
THAT WE WOULD COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TWO YEARS AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATES.
TO REPORT ON.
ADEQUACY OF BOTH THE AMOUNTS
THAT WE HAD BUDGETED.
AND THE.
WHETHER KIDS ARE WHAT FAMILIES
WERE WINDING UP GETTING BRIGHTER
WHERE THEY NEED TO KIDS AND
THEREFORE THEIR CAREGIVERS.
SO WE WILL DO THAT THESE ARE I
MEAN AS LUPUS IS ALSO TO SET
THESE ARE INTERIM RATES IT'S AN
INTERIM TOOL.
BUT WOULD YOU START SOMEWHERE
IF YOU DON'T START DON'T START
IF YOU DON'T STOP WE. DON'T GET
IT DONE.
INDULGE ME IF YOU CAN THEN
BROUGHT BECAUSE THIS IS APRIL
ELEVENTH AND WE'RE LOOKING AT A
START DATE OF MAY FIRST. IS IT
POSSIBLE FOR ME IN TERMS OF NEXT
STEPS FOR US.
TO HAVE OUR STAFF BE BRIEFED AND
TO MEET WITH YOU AS WELL AS TO
DISCUSS WITH THE UC DAVIS
RESEARCHERS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE. LOC TOOL.
SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FIRSTHAND
WHAT CAN AND CANNOT.
DELIVER BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH.
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN WE HAD A
MEETING SCHEDULED LAST WEEK
WHICH I CANCELED ON MY NOTE
CAUSED A BIT OF A FALSE SIX WE
HAD SO LITTLE DATA IN YET. THAT
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THREE IN
ALL THREE CASES ARE SELECTED.
ACT OF SEVENTEEN SOME.
ALL WEEKS ARE EXPECT THAT IN.
TWO WEEKS FROM NOW WE'LL BE
REPUBLIC OF.
FIFTY
SIXTY
WE WILL WE WILL LIKELY HAVE
THEM.
ON ALL OF THE EIGHTY CASES
SCORED AT LEAST ONCE YEAH BOTH
ONE RAIDER IN THAT. IN WITHIN
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS AND LIKELY
AT LEAST TWO RAIDERS FOR EACH OF
THE EIGHTY CASE SO WE WERE
BEGINNING TO SEIZE UP BUT AGAIN
I I REALLY WANT TO BE. CAREFUL
SIR
THAT IT THAT WE DON'T.
LATER I HAVE A FEELING THAT WE
DIDN'T LIVE UP TO SOMETHING IN
BRIEFING THE STAFF AT CENTER
THAT'S NOT THE SAME AS SAYING.
AUTUMN.
WE'RE REALLY PUTTING IT OFF I
MEAN WITWER BRIEFING SO THAT
EVERYONE GETS A GROWING SENSE OF
AWARENESS AS TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SOMETHING
FROM THE DYESS IS A.
OF FRUSTRATION FROM FEELING AS
HAVE WE BEEN INCLUDED IN SOME OF
THIS DISCUSSION SO THAT WE CAN
GET TO THE SAME COMFORT LEVEL
THAT IT APPEARS THAT YOU ARE AT.
AND SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO ASK IS
AN ABILITY FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS THIS MONTH.
BEFORE ANYTHING IS IMPLEMENTED
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER GET A
SENSE OF.
DIRECTIONS REGARDING THIS TOOL
AND ALLEN.
WOULD ASK AGAIN THAT WE BE ABLE
TO MEET OVER THE NEXT WEEK OR TO
TO SPEND THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THAT'S NECESSARY. TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S
BEFORE US IN.
IN TERMS OF.
PLANNING FOR A START DATE OF
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN.
WE KNOW WHAT YOU'RE ATTEMPTING
TO UNDERTAKE IS SIGNIFICANT AND.
YET I BELIEVE WE ALSO HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT CONTINGENCIES.
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO IN.
ADDITION TO THE SIX MAJOR
REFORMS THAT WE HAD TALKED
ABOUT.
BUT IF THERE WAS A POSSIBILITY
TO COME UP WITH CONTINGENCY PLAN
JUST IN CASE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO.
REALIZE THAT WHILE WE ASPIRE TO.
THIS DREAM.
THERE MIGHT NOT BE REALIZABLE
BY THE END OF THE YEAR AND HAVE
TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT THAT.
IF I SAID WHAT DID MY MIND.
WASN'T WORKING HAD CONTINUED IT
OUT OBVIOUSLY NOT.
LOSE MY CREDIBILITY ARM.
HOWEVER I THINK ANY
CONTINGENCIES WE LOOK AT HALF
BAD INCENTIVES AND DISINCENTIVES
THAT WERE BUILT IN SO THAT WE
DON'T WIND UP.
CREATING PERVERSE INCENTIVES
AT THE END OF THE DAY ARM. I'M
I'M. A MEMBER OF READING ONCE
THAT OF THE GENERAL EISENHOWER
HAD PANS A. SPEECH TO GIVE IF
THE INVASION HAD FAILED ALL SO
GOOD I DON'T THINK ANYONE
DOESN'T. AT ONE LEVEL SAY YES.
THINGS MAY NOT.
LINE UP THE WAY BE WANTING TO
BUT THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING
INCENTIVES IN THE RIGHT PLACES.
THAT PEOPLE ARE MOTIVATED.
TO BE DOING IT THAT THE WHATEVER
THE INERTIAL.
TENDENCIES ARE IN JUST THE
GOVERNMENT I MEAN ON THIS I'VE
REALLY. NOT CALLING ON ANYBODY
PUT THERE ARE INERTIAL
TENDENCIES
THAT WE DON'T SORT OF.
SLIPPED TO THE LOSE.
ON THEM BECAUSE OUR OUR COUNTY
SUB.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO WORKING ON
IT WITH A LOT OF PROJECTS ON
THEIR PLATES.
OB KEEPING OUR YOU KNOW OUR OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERS
FOCUSED ON ON BOARD AMID EVER
EVER EVERYBODY HAS OF THE
THINGS.
YES THEIR DATA TO YOUR QUESTIONS
OPERABLE IT IS YES.
THANK YOU UP THERE'S MUCH MORE
FOR US TO DISCUSS ON THIS ISSUE
BUT I DON'T THINK WE'LL GET TO
ANY OTHER RESOLUTIONS BY THE END
OF TODAY'S AREA.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TO
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE.
IF I CAN JUST I STARTED THE
MEETING WITH THAT BUT I CAN JUST
WANTED TO THANK BEN JOHNSON FOR
YOUR WRITE UP ON THIS ISSUE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US TO
UNDERSTAND. ALL THE FACETS AND
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT WHEN YOU
SPEND THE APPROPRIATE TIME SO
THANK YOU FOR THE.
NOW ONE ISSUE THREE.
YEAH.
NEXT.
ON
I THINK SO YEAH APARTMENT. FOR
THE QUIRK OF.
THAT'S GOOD.
WE NEED.
WILL BEGIN ON ISSUE THREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
FLIPPERS AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO
THE ADVOCATES PROPOSAL.
AUTUMN.
MISTER CHAIR OUT THE ROUTE AND
WENT CCR WAS ORIGINALLY PLANNED
THEY WENT INTO THE INTENT WAS.
I AS YOU KNOW FOSTER PARENT
RETENTION RECRUITMENT WAS
ALREADY PART OF THE CHILD
WELFARE PROGRAMS AND SO WE WOULD
HAVE SAID THAT WAS PART OF THE
PROGRAM WE ALIGN TO TWENTY LEFT.
HOWEVER BOTH WE AND THE COUNTIES
FULLY REALIZE
THAT IN ORDER TO. MAKE THIS WORK
THERE REALLY HAS TO BE A WHOLE
OTHER LEVEL OF. LIFT AND TURNS
OFF ARM PARTICULARLY RETENTION
SUPPORT AND THEN ALSO
RECRUITMENT PUMP TO HAVE THE
HOMES.
BUT WE NEED A CERTAIN AMOUNT THE
LAST ITEM SO THE.
IN THE ORIGINAL CONSTRUCTION
COLUMN THERE WAS
HALF YOUR FUNDING STARTING.
YEAR AND HALF AGO.
OF THIS ENHANCED FUNDING
THE CURRENT YEAR WAS BEING FULLY
FUNDED BY THE STATE.
AND THEN THE.
ORIGINAL PLAN WHICH IS WHAT'S
REFLECTED THE BUDGET IS HALF
YEAR FUNDING IN THE.
BUDGET HERE.
ALL SO THAT IN TOTAL THERE WAS A
SORT OF A TWO YEAR SURGE OF
RESOURCE.
ALL WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE.
CONCERNS ABOUT MAY NEED TO
CONTINUE BUT THAT'S WHAT'S.
THE CURRENT BUDGET.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM MS
HAMRICK.
I'M MAY NAME IS JOYCE AND RIGHT
TIME A FOSTER PARENT AND NOT
COUNTY.
.
ALSO A PRESIDENT THE ROMAN
EMPIRE FUSS MURATSUCHI. WE'VE
HAD A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED
THIRTY KIDS THAT COME THROUGH
OUR HOME IN THAT TIME. AND I'M
NOT A PUBLIC SPEAKER.
BUT I AM ALONG WITH A PASSION
FOR OUR KIDS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT HOW
INSTRUMENTAL IF IT FOR SPENDING
IS TO CONTINUE AND NOT HAVE IT
LASSEN BUT THEY STAY AT THE RATE
THAT IS RIGHT NOW. AND SOME OF
THE ISSUES ASSEMBLY LONG RUBIO
THAT YOU TRASK I THINK AND. I
WAS BIGELOW TO THAT TOO AND.
OUR RECRUITMENT PROBLEMS AND
ISSUES THAT AWAY BEFORE CCR.
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN.
A PROBLEM WITH THAT NOW IN THE
STATE AND THE NATION ALSO.
SO WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
CC ARE WE'VE HAD TO IDENTIFY
RESOURCE FAMILIES AND A
NONTRADITIONAL WAY FIFTH
RESPONDING HAS HELPING USED TO
IN OUR COUNTY FOR NEW AND
TARGETED RECRUITMENT MATERIAL.
WHICH ARE SOME THAT I HAVE HERE
THAT ARE TARGETING AS FAR AS
SPECIFIC GROUPS OF PEOPLE
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS EMPTY
NESTERS.
WE USE.
EVERY KIND OF PERSON GOING INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES SEE IF THEY
CAN HOW.
I DON'T COUNTY STAKEHOLDER INPUT
WAS CRUCIAL IN BUILDING PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT OUR CURRENT COMES
INTO IMPROVE RECRUITMENT.
IDEAS CAME OUT OF Q. P. AYE
MEETINGS I WORK GROUPS MENTORING
WORK GROUPS AND SURVEYS AND OUT
OF THOSE SERVICE MANY THINGS
HAPPEN.
I WON WITH THIS BIT RESPONDING
WE DEVELOPED A CAREGIVER SUPPORT
UNIT AS SOCIAL WORK RETIRED TO
SOME
TO SUPERVISE THE UNIT.
THAT OVERSEAS ARE MENTORING
PROGRAM IN CINEMA COUNTY.
AND THEY ALSO SUPPORT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION EFFORTS
AN EMERGENCY FUND WAS
ESTABLISHED TO BE USED FOR
UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE A
FAMILY. YOU HAVE CHILDREN COMING
YEAR HOME THINGS HAPPEN.
AN EXAMPLE OUT OF THAT GROUP OF
CHILDREN BROUGHT MITES INTO A
HOME THEY HAD TO BE EVACUATED
AND THE WHOLE HOUSE. ERADICATED
THAT'S EXPENSIVE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PERSON'S HOME. ANA SO
THOSE FUNDING THEY USE THAT
THOSE MONIES TO HELP THAT FAMILY
WHERE THEY HAD BLACK STAIN HAVE
THAT HOME. NAM.
CAR SEATS WHEN A NEW RESOURCE
FAMILY CAN'T GET OUT WHEN THEY
HAVE AN EMERGENCY PLACEMENT.
WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED A FAMILY
FINING COLLABORATION AND ALL
COUNTY APPROACH TO RECRUITMENT
WHERE WE SHARE TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
AND BRING THE COUNTY TOGETHER AS
FAR AS FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES.
RESEARCH FAMILIES CAN SHIP.
ARE WE ARE WE TRAIN TOGETHER.
FUNDING ALSO HELP SUPPORT SEND.
RESOURCE FAMILIES TO THE KEEP
THE I. CONFERENCE OUT OF STATE
WHICH BRINGS YOU TOGETHER WITH
OTHER CARE GIVERS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT YOU CAN WORK
TOGETHER. AND LEARN THE
DIFFERENCES IN HOW TO WORK
TOGETHER WHICH HELPED SINK IN
RETENTION AND OUR COMMUNITY.
COM.
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES THAT I CAN
JUST GIVE YOU A FEW THAT ARE
MENTORING PROGRAM WHICH IS USED
CPAP FIFTH RESPONDS AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE WE. AVOID
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES BY
AVOIDING LICENSING PROBLEMS WHEN
YOU HAVE A MENTOR ON MENTOR IT
WE HAVE A MENTOR ASSIGNED TO
EVERY HOME AS THEY BECOME
APPROVED FOR A YEAR AND THAT
MENTOR WORKS WITH THE FAMILY.
.
WE'RE ABLE TO.
HOW FAMILIES GO THROUGH THAT
GRIEF AND LOSS WHEN A CHILD'S
MOOD THAT THEY REALLY WANTED TO
KEEP MY CHILD TRANSITION TOM
LATIMES THAT FAMILY WANTS ME
FINISHED THEY WANT TO DO IT
AGAIN IT'S HARD WHEN WE GIVE UP
TILL THE WEE LA?
WE HELP TALK THEM THROUGH NEXT
UNIT JUST HELP SUPPORT THEM
THROUGH THAT TOO.
I'M.
WE'VE HAD CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
HOSPITALIZED THE CON THEIR
MENTORS TO HELP THEM FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO HOW TO HELP THEM CAN
YOU COME AND WATCH MY KIDS I CAN
TAKE A SHOWER.
ANYTHING LIKE THAT SO. I'M WE
ARE REALLY EXTREMELY PLEASED
WITH OUR MENTORING PROGRAM AND
CINNAMON COUNTY ALSO TO BRIDGE
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BIRTH
FAMILY.
WERE ASKED TO WE ARE ALWAYS ON
REUNIFICATION THAT'S WHAT WE DO
BUT THA'S NOT AS EASY AS IT
SOUNDS.
SO OUR MENTORS HELP BRIDGE THAT
GAP TO WORK TOGETHER WITH BOTH
THAT.
BY A FAMILY AND THE CARE GIVER
ON THEM A ONE OF THE MENTORS
STATED THAT THE DAY TO DAY
AVAILABILITY OF HAVING SOMEONE A
CALLER A TEXT AWAY IS EXTREMELY
VALUABLE. ALSO HAVING SOMEONE
HELP AFTER HOURS AND DURING
EMERGENCIES OFFERS FAMILY
SECURITIES.
I AND THAT SUPERVISOR THAT
SOCIAL WORKER FOR RECRUITMENT
RETENTION SAID ONLY NOT A FOSTER
PARENT CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND AND
SHARE WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE A
CARE GIVER. I HAVE SOCIAL%
WORKERS APPROACH ME ALMOST
WEEKLY IF NOT MORE FREQUENTLY
ASKED BY CONSIGNMENT TOUR.
THROUGH AN AGENCY BUT AT THIS
TIME WE DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING
OR CAPACITY X. TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO ALL CARE GIVERS SO
RIGHT NOW WE JUST YOU COUNTY
APPROVED THOMAS.
I'M BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDING FOR MARK.
OTHER COUNTIES USE THEIR FUNDING
FOR.
ONE COUNTY HAS A ONE STOP
LICENSING MODEL FOR OUR FAA YOU
CAN GO THERE AND GET ALMOST
EVERYTHING DONE IN ONE STOP
INCLUDES DINNER. AND.
.
I YOU KNOW BUT THAT'S IMPORTANT
THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO THEY CAN
GET IT DONE A LOT QUICKER THEN
MARIN AND MARIPOSA COUNTIES HAVE
FOSTER PARENT LIAISON THAT'S
PAID FOR OUT OF THE FIFTH
RESPONDING. TO MAKE THAT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE COUNTY
AND THOSE THAT FOSTER PARENTS
WORK.
.
WE ARE.
WELL THE STATE IS ASKING
RESOURCE FAMILIES TO BE FLEXIBLE
TO BE OPEN TO TAKE CHILDREN THEY
MAY NOT CONSIDER. TAKING INTO
THEIR HOMES BEFORE I CAN AGES.
IF FAMILIES ARE BEING ASKED TO
DO THIS THEY MUST HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO MAKE THE
CHILDREN SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR
HOME. THE PROGRAMSTHAT THE
PAPERS MONEY SUPPORTS ARE
CRUCIAL TO RECRUITING RETAINING
THESE QUALITY CARE GIVERS FAR
DESERVING CHILDREN.
THE BEST THING WOULD BE
RECRUITMENT OF THE RIGHT HOMES
FOR OUR KIDS AND FOR THE CURRENT
FAMILIES TO BE WELL SUPPORTED IN
WHAT THEY DO.
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE PART OF
THE COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
CONTINUED PAPERS FUNDING MANY
CHALLENGES COME ALONG WITH C. C.
AREN'T RFA.
WHICH I FULLY SUPPORT BUT THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE THE FULL FUNDING.
PART OF OUR FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND YOU DID A
GREAT JOB IN PUBLIC SPEAKING.
THANKS CHOICE AND THIS IS CNN IF
AND WITH CHILDREN NOW AND
THERE'S NOT MUCH MORE I CAN SAY
MEAN CHOICES AS PROVEN I THINK
WHY THIS IS SUCH A VALUABLE
PROGRAM. AND SO NEEDED IF WE
TRULY WANT TO STEP KIDS DOWN OUT
OF GROUP HOMES WE NEED
CAREGIVERS WHO ARE COMMITTED AND
DEDICATED IN THAT WERE
SUPPORTING THE WAY THEY NEEDED
TO BE SUPPORTED. I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE HAPPENING AGAIN IS AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS REDUCING RESOURCES
TO A PROGRAM BASED ON TIME LINES
RATHER THAN REALLY STOPPING AND
THINKING ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE
CARE GIVERS AND THE FAMILIES. SO
ASKING AGAIN TO SLOW DOWN TO
RETHINK THIS CUT AND AND TO KEEP
THE MONEY AT THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF FORTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THE FAMILY STILL NEED IT AND
WE'RE NOT AT A PLACE WHERE YOU
HAVE ENOUGH CARE GIVERS TOSTEP
CHILDREN DOWN YET. IT'S NOT THE
TIME FOR A CUT.
AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE A FEW SMALL
TWEAKS WE KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT PEPPERS NOW COUPLE YEARS
AND. WE'D LIKE TO REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO ENSURE
CARE GIVERS IN YOUTH ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE INPUT INTO FAT PURSE
PLANS. ON SO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT THEY NEED AND
WE'RE LISTENING TO THEM ABOUT
THAT. A TO REFINE THE FOCUS OF
THE FUNDING TO SUPPORT BEST
PRACTICES AS WE'VE SEEN THEM
DEVELOP. AND ALSO TO ENHANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH IMPROVED
REPORTING OF HOW THE FUNDS WERE
USED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
THREE.
YES SORRY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IT'S PART OF AND IT'S JUST GREAT
IT'S I'M.
I.
I JUST WENT IN AGAIN REITERATE
THAT.
WOULD BE OPPOSED TO ANY ACTIONS
AGAIN ON A PROPOSAL THAT'S NOT
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE HEARD
THE CONCERNS AND WE'VE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COUNTY AND
SO ON.
TO SEE WHAT WHAT OPTIONS IT
THERE ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE OR
IF SOMETHING MAY NEED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION.
THINKING.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAC
AND FOR THE REASONS STATED
ELOQUENTLY BY THE WITNESSES WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU SIR.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MAR THE CARRERA PRISON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHERRI JUSTICE COOK FROM SOLANO
COUNTY AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M ANGELES BUFFALO BEACH
CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THINKING NOW.
CAROL LAMBERT FROM MARIN COUNTY
AND WE LOVE OUR FAST CURRENTLY
IS ON A WE'D HATE TO LOSE AND
SO.
YOU.
KRISTIN PARA ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
BECAME.
JACQUI RESIZER CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE CHILD FAMILY SERVICES
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHARLIE GOT SPIRIT MARIN FOSTER
CARE ASSOCIATION AND WE'D ALSO
HAD TO LOSE OUR RECRUITER.
RUNNING WATER FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA BONUS SAPPORO.
I THINK.
HI ANDREA ROGERSON TO MARIPOSA
COUNTY AND I AM A FOSTER PARENT
LIAISON SO I I I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
PATRICIA MAGUS AND I'M
CALIFORNIA STATE FOSTER PARENT
ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M HAPPY THAT LIGHTS BROUGHT ME
OUT HERE TO SACRAMENTO THEM BEEN
HERE TO THE CAPITOL.
BUT I'M FROM ROWLAND HEIGHTS
GAMBA FAMILY SHOULD BE FINE IT
AND I SUPPORT THE FULL
ALLOCATION OF THE FULL. FUNDING
FOR THE FAMILIES FOR FOSTER.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND WELCOME TO
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
ANDREA YATES OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOSTER PARENT
SLASH KINSHIP CARE I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT.
THINKING OF.
HE WON'T TAKE FOSTER PARENT
FILMS THAT CALIFORNIAN I SUPPORT
THINKING OF.
PRETTY GOLDBERG LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE
GRANDPARENT AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT BECAME.
CHRISTI CARTER LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA COMES IN A SUPPORT
GROUP. A LEADER AND I AM VERY
SUPPORT. LIKE THE FOR IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
OR BRING IT UP TO THE DIET TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
IF NOT I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION
FOR THE COUNTIES IN THE
ADVOCATES.
CAN YOU PLEASE SPECIFY HOW MUCH
EXACTLY AS SOUGHT FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN. AS
WELL AS TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO IT NOW WE CAN DO THAT
OFFLINE BUT I'D. LIKE TO GET A
MORE ACCURATE REPRESENTATION TO
MAKE SURE WHERE.
ABLE TO DISCUSS IT FULLY SOME.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOR A JUST GOD AGAIN THAT JUST
BASED ON FINANCE. IF ANY OF
THOSE PROPOSAL AMOUNTS ARE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'RE
INCLUDED. IN THE.
AGENDA WHICH ASKED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THOSE BEWARE.
THANK YOU.
THREE.
I THINK THAT MIGHT RIGHTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON PERFECT
TIMING.
THE BILL.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I MALES THAT FRANKIE GUZMANIA
CMOS SHEA HOLLOW MEN COME
FORWARD.
SIR.
THE BILL.
DO YOU NEED.
CIRCLE.
HI HOW ARE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'VE MENTIONED.
QUE HERMOSA ELEMENT POPULATION.
IT WILL.
SHEIK GOT IT.
WHEN YOU'RE READY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GO.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR OF THE STAFF
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ELEMENT OUR SPONSORS FOR
WORKING.
ON THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AUTUMN. OVER THE PAST YEAR.
OUR AND WE.
SEE THAT GROUP HOMES CARING FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFF
TOO OFTEN.
A CALL TO LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
MINOR INCIDENCES OFTEN RESULTS
IN INCARCERATION.
THESE CHILDREN HAVE SUFFERED
TRAUMA AND DESERVE BETTER. ARE
TO BE SENT TO JUVENILE HALL AND
PLACED ON OUT OF TIME A TIMEOUT.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL PROVIDES
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT YOUTH AND
THESE GROUP HOMES
HAVE A GREATER SUPPORT.
AND SO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HAS MORE OPTIONS THAN TAKING
THEM TO JUVENILE HALL.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL CALLED FOR
A SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS.
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WOULD GO TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
TRAIN GROUP HOME.
BOMB SHELTER STAFF AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT UP INSTRUMENT
INFORMED INTERVENTIONS.
THIS MONEY IS.
.
A THIS MONEY UPPER TRAINING ALSO
I'M HAS A ONE POINT FIVE FEDERAL
MATCH.
AND SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
GO TO COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROMOTE HEALTH
AND EDGE AND YOU.
DEVELOPMENT.
THROUGH ARTS THROUGH EXTRA
CURRICULUM IT EL EDUCATION AND
ALSO.
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS THE
MONEY UP WITH THIS PROPOSAL WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED COUNTIES OF BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
THE BIO. IS VITAL TO SUPPORT
FOSTER YOU WHO DESERVE BETTER
THAN TO BE.
SENT TO JUVENILE HALL AS TYPE
OUT.
AND FURTHER TRAUMATIZING THEM
IN THIS PROCESS HERE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING ON TESTIMONY
IS MISTER GOES MON THE DIRECTOR
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH JUSTICE
INITIATIVE. AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR LAW FOR YOUTH LAW AND
ALSO SAY. OF HARLEM AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH
FAMILIES AND WITH STUDENT FATHER
FAMILY FROM SAN JOAQUIN.
I.
M..
GREETINGS SHERMAN TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY YOU SPEAK MY NAME IS
SHERRY HARLEM AND I AM THIRTY
ONE YEARS OLD.
MY INTRODUCTION TO THE POTS
OCCURS AT THE BEGINNING AGE NINE
I COULDN'T TAKE THE ABUSE
ANYMORE SOCK DECIDED TO TO. TELL
A CLOSE FRIEND.
ABOUT THE ABUSE THAT WAS GOING
ON IN MY HOME BEING FACTUALLY
THOUGHTS ABOUT MY BROTHER AND
UNCLE. DUE TO MY MOTHER'S
ABSENCE IN THE HOME.
THE FRIEND THAT I CONFIDED IN
DECIDED TO TELL HER MOTHER WHO
JUST SO HAPPENS TO BE A SOCIAL
WORKER.
THE NEXT DAY THE POLICE SHOWED
UP AT MY SCHOOL TO DOCUMENT ANY
BROUGH THIS.
AFTER SCHOOL. I CAME HOME.
I CAME HOME THAT DAY I WAS
PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE STIFF
THEM.
THE CHILDREN SHELTER WAS NOT AN
ISSUE FOR ME IT WASN'T UNTIL I
WAS PLACE AN ACTUAL FOSTER HOME.
IF THINGS TAKE A WRONG TURN
WHILE AT THE SHELTER AND THE
FOSTER HOME I WAS NOT OFFER
COUNSELING FOR THE TRUMP MY
UNDER.
I SO I STARTED TO LASH OUT AT
EVERYTHING AS A RESULT OF NOT
DEALING WITH ALL MY ISSUE I WAS
REMOVED FROM A DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT TO ANOTHER DANGER TO
FIRE ME. CALL JUVENILE HALL.
NOW AT THESE PLACES MEANT TO
SAVE ME FROM THE DANGER I NEVER
RECEIVED THE REAL HELP I NEED
IT.
THE REAL HELP I NEED AT THE NINE
YEAR OLD GIRL BEING SEXUALLY
ABUSED. WHAT'S COUNSELING.
NOT THE FOSTER CARE TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
IT WAS LIKE I WAS BEING USHERED
INTO THE PRISON SYSTEM RATHER
THAN OFFER SERVICES THAT WOULD
HELP ME MENTALLY IDEA WELL ALL
YOU. DO WHEN THEY ARE NOT BEING
ATTENDED TO CORRECTLY NOW AGE
THIRTY ONE I'M A COMMITTEE
ORGANIZER FOR FATHERS AND
FAMILIES.
THE MISSION AT OUR OFFICE IS TO
PROMOTE THE CULTURAL SPIRITUAL
ECONOMICAL IN SOCIAL RENEWAL OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE FAMILIES IN
STOCKTON I AM THAT FAMILY.
UPON RELEASE ON MIDDLEMAN NAME
ANDRE WHO WITH A VOLUNTEER
FATHERS AND FAMILIES.
HE INTRODUCED ME TO FAMILY NEW
YEARS WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
FATHERS AND FAMILIES THE OFFICE
IN IS STAFF WELCOME YOU LET ME
KNOW I WAS HOME.
BEING THAT HAD JUST COME HOME
FROM PRISON I DID KNOW THAT I
HAD A VOICE.
WHEN YOU GET A PARTISAN FAMILIES
THEY LET YOU KNOW YOU DO HAVE A
WAYS AND YOU DO MATTER HALF THE
REASON YOU'RE LISTENING TO ME
TELL MY PART OF THE STORY TODAY.
BECAUSE LET'S JUST BE HONEST
THREE TO FIVE MINUTES IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME TO TALK ABOUT THE
TRAUMA I RECEIVED.
AT THE HEAD OF THE BEING IN
FOSTER CARE.
SO THE TIME I DO HAVE I WOULD
LIKE TO TELL YOU.
WHAT I HAVE GAINED FROM BEING
AND FOUGHT THE IT BOTHER THEM
FAMILIES AND WORKING FOR THEM WE
HAVE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS FOR KIDS?
PROGRAMS THAT I HOLD DEAR TO MY
HEART TODAY BECAUSE IT HAD I
NOT.
BEEN HIRED AT FATHER THEIR
FAMILIES
AND BEING THAT I AM A FILLED IN
FORM INCARCERATED FOR ELEVEN
YEARS I AM. PRETTY SURE THAT I
WOULD END UP BACK IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM.
STOLE THE MAIN REASON WHY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS BECAUSE.
BEING IN AMERICAN HA I FELT LIKE
IF THE STAFF WOULD HAVE BEEN
TRAINED.
I WOULDN'T. HAVE TO GO THE
DIRECT ROUTE THAT I WIN ON HALF
A DOZEN FAMILIES WE OFFER
PROGRAMS LIKE. THE GARDEN
PROJECT WHERE THE KIDS COME OUT
THERE AND THEY LEARN HOW TO
CULTIVATE AND THEY ARE GREETED
WITH NOTHING
HAVE THE TRUMPCARE UNIT WHERE
THE KIDS CAN COME BACK AND TALK
ABOUT THEIR PROBLEMS TALK ABOUT
THEIR ISSUES. TALK ABOUT
WHATEVER IT IS THAT'S GOING ON
WITH THEM AND I ACTUALLY
HONESTLY FEEL A STUDY ONE THE
OTHER PROGRAMS I USE TODAY. HAD
THESE KIDS HAVE THOSE PROGRAMS
RIGHT NOW THEY WOULDN'T BE GOING
TO JUVENILE HALL FOR THE LITTLE
THINGS THAT THEY'RE DOING I
WOULD TO JUVENILE HALL FOR
DISTURBING THE PEACE.
YOU HAVE A KID THAT NGUYEN INTO
AMERICAN HALL A VERY QUIET
INTIMATE WITH ESPECIALLY
THOUGHTS ABOUT HER BROTHER AND
ALL THE THINGS GOING ON IN THE
HOUSEHOLD. AND YOU CHOOSE
TO.
DEAL WITH THAT CHILD ISSUED BY
CINNABON TO JUVENILE HALL.
INSTEAD OF SITTING HER DOWN YOU
KNOW THAT I'M A QUIET PERSON A
YOU KNOW WHATEVER HAVE GOING ON.
AND YOU TO. TO SHOW ME HOW MUCH
YOU CARE BY SENDING ME TO
JUVENILE HALL INSTEAD OF TALKING
TO ME.
THEY YOU KNOW THAT I'M NOT A
TROUBLED KID OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE BUT YOU HAVE THESE
KIDS GOING TO AMERICA HALL OR
DEALING WITH CERTAIN ISSUES. AND
THIS IS THE WAY THAT THE ISSUES
ARE BEING HANDLED FACTUALLY
PHIL.
THAT THIS IS THE BILL THAT I
HOLD DEAR TO MY HEART FOR THOSE
REASONS.
BECAUSE I'M HERE SPEAKING OUT
FOR THE KIDS WHO WERE THERE NOW
WHO CAN'T SPEAK I AM THEIR VOICE
SO I WILL LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO FEED HIS BILL BEING PASSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU MISS
HOLMAN NEXT WHERE FRANKIE GOES
MARK.
THANK YOU CHAIR HIGH MEMBERS OF
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE MANY FRANK IT WAS MINE
I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW. AND I'M
HERE SUPPORTIVE DID BUDGET ASK
FOR ABOUT SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT.
PER YEAR FOR THREE YEARS TO
CREATE A COMMUNITY BASED.
FOSTER YOU DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM
TO TREAT ALL CHILDREN THAT ARE
ACCUSED OF LOW LEVEL OFFENSES
FOSTER YOUTH LIKE SHEA
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR AGE AND
COMMUNITY SETTINGS. WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON HEALTH AND WELL
BEING.
YOU KNOW SOME CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES HAVE BEGUN TO CREATE
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
FROM AND FORMER SERVICES TO
VULNERABLE YOUTH POPULATIONS.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE IMPACT
THE COMMUNITY BOOK BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT BOTHERED HIM
FAMILIES HAS ON THE LIVES OF
FOSTER YOUTH AND OTHER
VULNERABLE YOUTH.
THIS REQUEST THIS REQUEST A.
TODAY WILL ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES WERE TOO MANY FOSTER
YOUTH ARE CROSSING OVER INTO THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. A
OPERATING COMMUNITIES ARE ARMED
WHAT.
BY FAR THIS REQUEST WILL ENSURE
THAT. COMMUNITIES WERE FOUGHT
MANY FOUGHT FOR YOU THE CROSSING
OVER INTO THE JUVENILE SYSTEM
AND WE'RE GROUP PALMS IN
SHELTERS THAT OVER ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DEAL WITH YOU
BEHAVIOR. WILL INSTEAD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A ROBUST NETWORK OF
TROM INFORMED. CULTURALLY
RELEVANT HEALTH BASED APPROACHES
TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE OF
THE VULNERABLE YOU'VE.
UNDER THIS PLAN THE DEPARTMENT
OF.
SOCIAL SERVICES IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
BOARD OF TO INCOMMUNICADO
ACTIONS ONE MINISTER A U.
DIVERSION. AND DEVELOPMENT FUND
TO PROVIDE TRAINING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FOSTER CARE
STAFF.
AND PROVIDE COMMUNITY BASED
TRAUMA FORM SERVICES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PLACE TO CONGREGATE CARE.
IN FACILITY THAT OVER RELY ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEAL WITH
THESE YOUTH.
FIRST.
THOUGHT FOR EACH OF THESE THAT
THREE YEARS SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OR SEVEN HAVE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL FUND YOU DIVERSION
DEVELOPMENT.
AND WILL BE ALLOCATED COUNTIES
WITH HIGH RATES OF CROSSOVER
YOUTH USING A FORMULA.
UNDER THIS PLAN COUNTIES MUST
SUBMIT A YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
DIVERSION PLAN. IDENTIFIER LEAD
PUBLIC AGENCY.
WHO LOCATIONS WITH THE GREATEST
NEED?
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND SERVICES TO BROUGH BE
PROVIDED. AND YOU THINK WELL
BEING OUTCOMES TO BE MEASURED.
ADDITIONALLY PLANS MUST IDENTIFY
BRAIDED OR MATCHING LOCAL COUNTY
FUND SUCH AS AVAILABLE FUNDS
PROPOSED FOR A PURPOSE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND YOU DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
UP TO FIFTY PERCENT OF THE FUNDS
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO THE LEAD
AGENCY FOR COORDINATION AND
TRAINING.
AND ADMINISTRATION OF THE YOUTH
THAT VERSION AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
THE LEAD AGENCY MUST PASS
THROUGH NO LEFT OF SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE FUNDS TO ONE OR
MORE COMMUNITY BASED.
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
DIRECT SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH
AT RISK. OF ARREST AND
INCARCERATION.
COMMUNITY BASED DIVERSIONARY
SERVICES FUND IS PROGRAM INCLUDE
MENTORING. EDUCATIONAL IN
RICHMOND COLLEGE AND CAREER
PREP.
ARTS RECREATION CULTURAL AND
ETHNIC STUDIES AS WELL AS
CULTURALLY RELEVANT HEALING
PRACTICES FELT AWARENESS AND
HEALTH PROGRAMMING.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE A PROVEN
EVIDENCE BASE
AND OUR MORE COST EFFECTIVE FOR
DEALING WITH LOW LEVEL OFFENSIVE
THEN IF THE PRACTICE OF ARREST
AND INCARCERATION.
OF THE CHILDREN INTERESTED IN
OUR STATE CARE.
SECOND THIS PLAN HOW THE
TRAINING COMPONENT FOR FOSTER
CARE STAFF AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ON ADOLESCENT
DEVELOPMENT. TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. AND DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
EMPLOY EFFECTIVE AND APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTIONS
FOR VULNERABLE YOUTH IN LIEU OF
ARREST INCARCERATIONS.
FURTHER STAFF AND OFFICERS WILL
BE BECOME FAMILIAR WITH
AVAILABLE COMMUNITY BASED
DIVERSIONARY SERVICES AND CAN
MAKE REFERRALS WHEN THEY
ENCOUNTER FOSTER YOUTH IN NEED
OF SUPPORT.
THIS PLAN ALSO MAKES FUN OF
MAKES USE OF TITLE FOR E.
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS.
I WHICH CAN COVER SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE TOTAL COSTS OF
TRAINING FOSTER CARE STAFF AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
IN THIS EXAMPLE.
THE ESTIMATED COST OF TRAINING.
.
THE NEED FOR FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
A FOSTER CARE STAFF IF IF YOU
FEEL AT EASE THAT WE ARE MAKING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED CALLS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT PER YEARS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND UNDER THIS PLAN WITH
INVESTMENT OF HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS.
IF THEY CAN RECEIVE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION AND FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS FOR THIS
TRAINING.
THIRD. THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WILL CONTRACT WITH THE
RESEARCH FIRM TO STUDY THE
PROGRAM OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD AND MEASURE REDUCTIONS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSES. CORE
CASELOADS AND PROCESSING DAYS
THAT YOU SPEND A DETENTION AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY. IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE DIVERT FOSTER YOUTH
HEALTH AND WELL BEING INCLUDING
COMMUNITY STABILITY EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
REDUCING LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIVE TO YOU FOR LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE STATE
AND PARTICIPATING LOCALITIES.
FURTHERMORE IMPROVEMENT AND
FOSTER YOUTH HEALTH AND WELL
BEING ARE FAR MORE COST
EFFECTIVE.
THEN LIFELONG INVOLVEMENT IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AS SUCH THIS PLANET BOTH
SOCIALLY AND FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE.
BY REDUCING OUR OVER RELIANCE ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND POWER TIED IN COMMUNITY
BASED TROMBONE FORM CARE FOR
MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH CALIFORNIA
CAN IMPROVE LIFE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH BETTER UTILIZE
SCARCE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES.
AND IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY I URGE YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER HIS NON NEXT WE
HAVE DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN.
YOU'RE ON OUR AGENDA IF YOU'D
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS.
ALL.
THERE ARE PROBLEMS.
BY.
WHO WE HAVE PROVIDED TO?
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
SPONSORING AUTHORS.
ARM AND OF THEIR.
CLEARLY YOU ARE ISSUES ON WITH
GROUP CARE RELIANCE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ON.
AND SO AGAIN IT'S A MATTER OF
THIS SORT OF THING PRIORITIES OF
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LEN
INCUMBENTS ON ISSUE FOR.
JUST INVESTMENT FINANCED THROUGH
HOW WE JUST WOULD I REITERATE
THE CONCERNS AND THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT FORMER SOCIAL SERVICES AND.
AGAIN AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THIS IS PRIORITY. LEGISLATURE
WERE WILLING TO PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THIS BUT
AT THIS TIME WE BE OPPOSED TO.
THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU SURF WILL
NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FOR.
REALLY COOL BEING FROM
CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
IN HUMAN.
ISRAELI VIA.
WHAT COULD THE CALIFORNIA LIES
FOR YOU THINK COMMUNITY JUSTICE
AS WITH STRONG SUPPORT? THANK
YOU SIR.
TIGHTER SHAKUR YOU PHYSICALISM
IS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
MA'AM.
CHRISTIAN FRANCO MOTIVATED
INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP FOR PUBLIC
ADVANCEMENT.
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
WALKING GRANGER YOU JUST
COALITION IN BSS A STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR AND NICE NAME.
LARA DOLPHY WITH THE W. HAYWOOD
BURNS INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M DOUG SHOTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LANCEOLATA SERVICES
OF OUR MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES OF
MANY A GROUP PALMS.
EVERY GIRL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL BOTH FOR THE
TRAINING IS ALSO FOR THE
DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT
SIR.
MICHAEL HARRIS NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR.
FRANK BACK WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS AND ALSO ON
THIS ITEM ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
I WILL BRING IT BACK UP TO THE
DYESS FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE
MAY HAVE.
SEEING THE HOUR OF THE DAY ENDS
IN LIGHT OF ASSEMBLY RUBIO
RECOMMENDING FULL DAY MEETINGS.
WHO GOING TO KEEP WORKING
COMMENTS SHORT BUT WANTED TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD HERE
TODAY?
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK.
I MAY TAKE A MINUTE IF WE CAN TO
EXCHANGE SOME OF THE.
REPRESENTATIVES WILL BE IF YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO BEFORE WE START
ISSUE FIVE.
TO GET WORK.
YOU'VE ALREADY
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO LOOK
ONCE AGAIN THANK THE CHAIR OF
THE STAFF AND DEPARTMENT OF.
SOCIAL SERVICES AN APARTMENT OF.
FINANCE THE LA OH.
AND THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
EXTENDED OF FOSTER CARE
BENEFITS ARE CRITICAL AS YOU
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD. THESE
YOUTH FACE GREATER.
CHALLENGES AND COMPLETING THEIR
EDUCATION AND FINDING STABLE
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL ASK FOR ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
ENSURE THAT A NUMBER. OF OF THE
YOUTH WHO CURRENTLY CANNOT
ACCESS EXTENDED A FOSTER CARE
WILL NOT BE LEFT OUT.
I'M HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS SERVE A
SUBPOENA.
REPRESENTING THE A YOUTH
JUSTICE OF FELLOW OF SOUTH BAY
AREA LEGAL AIDS.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE ANOTHER
YOUNG LADY WHO ALSO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY THEY WILL
BOTH SELF INTRODUCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SABRINA FORTE I AM A
STAFF ATTORNEY AT BAY AREA LEGAL
AID AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON BUDGET REQUEST ON
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. THIS IS A
VERY NARROW TECHNICAL FIX OF
THEM ENORMOUS IMPORTANCE TO
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE BARRED FROM
ACCESSING EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SERVICES DUE TO ADMINISTRATIVE
HURDLES BEYOND THEIR CONTROL.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND BE LEGAL IS
THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF STE FREE
CIVIL LEGAL SERVICES IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA TO RESIDENTS
LIVING IN POVERTY. OUR YOUTH
JUSTICE PROJECT SPECIALIZES IN
DIRECT CIVIL REPRESENTATION OF
YOUNG PEOPLE INCLUDING FOSTER
YOUTH SURVIVORS A TRAFFIC IN AND
DO YOU EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
MANY OF THE YOUTH JUSTICE
PROJECTS CLIENTS ARE NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE ALREADY RECEIVING
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SERVICES.
THANKS TO THE PASSAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOSTERING CONNECTIONS
TO SUCCESS ACT YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
TURN EIGHTEEN AND FOSTER CARE
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE ONGOING
SUPPORT UP TO AGE TWENTY ONE TO
BETTER PREPARE THEM FOR
ADULTHOOD.
THESE SUPPORTS INCLUDE.
TRANSITIONAL INDEPENDENT LIVING
CASE PLANS THAT ARE MODIFIED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE YOUTH AT
SIX MONTH INTERVALS. MONTHLY
MEETINGS WITH A CHILD WELFARE
WORKER. FULL SCHEMATIC CAL UP TO
AGE TWENTY SIX.
LEGALLY MANDATED SCREENINGS AND
ASSISTANCE WITH SSI FOR FOSTER
YOUTH WITH DISABILITIES.
PORT IN RESOLVING CONSUMER
CREDIT ISSUES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
THEFT A COMMON PROBLEM.
A CONTINUUM AND FINALLY A
CONTINUUM OF PLACEMENT OPTIONS
INCLUDING FOSTER FAMILY HOME
SUPERVISED INDEPENDENT LIVING
PLACEMENTS TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
AND DISABILITY BATES CARE
FACILITIES AS WELL AS
ELIGIBILITY FOR. ELIGIBILITY FOR
ONGOING TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
AFTER EXITING CARE.
THE SUPPORTS REPRESENT A
CRITICAL SAFETY NET TO HELP.
TRANSITION AGED YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED ABUSE ABANDONMENT
AND NEGLECT AVOID THE POOR LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED
WITH CHILDHOOD ADVERSITY.
HOWEVER OUR DEPENDENCY COURTS
AND COURTS OF APPEAL HAVE
IDENTIFIED A FEW SMALL AND
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO REMAIN AN ELIGIBLE
FOR THESE CRITICAL SUPPORTS.
THE LA OWN ANALYSIS AND
IDENTIFIES FOR SUBPOPULATIONS OF
YOUTH WHO HAVE FACED TECHNICAL
BARRIERS TO ANSWERING AND RE
ENTERING FOSTER CARE. FOR
EXAMPLE TIME SIMPLY RUNS OUT
BEFORE THE JUVENILE COURT CAN
MAKE DISPOSITIONAL FINDINGS OR
THE TIMING OF CERTAIN BENEFITS
PAYMENTS IS OUT OF SYNC WITH THE
UTES PETITION TO REENTER FOSTER
CARE EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE ON.
THESE BARRIERS ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE CONTROL OF THE YOUNG PERSON
SEEKING TO ENTER OR REENTER
FOSTER CARE AND WERE NEVER
INTENDED TO BAR ELIGIBILITY TO
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
WE THINK THESE UNINTENDED
TECHNICAL BARRIERS AFFECT JUST A
SMALL NUMBER OF UNITS SMALLER
EVEN THAN THE ALEJO ESTIMATE.
BEFORE THESE YOUTH FAILURE TO
REMOVE THESE BARRIERS HAS LED TO
TRAGIC AND UNAVOIDABLE RESULTS
INCLUDING AND ESPECIALLY
HOMELESSNESS BUT ALSO
HOSPITALIZATION AND
INCARCERATION.
ELIMINATING BARRIERS IDENTIFIED
IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL
ENSURE THAT YOU THEY'RE ABLE TO
ANSWER OR RE ENTER FOSTER CARE
AND ENSURE THEIR SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD EVEN IN
THE FACE OF TECHNICAL. OR
BUREAUCRATIC DELAYS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE THE THEME OF
THE DAY.
AHMADI AT THE YOUNG WOMAN
SITTING ALONGSIDE ME WILL SHARE
HER OWN STORY TO ILLUSTRATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE IN A YOUNG PERSON'S LIFE.
AND ALSO THE CHALLENGES THAT
THREATEN TO BAR ACCESS TO SOME.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
REQUEST
HE CAME HOME GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AHMADI
OF FULLER I'M EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD.
AND I'M AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
I'M SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW TO BE ON
UNPREDICTABLE THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM CAN BE.
AND BECAUSE I WAS FORTUNATE TO
ENTERPRISE THE CARE SHIRLEY
BEFORE MY EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY SO
THAT I COULD. GET EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE SERVICES NOW OFFERS
ENTERPRISE THE CARE WHEN I WAS
SIX YEARS OLD I DIDN'T STAY IN
FOSTER CARE FOR VERY LONG.
AND I WAS SENT TO LIVE WITH MY
DAD AND GRANDMA THEY'RE THEY
WERE ALWAYS FIGHTING IT DENIED
SHE KNEW OF.
WE WERE HOMELESS ALLY AND I WAS
NOT ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL FOR
MANY MONTHS AT A TIME.
AT SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD ARE ONLY
HAD FIFTEEN CREDITS.
OF HIGH SCHOOL COMPLETED ALMOST
KIT OTHER KIDS HAVE TWO HUNDRED
ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
THE HOUSE WE WERE LIVING IN
BRING DOWN MY GRANDMOTHER WANTED
TO GO BACK TO THE CHECK POST.
THAT WE USED TO LIVE AT HIGH
DENOMINA GO BACK THERE BECAUSE
IT WAS DANGEROUS.
PEOPLE MOVES DRUGS IN AND OUT OF
THE CHIAPAS.
THERE ARE ALWAYS A LOT OF FIGHTS
AND THERE WERE ROACHES AND RATS
EVERYWHERE.
I WAS NOT SAFE THERE.
BY THE.
THIS TIME I WAS SEVENTEEN YEARS
AGO I TELL MY SCHOOL COUNSELOR
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND SHE TOLD
ME ABOUT YOU SHOWED THEM SAN
FRANCISCO.
THIS SET ME ON A PATH DEFINING
SAFETY AND THEY'LL STABILITY.
THE STAFF AT THE SHOW THEY GAVE
ME FOOD CLOTHES AND A SAFE
PLACE.
ASLEEP THEY HELPED ME FIGURE OUT
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL AND
HELPED ME FIND A SUMMER JOB THE
SHELTER. OFFICER INTRODUCED ME
TO.
A LAWYER AND A SOCIAL WORKER WHO
TALK TO TALK TO ME ABOUT. MY
FAMILY AND ABOUT FOSTER CARE
THEY HAVE MIXED.
HELPED ME EXPLAIN MY SITUATION
TO CHECK OUT WELFARE AND TO
EXPRESS HOPE THEY WERE WITH ME
EVERY STEP. TO TELL ME WHAT TO
EXPECT AND HOW TO ME IN MY
FAMILY WOULD BE AFFECTED.
ENTERING FOSTER CARE WAS NOT AN
EASY DECISION BECAUSE I DO NOT
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
TO MY MOM ABOUT SYSTEM BY THESE.
DESPITE THE FEAR GOING INTO
FOSTER CARE WAS THE RIGHT STEP
FOR ME TO TAKE GIVEN TO FOSTER
CARE MEANT THAT I DO NOT HAVE TO
BE HOMELESS ANYMORE. SINCE I
ENTERED FOSTER CARE.
I HAVE HAD IS A PLACE TO LIVE.
AND I COULD GET MY EDUCATION
BACK ON TRACK I'M SET TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL IN ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES STINT ENTERING
FOSTER CARE.
I HAVE BECOME MORE INDEPENDENT
AND I HAVE MET PEOPLE WHO ARE
POSITIVE INFLUENCE ON MY LIFE
IDENTIFIES THE CARE SHORTLY
BEFORE MY EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY
MEANT THAT I COULD HAVE.
TWO YEARS OF.
THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT I NEVER
RECEIVED BEFORE FROM ANYONE. AND
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A BETTER
LIFE
THE PROCESS OF BECOMING A FOSTER
YOUTH WAS VERY CONFUSING EFFORTS
CBS DID NOT OPEN. A CASE AT ALL.
WHEN THEY FINALLY LEARN ABOUT
MUCH SITUATION INDEED OPEN THE
CASE MY HEARINGS GODLY FOR
REASONS THAT AND UNDERSTAND.
AFTER MY SIBLINGS AND I WERE
DETECTED TAINTED TOOK THREE
MONTHS FOR THE COURT TO TAKE
JURISDICTION AND MAKE. YOU
DEPEND LOCALLY IT QUICKLY I HAVE
HAD IT TURN EIGHTEEN BY THEN IF
I HAD TURNED.
OF I HAD TOLD FOSTER CARE ABOUT
MY SITUATION JUST A FEW MONTHS
LATER I WOULD HAVE RAN OUT OF
TIME THIS BUDGET REQUEST TO
ALLOW YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME TO
MOVE QUICKLY THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF BECOMING A FUSSY YOU.
IT'S A GANG. ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES SUPPORT A HOUSING THAT
WE NEED TO SUCCEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FULLER.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DIRECTOR
LIKE BORN PREVENTING.
I THINK YOU ARE MISTER AREN'T WE
YES WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS ON.
THE THE BOTH THEIR THE ESTIMATE
AS WELL AS I THINK AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SEVEN WITCHES.
COMPANION LEGISLATION TO OFFICE.
ARM AGAIN SUPPLY.
MATTER FOR FURTHER LEGISLATIVE
ACTION.
THINK.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA NO I'M
WE DID PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PROVIDING A COST
ESTIMATE.
FOR.
AS THE PROPOSAL BEFORE I THINK
THE LEGISLATION HAD BEEN WRITTEN
BUTTOCK CERTAINLY WITH THAT WITH
THAT BUT THE INTENT OF A OF THAT
LEGISLATION WAS JUST MENTION.
AND WE WERE JUST NOTE THAT.
GIVEN THAT THESE ARE YOUTH THAT
AREN'T ACTUALLY INVOLVED IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM CURRENTLY
WE DON'T HAVE ADMINISTRATIVE
DATA AND SO THEY'RE JUST AS A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHAT
THE CASELOADS. WOULD ULTIMATELY
BE.
AND THEREFORE WHAT THE CON
COMMITMENT COSTS WOULD BE WOULD
NOTE THOUGH THAT THE BUDGET ASK
IS AT THE HIGHER RANGE OF THE
ESTIMATE GIVEN FOR.
FOR CASELOAD.
THAT WE DID PROVIDE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU SIR. AT THIS.
THE PART OF FINANCE I JUST AND
REYES FROM FINANCE AND I JUST.
THAT NOT WITHIN THE MERITS THE
BILL.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
AS MY ONLY.
COUNTERPART AND AND THAT'S WHAT
GIVE.
DESCRIBED THE CHALLENGES WITH
IDENTIFYING THE POPULATION ON
THAT SAME I'M WE'VE WORKED WITH
THE SPONSORS THEM AND WE'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE WORK WITHIN
THE. AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ON A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON IT AND
I'M IS RELUCTANT THIS.
POSITION IS A PROPOSITION THIRTY
IMPACTS OF WE DON'T IDENTIFY.
THE INTENSIVE WITH AUTHORS
CHINA.
TO ASSIST AND HELP ON WITH THIS
LATE WITH THE LEGISLATION IN
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL THERE COULD
BE A SIGNIFICANT UNKNOWN IMPACTS
SO.
AGAIN WHICH TO WHEN ARENA
WILLING TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
YOU TO FINE TUNE TO LOOK
TOWARDS.
THAT THE INTENDED GOAL OF WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR FOR THIS
POPULATION.
WHAT UP IF YOU YOU CAN SEND THE
TO ME BUT WHAT IMPACT WOULD IT
HAVE ON PROP THIRTY?
SO WITH ANY SORT OF FOSTER CARE
RELATED AND EXTENSION ON X.
ABOUT HER IF IF THE THE THE
POPULATION TO BE A LARGER. ON
THEM WHAT WE'RE INTENDING OR
WHAT THE AUTHORS IN TUNING HERE
SO AND THIS PROPOSAL COULD
POTENTIAL NOT BE ENOUGH IS WHAT
WE'RE GETTING AT. UMPS RIGHT.
CATHOLIC.
WITH THAT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE EITHER
YET ANOTHER TEAM MEMBER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE.
THANK YOU.
FRANK BACK WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS IN THE
ABSOLUTELY SEE THE MERITS IN THE
PROPOSAL WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE LA ON THE
COMMITTEE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT NOT JUST THE
PLACEMENT COST BUT THE SOCIAL
WORK COST ASSOCIATED WITH. THE
EXPANSION POPULATION ARE
INCLUDED IN THE FISCAL ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU SIR.
CAN THOSE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
POINT A CO SPONSORS ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND APPRECIATE ALL
COMMENTS AND I'M IDEA GIVING HER
STORY HERE TODAY. AYE MEN THANK
YOU FOR HEARING THIS PROPOSAL WE
THINK IT.
WARRANTS I'M A CONVERSATION
ENSURING THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING
BARRIERS THAT ARE OUTSIDE THESE
CONTROL OF THESE YOU TO PUNISH
THEM FOR THINGS THAT THEY CAN'T
HAVE. ANYTHING AROUND AND SO
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON SOLVING THE ISSUES AROUND
PROP THIRTY AND HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
CHRIS EMPOWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ALSO A PROUD
CO SPONSOR WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THE LA DOES OFFICE HAS
DONE WORK CONTINUE WORK. WITH
YOU TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
REGARDING FISCAL ISSUES
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS TODAY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
JOHN MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
LASSITER CALIFORNIA ANOTHER
PROUD CO SPONSOR.
.
STATEMENTS REALLY THE NEED AND
THE SERVICES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THESE YOUTH AND
FOR THEM TO BE DENIED THOSE
SERVICES BY A FEW DAYS OR JUST
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T COME INTO
THE SYSTEM RIGHT WHEN THEY
SHOULD HAVE. AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE TRAGIC LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING. WITH EVERYBODY
THAT'S MAKE COMMENTS TODAY
THINKING. WE CAN MOUNT.
SINGLE FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
BRING IT UP TO THE DIES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE MAY
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
MR GIVE SENATE'S THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT'S VITAL
THAT WE ENSURE OUR FOSTER YOUTH
ARE FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMMENTS I ALSO WANTED TO
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON AND.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
FIVE OPEN FOR NOW AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SIX THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
WE'RE GONNA START WITH MICHELLE
EVANS IF THAT'S OKAY AND THEN GO
ON TO CARRY FOR.
AT GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MICHELLE EVANS AND I
AM A LAW STUDENT AT THE MCGEORGE
SCHOOL OF LAW PARTICIPATING IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PUBLIC POLICY
CLINIC.
I AM AT THE SCHOOL I AM ALSO A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I'VE BEEN A SOCIAL WORKER
ACTUALLY FOR CLOSE TO TWENTY
YEARS AND HAVE ACTUALLY WORKED
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND
WORKED WITH YOUTH AND FOSTER
CARE AND A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SETTINGS.
AT THIS PROPOSAL CAME ABOUT
BECAUSE OF OUR CONCERN THAT A
LOT OF US TO TALK ABOUT TODAY
THE TRAUMA THAT CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY ARE REMOVED
FROM THEIR HOMES.
AND THEN I'M GOING TRAUMA THEY
EXPERIENCED WHEN THEY DON'T
EXPERIENCE.
STABILITY WITHIN THE SYSTEM WHEN
THEY'RE MOVE FROM THAT INITIAL
HOME THEIR PLACED INTO A GROUP
HOME TO RESIDENTIAL. TO ANOTHER
POLICEMAN AND WE THIS LACK OF
STABILITY Y. LANCAIR COMPLICATES
THE DIFFICULTIES OF THE CHILD
CAME INTO CARE WAITED MAKING IT
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
CHILD TO EVER FIND PERMANENCY.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT A
CHILD IS IN CRISIS THAT DAY BUT
THEY'RE PLACED IN A FOSTER HOME.
WE NEED TO NOT WAIT FOR A CRISIS
TO MANIFEST ITSELF IN THEIR NEW
HOME BEFORE OF WE MOBILIZE
SUFFICIENT TRAINING AND SUPPORT
FOR THE FAMILY. WHO HAS NOW
JOINED TO THE CRISIS OF THE
CHILD?
WE NEED TO HELP THE FAMILY AND
CHILD THROUGH THE TRANSITION OF
PLACEMENT TO HELP STABILIZE AND
PRESERVE THE POLICEMAN.
FROM DAY ONE AND HELP THE CHILD
TO HEAL AND NOT CAUSE FURTHER
TRAUMA.
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS BY
PROVIDING TRAUMA INFORMED
COACHING TO RESOURCE FAMILIES AT
THE OUTSET OF PLACEMENT.
WHEN THE CHILD FIRST ENTERS THE
HOME AND CARRY WILL TALK MORE
ABOUT THOSE DETAILS.
WITH A TRAUMA INFORMED PLAN FOR
SUCCESS CREATED WITH FAMILIES
AND COACHES FROM DAY ONE OF THE
PLACEMENT WITH ONGOING SUPPORT
THROUGH OUT THE PLACEMENT WITH
THE COACH AVAILABLE. AND IF A
CRISIS DOES ARRIVE HOPEFULLY
WERE PREVENTING THAT FROM
HAPPENING BUT TO HAVE THEM WHEN
THEY ARE TO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM.
WILL HELP FURTHER THE GOALS OF
THE CCR AND EVERY CHILD TO LIVE
IN A STABLE AND NURTURING HOME.
WITHOUT A PLACEMENT JAMES AND
LESS THE MOVE IS
TO THEIR HOME IS ALSO HELP
IMPROVE RESOURCE FAMILY
SATISFACTION AND RETENTION FOUND
A SATISFYING PROCESS RESOURCE
FAMILIES TO NOT HAVE SUCCESS
WITH A CHILD THAT'S NOT WHEN
THEY FIND OUT TO BE FOSTER CARE.
IN MY OPINION PROVIDING THIS
LEVEL OF TRAUMA AND FORMED
COACHING SUPPORTER.
TO FAMILIES AT THE OUTSET OF
PLACEMENT IS.
ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO THE ONGOING
SUCCESS
FOR THE OUTCOMES OF THE CCR.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU INCLUDE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEAN SHINES
BUDGET REQUEST AND THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET FIGURE BECAME.
MISS FOURTH YES THANK YOU I AM
MY NAME IS CARRIE FOR EARTH AND
ALONG WITH MICHELLE I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF THAT. LEGISLATION
PUBLIC POLICY CLINIC AT MCGEORGE
SCHOOL OF LAW.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THE COMMITTEE INCLUDE FOUR POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A TWO YEAR
RESOURCE FAMILY. COACHING PILOT
PROJECT IN THREE TO FIVE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
COACHING SERVICES PROVIDED TO
RESOURCE FAMILIES AT THE OUTSIDE
OF THE PLACEMENT WILL GIVE MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT TO HELP PREVENT.
CRISES BY DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR
SUCCESS FROM THE BEGINNING
PROVIDE RAPID SUPPORT. WHEN
PROBLEMS DO ARISE AND WILL
PREVENT THE NEED FOR SEVEN DAY
NOTICES AND EMERGENCY REMOVALS.
COACHING FACILITATE THE TRANSFER
OF LEARNING FROM TRAINING
RECEIVED BY RESOURCE FAMILIES
INTO PRACTICE IN THEIR HOMES.
THE PILOT WILL ALLOW TWENTY
QUALIFIED WORKERS TO BE TRAINED
AS COACHES AND PROVIDE.
DESIGNATED SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY
TO RESOURCE FAMILIES.
TO IMPROVE FOSTER PARENT
RETENTION AND SUPPORT. IMPROVE
STABILITY IN PERMANENCY FOR
FOSTER YOU. AND PROVIDE A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE AT THE END OF
THE PILOT TO DETAIL THE OUTCOMES
AT IMPROVING FOSTER PARENT
RETENTION AND PLACEMENT
STABILITY.
WORKERS ASSIGNED AS DESIGNATED
COACHES TO RESOURCE FAMILIES
WILL HAVE THE PRIMARY ROLE TO
COACH AND ASSIST RESOURCE
FAMILIES WITH BONDING AN
ATTACHMENT. BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES. WORKING WITH
BIOLOGICAL FAMILIES AND
EFFECTIVE PARTICIPATION AND
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
INCLUDE THIS REQUEST FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN IN
THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
DOCTOR LIKELY.
THE ONLY QUESTION I THINK IT
HAPPENS TO CHAIR IS THIS MAY BE
A BIT DUPLICATIVE IF THERE IS IN
FACT THE EXTENSION OF FLIPPERS
FUNDING. AUGMENT THIS SORT OF
COVERS THE SAME AREA BUT.
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO.
BUT UNTIL THERE'S A DECISION ON
THE ONE IT'S HARD TO KNOW ABOUT
THE OTHER.
ANDERSON.
BERMAN TO FINANCE A LEO.
JUST BASED FORMING OF FINANCE
AND AND JUST TO REITERATE THE
YEAR.
DIRECTORS AND I'M COMMENTS.
THAT HIS ACTION MAY BE
DUPLICATIVE OUT SOME SERVICES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH OUR
FAA I'M OR EVEN THROUGH THE.
THE FIGURES FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDE ITS AT THIS TIME WOULD
BE OPPOSED.
TO THAT PROPOSAL FROM ACTIONS
TAKEN HOWEVER THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS.
AYE AND SPONSORS TO. PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS MOMENT
FORWARD TO ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIX.
SEEN ON A BRING IT UP THE DYESS
AND I WAS GONNA ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT.
WHAT IS CURRENTLY BEING PROVIDED
AT THE COUNTY AND THAT?
IT SEEMS THAT THAT'S BEEN
ANSWERED.
IN THAT AT SOME POINT THERE MAY
BE DUPLICATIVE SERVICES AND.
WELL I WOULD CLICK TO TO SORT OF
CALM MADNESS HAMMERSMITH WHEN
SHE WAS TESTIFYING ON THE FOR
PRINCE THING WAS SORT OF
DESCRIBING SOME MENTORING AND
COACHING SORT OF ACTIVITIES SO
THAT THEIR OWNERS NELSON.
SUGGEST
I DEPENDING ON WHAT ACTIONS YOU
TAKE LATER IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
THEY MIGHT WERE POINT TO THIS
SORT OF ACTIVITY IS A PARTICULAR
PRIORITY.
ON BUT.
AGAIN I DON'T SAY THAT TO.
RAIN ON THE IDEA OF ITS
IMPORTANCE.
WITH THAT IN THE FOR THE PLANT
BUT.
AS I SAY I AND I KNOW THERE
THERE'S A LOT OF PROGRAM I MEAN.
IT IS TO PLUG HIS SPLIT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IT DOES CUT
SOME OF THE FUNDING SO MR
MAIENSCHEIN PROPOSAL.
YOU SAID FUNDING THEIR
INDENTURES THAT IT DOES GO
THROUGH SAID ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
SOMETHING BETTER TO LOOK AT AS
WE GO INTO MAY REVISE.
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
INDEED THERE.
SO.
WITHOUT I WANTED TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE SIX OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVEN
.
AFTER.
I COULD ASK MR ROSE TO LEAD OFF
AND WE'RE JOINED BY DAVE
MCDOWELL DUE TO THE HOUR OF TIME
IMAGES ASKING YOU BE BRIEF WITH
THE PROPOSAL IN.
GREG ROSE FOR A DEADLY DIRECTOR
FOR CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES OF
THE DEPARTMENT I WILL BE BRIEF
I'LL JUST ASK DAVE TO A STEP
THROUGH THAT THE ACTUAL.
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
I'M DAVE MCDONALD CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS AND EVALUATION AT IN
THE CHILDREN'S SERVICES DIVISION
THAT'S THAT DEPARTMENT.
AT THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
IS FOR ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS HAS SIX HUNDRED NINETY
SIX THOUSAND OF WHICH IT IS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY. FOR
NINE POSITIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING ONE STAFF SERVICES
MANAGER AND EIGHT A ANALYSTS.
FOR HAVE FIVE OF THE POSITIONS
AND THE MANAGER IS THE REQUESTED
IS FOR REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY
SO THAT I COUNTIES WHO HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO COMPLETE THE. CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES CASE REVIEWS
THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED BACK IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. A MAY CONTRACT
BACK WITH THE DEPARTMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS CAN BE COMPLETED.
OTHER KIDS REVIEWS ARE AN
ONGOING FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND
A DELIVERABLE IN OUR FORTHCOMING
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT PLAN SO THE
REVIEWS ARE NOT AN OPTIONAL
ACTIVITY.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE THREE
ANALYST POSITIONS IN THIS
PROPOSAL IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES
TO. OUR IN DEVELOPING IMPROVE
COORDINATION FOR MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE NEED FOR THIS WAS HAD
DETERMINED THROUGH OUR RECENT
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES REVIEW
THAT WAS COMPLETED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. WHICH FOUND THAT THE
SERVICES AND OUTCOMES FOR AT
THESE YOUNGER CHILDREN WERE
LACKING COMPARED TO THOSE.
OVER THE AGE OF FIVE.
YOU SEE OF MISS ROGERS HERE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS YOU'D
LIKE THAT SORRY IF YOU ON OUR
PANEL.
MR CROSSED.
ACTUALLY I'M FOR THE NEXT BCP ON
POUND ACROSS FROM COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING.
FAIR ENOUGH.
THE LONG RUN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO ANY
COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE SET UP WE
HAVE REVIEWED THE BCP AND TAKE
NO ISSUE WITH THE OTHER BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
JUSTIN GREATEST PROPONENTS
BELIEVE SUPPORT OF THEIR THAT
DEPARTMENT PROPOSAL.
HIM WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON
THE SECOND PROPOSAL SIR.
THIS PROPOSAL WE'RE ASKING FOR
SEVEN HERE IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
CONTINUES SIX POSITIONS TO DO
INSPECTIONS ON THAT GROUP COMES
PART THAT HAVE HIGH USAGE OF
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS.
OF THESE ARE LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS WAKE UP TO YOUR
FINDINGS OR ASKING TO EXTEND IT
FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS.
THE PERMANENT FINANCE HELLO ANY
COMMENTS ON.
LA OPEN JOHNSON OUT NO ISSUES
WITH THIS PEACEKEEPING.
JUST PRAISE FROM FINANCE AGAIN
JUSTIN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVEN AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
A
.
HOW ARE YOU?
IF YOU'RE STARTING THINK THERE'S
A FAIR AMOUNT OF INFORMATION AND
ON THE AGENDA IF I CAN HAVE YOU
FOCUS ON THE QUESTIONS ON PAGE
FIFTY ONE.
I WOULD BE APPRECIATED SIR THANK
YOU.
SO THE FIRST QUESTION HAS A
DEPARTMENTS IN IMPACT ON THE
COMPLAIN BACKLOG FROM THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND RESOURCES.
YES WE HAVE.
THE COMPLAINTS WE'VE COMPLETED
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
FIRST WE RECEIVED THIRTEEN
POSITIONS AND FISCAL YEAR.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO AND
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG.
SO SINCE THAT TIME OUR
COMPLAINTS OF INCREASED
INCREMENTALLY COULDN'T YOU'VE
GOTTA OF.
LIST OF OUR.
A SUMMARY OF OUR WORK FLOW THAT
WE PASSED OUT THAT DOESN'T HAVE
OUR COMPLAINT WORKLOAD BUT IT IS
IN THE AGENDA. BUT OUR
COMPLAINTS BEEN INCREASING EACH
YEAR SO WITH THOSE POSITIONS WE
RECEIVE WEAPON ABLE TO COMPLETE
KEEP OUR COMPLAINTS.
COMPLETE IN AS MANY AS WE BEEN
RECEIVING SO OUR BACKLOG HAS
BEEN.
THOSE COMPLAINTS OPEN OVER
NINETY DAYS HAVE BEEN TRENDING
DOWNWARD BUT WE HAVEN'T YOU KNOW
AYE THREAT WE HAVEN'T COMPLETED
THE THE ENTIRE BACKLOG BUT THEY
HAVE WE HAVE BEEN. REDUCING THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE OVER NINETY
DAYS.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE JUST
BRIEF SUMMARY OF OUR VISITS
WE'VE DONE OVER EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND VISITS OF COMPLAINTS
CASE MANAGEMENT INSPECTIONS AND
FACILITY INSPECTIONS AND I'M
LICENSE SO. WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SOME LICENSE
PROGRAM ALISON DO THE
INSPECTIONS SO. TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE A WORKLOAD BETWEEN
ANNUAL INSPECTIONS AND THE
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS.
I DO FROM.
ARE WE MEETING THE INSPECTION
FREQUENCY STANDARDS AS OUTLINED
IN STATE LAW AND THAT THAT IS
NUMBER TWO SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MEET OUR STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
SO.
AS OF JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR WE ARE FREQUENCY IS
INCREASED FROM FIVE YEARS TO
THREE YEARS AND WE'VE WE'VE.
MADE APPROXIMATELY NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT OF OUR AND OF OUR THREE
YEAR INSPECTIONS BUT WASN'T FOR
THE FIRES IN THE. THE OROVILLE
DAM WE WOULD'VE MADE A HUNDRED
PERCENT.
WHAT WE CURRENTLY DOING WITH THE
BACKLOG IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE
REACHED THE?
AND I'M APPROPRIATE AMOUNT BUT.
HOW WILL THE TOOL AND
DEVELOPMENT WORK?
WILMINGTON PHONES.
THE TOOL IS THE HASN'T WASN'T
DEVELOPED FOR AND FOR THE
BACKLOG ACTUALLY BUT.
.
DID THE BACKLOG IT'S JUST THE
INCREASED COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE
HAVE BURLY HAMPERED US FROM.
FROM PRODUCING THE BACKLOG TO
WHAT WE EXPECTED WE WOULD HAVE
DONE.
THE COMPLAINTS EACH YEAR WE
DON'T KNOW IF IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE.
.
WITH THE FACILITIES HAVE TO POST
OUR EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER FOR
COMPLAINTS.
WE'VE GOT A ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
HOTLINE.
SO WE'VE GOT A LOT OF ATTENTION
FOR PEOPLE TO CALL.
SO WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S WHAT
SPIKE THEIR COMPLAINTS
WERE WERE HOPING THAT ONCE WE
GET TO ANNUAL INSPECTIONS FOR
ADULT SENIOR CARE THAT OUR
COMPLAINTS WILL COME DOWN.
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WHOSE.
pTHOUGH IN TERMS OF HOW WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE BACKLOG WERE
TRYING.
WE LINE OR
WE'VE GOT.
TASK FORCE WE'VE HIRED RETIRED
ANNUITANTS WE'VE GOT TASK FORCE
TRYING TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO WE
CAN HAVE TEAMS THAT GO OUT WERE
WERE BUNDLING OUR COMPLAINT WITH
OUR ANNUAL INSPECTIONS IF
THEY'VE GOT COMPLAINTS. WILL GO
OUT TO THE COMPLAINTS WE
PRIORITIZE OUR COMPLAINTS SO
BASICALLY THE BACKLOG IS IS
MAINLY LIKE.
PRIORITY THREES AND FOURS
THEY'RE NOT LIKE HIGH RISK.
PRIORITY ONES AND TWOS WE'VE WE
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS THOSE.
.
AS WE RECEIVE THEM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OLEO ANY
COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE EIGHT.
SEEING NON PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE EIGHT.
SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DYESS AND GIVE ME JUST
ONE SECOND
.
MAYBE IT'S A ON A THEME FOR THE
DAY BUT I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
DESCRIBE THE NEW TOOL A LITTLE
BIT. AS WELL THERE TO DESCRIBE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS TO.
SO THE TOLL WHERE DEVELOPED.
FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS WELL
IT'S BEEN SINCE THE RECESSION
THERE THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOP A
TOOL CALLED THE KEY INDICATOR
TOOL WHICH IS AN ABBREVIATED
TOLL.
THERE WAS AS YOU I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE THEY HAD THE
FURLOUGHS IN THE FREEZER SO WAS
AN ABBREVIATED TOOL TO BE ABLE
TO DO AS MANY INSPECTIONS AS THE
DEPARTMENT COULD DO.
ON AS WE'VE BEEN FINDING OVER
TIME.
THE TOOL DIDN'T IDENTIFY SOME
AREAS OF OF NON COMPLIANCE THAT
WE THOUGHT WOULD BE MORE
PRODUCTIVE TOOK TO LET US KNOW
HAD A TIME WHERE WE COULD.
START.
HELPING FACILITIES BEFORE THEY
GOT TO THE POINT OF BEING ABLE
TO HAVE TO SHUT THEM DOWN.
SO THIS NEW TOOL IS DEVELOPED
BY.
ACTUALLY THE ARTICLES IN THE
REGULATIONS SO WOULD BE ON.
OPERATIONS STAFFING MEDICATIONS
PHYSICAL PLANT.
PERSONAL RECORDS SO IT'S IT'S
DEVELOP SO YOU GET A THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY DEGREE LOOK AT
PULSE OF THE FACILITY THE HELP
OF THE FACILITY AND SO. IT'S
DEVELOPED IN A WAY THAT CAN BE
USED AS A SELF ASSESSMENT TOOL
FOR THE PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY
CAN LEARN.
THIS IS WHAT THE REGULATIONS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR.
IT IT'S IT'S PRETTY AND OUT
THAT'S GOT A SPECIALTY TOOL
BEHIND EACH OF THOSE AREAS SO IF
WE FIND AREA AN ISSUE WITH
MEDICATIONS. IT'S GOT A
SPECIALTY TOOL THAT JUST DIVES
DEEP IN THAT AREA SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY FIND WHATSOEVER BECAUSE
OF WHERE THEY'RE HAVING ISSUES.
ON THE TOOLS BEFORE WE DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE TOOL
IN THE PAST.
SO THIS IS IT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE FEEL IS GONNA BE A
PREVENTATIVE TOOL FOR THE
PROVIDERS THAT THEY CAN USE THIS
TRAINING AROUND STAFF IN IT AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
IT'S GONNA BE A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS
WE'VE WE'VE MET WITH THEM
THEY'VE GOT THE TOOL RIGHT NOW
WE'RE LETTING THEM. GET FAMILIAR
WITH IT FOR THREE MONTHS BEFORE
WE START OUR PILOT WHICH WILL BE
IN JULY.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NINE.
MISTER CHAIR PAT LEERY I'M TO
KEPT DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES I ACTUALLY LIKE TO DO
THE SECOND VCP FIRST YEAR WHICH
IS THE PRIVATE ALTERNATIVE
BOARDING SCHOOLS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE RESULTS OF A
BILL PASSED BY SENATOR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WITH MY SENATOR
LARA TWO YEARS AGO.
THAT REQUIRES US TO NOW LICENSE
PRIVATE THERAPEUTIC BOARDING
SCHOOLS AND WILDERNESS CAMPS
IT'S AN ENTIRELY NEW CATEGORY
FOR US.
THESE ARE FACILITIES THAT HOLD
THEMSELVES OUT AS BEING
THERAPEUTIC IN NATURE IN OTHER
WORDS THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
SOME SORT OF MILIEU THAT
ACTUALLY.
DEALS WITH.
TROUBLED TEENS HIS THEY'VE OFTEN
BEEN BEEN.
CHARACTERIZED.
THERE WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
WHEN THAT BILL WENT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT INAPPROPRIATE
ACTIVITIES AT THESE.
FACILITIES AND THE FACT THAT
THEY WEREN'T LICENSE THEY
WEREN'T USING.
LICENSED STAFF I'M OR CERTIFIED
STAFF IN THE PROCESS.
AND SO. IT BITS THESE TWO NEW
CATEGORIES WHICH ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THAT SOMEHOW OF
REGULAR FACILITIES OTHERS ARE
LITERALLY OUT IN THE WOODS OR
THE MOUNTAINS.
REQUIRES US TO CREATE A NEW
LICENSING.
SCHEMA FOR THAT.
THIS PROPOSAL GIVES US TWELVE
PERHAPS STAFF IN ORDER TO DO
THAT.
WHICH IS ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS.
ALLOWS US TO DO WERE POINTED TO
USE OUR GROUP HOME REGULATIONS
AS THE BASIS ARE NOT GONNA WRITE
IT FROM SCRATCH WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THAT.
AND THEN ADD ON TO THAT AS
NECESSARY.
THESE ARE VERY VERY DIFFERENT IN
THAT THESE ARE NOT.
CURRENTLY OPERATING FACILITIES
WHO ARE COMING FORWARD SAYING
WE'D LIKE TO BE LICENSED WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE LICENSURE FOR THE
MOST PART THEY ARE.
WE MAY HAVE TO DO A LOT OF
INVESTIGATION TO DISCOVER WHERE
THESE FACILITIES ACTUALLY ARE.
AND THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
INVESTIGATION AND.
SEARCHING OUT BOTH INTERNET
CHAT ROOMS.
TO FIND WHERE THESE THESE
FACILITIES MAIN FACT BE
OPERATING WE ALSO BELIEVE
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
POTENTIAL LEGAL ACTIVITY.
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
RELIGIOUS.
CONCERNS SOME.
THESE FACILITIES IN THE PAST
HAVE INDICATED THEY WERE
OPERATING AS A FAITH BASED.
INSTITUTION WHICH WE DON'T
REGULATE.
I HAVE AND SO FINING THE
DISTINCTION A DIFFERENCE THERE.
IS GONNA TAKE SOME LEGAL WORK
AS WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO THIS
IS OUR BEST ESTIMATE OF A
POPULATION THAT WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE ANY REAL
INDICATION OF WHAT THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF IT WOULD BE.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE NEED WE
NEED TO DO CONSIDERABLE WORK IN
ORDER TO GET STARTED ON IT. FROM
WE USE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S LIST OF PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
AS A SET UP AS A STARTING POINT
TO SEE HOW MANY MIGHT FALL INTO
THAT CATEGORY.
BUT UNTIL WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
THIS WE WON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW
MANY THESE FACILITIES ARE GONNA
COME UNDER OUR REGULATION.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT PCB OKAY THE NEXT ONE IS
ACTUALLY ON.
IT IT'S FROM OUR ADMINISTRATION
DIVISION AND ITS FOR DISASTER
SERVICES PROGRAM LAST YEAR THE.
IMMEDIATE EVACUATION OF THE
AREA AROUND THE OROVILLE DAM.
AND LATER FOLLOWED BY THE
OCTOBER FIRES AND MUD SLIDES.
GAVE US PAUSE THE DEPARTMENT IS
THE SINGLE STATE AGENCY THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR MASS KAREN
SHELTER IN DISASTERS WE'RE THE
ONES WHO WORK WITH THE RED CROSS
AND LOCAL AND COUNTY SOME LOCAL
PROVIDERS TO STAND UP SHELTERS.
AND TO SHELTER ACTIVITIES IN THE
STATE WE RECOGNIZE WE HAD SOME
SERIOUS GAPS THAT WE NEEDED TO
FILL IN.
IN ORDER TO DO THE BEST JOB
THAT WE CAN WE'VE WE HAVE THERE
BEEN OVER FIVE HUNDRED SHELTERS
THAT HAVE OPERATED IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. AND IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS IT HAS ONLY
INCREASED AND WE DO NOT SEE ANY
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
GOING TO GO DOWN. THESE STAFF
WILL ALLOW US TO NOT ONLY HAVE
MORE BOOTS ON THE GROUND SO TO
SPEAK.
DURING A DISASTER BUT WE BOTH.
ARE OUT IN THE FIELD ACTUALLY
WORKING IN SHELTERS AND WITH
LOCAL WANT EMERGENCY OPERATION
CENTERS WHERE ALSO STOPPING THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE FACILITATING
WHATEVER THE SHELTERS MIGHT MEAN
BE A BAD SPIRIT STAFF.
HOT MEALS.
ADA COMPLIANT SHOWERS WHATEVER
THEY NEED WE HEAR THE ONCE
HELPING TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
OCCURS. IT IN IN TIMES OF NOT
DISASTER WHEN WE ARE NOT HAVING.
THOSE KIND OF.
.
ACTIVITIES GOING ON WE'LL BE OUT
WORKING WITHIN THE REGIONS IN
THE STATE WHAT THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS. TO DEVELOP
DISASTER PLANS.
SO THAT WHEN A DISASTER OCCURS
EVERYONE.
IS FAMILIAR WITH EVERYONE
EVERYONE'S ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE QUEER
EVERYONE SCHOOL LINES OF
COMMUNICATION ARE VERY
ESTABLISHED AND FILL. IN THE
CINEMA AND NAPA FIRES IN
PARTICULAR THIS LAST FALL THAT
WAS REALLY REALLY HELPFUL ON THE
GROUND AND AND THE FOR THE FOLKS
THERE. THEY ALREADY HAD
EVERYBODY CELL PHONE NUMBERS
WHEN THEY NEEDED THINGS HE KNEW
EXACTLY HOW TO GET IT IT REALLY
FACILITATED HELPING TO GET THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE NECESSARY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LIVE.
I'M MORE IN THE PROCESS AND HAVE
BEEN REVIEWING THESE TWO
PROPOSALS AND REYES NO
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS I WOULD
NOTE FOR THE FIRST BZP THAT WE
HEARD REGARDING THE PRIVATE
ALTERNATIVE BOARDING SCHOOLS AN
OUTDOOR PROGRAM OVERSIGHT AND
POLICY DEVELOPMENT GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES THE SCOPE OF. WORK ON
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES THAT WOULD THEN
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
COME BACK ONCE WE HAVE A BETTER.
AND SENSE OF WHAT THE ASSOCIATED
WORKLOAD IS WHAT DO YOU WHAT
WITH THIS PARTICULAR REQUEST AND
THEN RIGHT SITES FROM THERE.
JUST INTEREST BERMAN A FINANCE
AND LOGISTICS AND SUPPORT OF
BOTH PROPOSALS AND JUST LIKE TO
NOTE THAT. THE.
THAT PREVAILED TURNING BOARDING
SCHOOLS BCP'S.
JUST BUILDING UPON THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT IS
PROVIDED DURING THE TWENTY
SOMETHING BUDGET ACCESO TIME WE
WE TOOK.
AS COMPANIES WE CAN AS SOON. AS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPRESSED ON
TRYING TO DETERMINE WHO THIS
POPULATION AS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE NON.
SEEING NONE OF.
PLEASE OUR FEAR.
WE WOULD LIKE IS THAT.
WITH THAT.
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE NINE OPEN
BUT WANTED TO ECHO IF I COULD
SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM ALEJO
ON ISSUES.
ISSUE TEN.
COULD EAT GOOD AFTERNOON I
GUESS IS GOOD EVENING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ARE IN MY NAME
IS MOMENTO METAL IN I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
AND ACHIEVEMENTS JULY JUDGE FOR
THE STATE HEARINGS DIVISION AND
WE HAVE TO BE SEE PEACE ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND ALL ADDRESS
THE FIRST ONE WHICH IS THE AC
REQUEST FOR FOUR. POINT OH
POSITIONS FOR OUR ACMS PROJECT.
BOMB IT SO THIS IS THESE ARE
PETITIONS FACADE THAT ARE
CONTAINED WITHIN OUR S. P. ARE.
OF FROM THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PROJECT.
BUT THAT THEY TERMINATED.
ON DECEMBER SAYS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WERE LOOKING TO EXTEND
THOSE ARM AND THE AT A COST OF
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY THREE
THOUSAND. ON ENDA WE ASK FOR A
SUPPORT FOR THAT.
IN THE SECOND A IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AND OKAY THE SECOND
ONE IS.
IF THEY REQUEST OUGHT TO.
FOR SIXTEEN ADDITIONAL STAFF
ARE TO ADDRESS INCREASED
WORKLOAD ARISING FROM TO A MAJOR
FACTORS ONE IS THE OUR CHANGE IN
FEDERAL LAW.
THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR OF THAT
DATA.
REQUIRES US TO HOLD EXPLAINED
HEARINGS IN THREE DAYS ARE AND
ALSO REQUIRES US TO ENGAGE IN.
EXHAUSTIVE OF A REVIEW TO
DETERMINE WHETHER A NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW PROCESS
HAS BEEN ARE GONE THROUGH BY
CLAIMANTS ARE THAT ALONG WITH
THE TWENTY TWO PERCENT INCREASE.
IN THE DECISIONS THAT WE ALL
HAVE TO WRITE A OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS.
COME TOGETHER TO FOR US TO HAVE
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL A ALJ
RESOURCES IN THE AMOUNT OF
SIXTEEN IN ORDER FOR US TO CLOSE
THE GAP IN AVOID. HAVING LAKE
DECISIONS AND THE CORRESPONDING.
LA PENALTIES THAT COME FROM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA
OWNERSHIP.
JENNY BALLOT THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE REVIEW REVIEWED BOTH THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE NO ISSUES
WITH THE OTHER.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE TEN
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT UP TO
THE DICE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
ELEVEN. THINK
.
I AM LOOKING FOR AVINASH YA
CRESSEY AND MARTIN MARTINEZ.
SPEAK TO THE PROPOSAL ON ISSUE
ELEVEN.
THANK YOU THAT.
SELECT.
OKAY.
GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING THAT'S
ARAMBULA.
MY NAME IS OUT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AL SANTANA
AND THE.
A HEALTH POLICY ANALYST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IN THE RULE HEALTH
BOARD. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH
ME THAT I'M JUST GOING TO
INTRODUCE.
THEIR FIRST ONE IS MIKE
MARTINEZ FROM REDWOOD VALLEY
CONSOLIDATED TRAVEL HEALTH.
COMING.
CHAIRS
FOR DINNER OKAY LIKE TO CONGRESS
HE.
AND I THINK JOB MISTER MARTINEZ
HAD A LETTER THAT HE WANTED TO.
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE SO YOU
CAN GET THAT FOR THE SERGEANT.
AND THEN THE SECOND ONE IS SEVEN
A SECRECY
WHO IS OUR DIRECTOR OF OUR
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
BOB THANK YOU FOR YOU KNOW BEING
HERE TODAY I SORT OF CAME UP BUT
THE.
WE WERE WAITING A LONG TIME AS
THOUGH WE WERE JUST OUTSIDE THAT
LOOKS AS WE'VE BEEN RUNNING SO.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS BUT OTHERWISE I'LL BE
QUIET THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARK MARTINSEN
DIRECTOR.
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR REDWOOD
VALLEY RANCHERIA CONSOLIDATED.
TRAVEL HEALTH AND.
WORK WITH THE CELTICS PROGRAM
SINCE IT FIRST STARTED.
AND I HAVE OUR.
I HAVE SEEN.
WHAT IT DOES FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THAT ARE NOT?
ADDRESSED IN MANY WAYS.
AND.
THIS FUNDING THAT WE GET.
COMES TO NATIVE COMMUNITIES IN
THE COMMUNITY CIVIC COMES TO HAS
BIG ISSUES WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES.
TRANSPORTATION AND THEN
AND A LOT OF A LOT OF VIOLENCE
AND ALL OF THIS IN THIS FUNDING
THAT WE GET.
IS IS.
ONE.
ONE THING THAT WE.
WE USE.
A COMBAT.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TO COMBAT.
VIOLENCE TO TO TAKE PEOPLE AND
SAVE THEIR LIVES AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND.
TO GET BACK INTO BALANCE WITH
LIFE.
AND.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH THOUGH BECAUSE
THEIR TERRITORY SO BIG.
AND YOU JUST HAVE ONE.
I'M A PROVIDER.
AND THE PROVIDER WHEN YOU JUST
HAVE ONE AND YOU HAVE A BIG
COUNTY WITH TEN DIFFERENT KID
NATIVE COMMUNITY SENATE. THEY
DON'T GET ANY KIND OF OTHER
SERVICES FROM.
MANY PLACES
THAT DATA IT WHEN I NEED TO GO
PICK A KIND OF.
SAY ROUND VALLEY.
AND TAKEN TO TREATMENT THAT'S
THAT'S
THREE HOURS TO GET THERE GET
BACK WHERE I STARTED. AND THEN
GO DOWN TO THE TREATMENT CENTER
WHICH SOME OF THEM ARE FIVE
HOURS AWAY SAY DOWN IN FRESNO.
SO IT HAS A LOT TO DO IT
TRAVELING.
AND THEN.
AND TAKING ME OUT OF MY OFFICE
SO THERE'S NOBODY THERE NOW.
SO WHAT WHAT I SEE HERE IS IF WE
CAN GET THAT WHAT WORD QUESTING.
AND GET ANOTHER WORKER THERE.
THERE THAT THIS IS GONNA BE.
WORKING TWICE AS GOOD
AS AS WHAT I I PROVIDE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES TO TO COME. AND AND.
HAVE A PLACE FINALLY TO GO AS AS
I WAS WAITING HERE TODAY I GOT
ALL KINDS OF PHONE CALLS. PEOPLE
UPSET BECAUSE HAVE NOT MY OFFICE
THINGS LIKE
I'M I'M COMING OVER HERE TO SEE
IF I CAN GET MORE WORKERS.
AND IF AND IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
IT'S REALLY GONNA REALLY HELP
OUT AND A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PLACES PLUS TO SPENDING.
WHEN WE HAD.
FIRST STARTED OFF WE HAD
MEETINGS WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES THAT THIS GOES TO.
AND WE WOULD SHARE.
WHAT?
WE CAN DO IT THIS FUNDING AND
THAT REALLY HELPED US.
UNDERSTAND HOW TO GET OUR
PROGRAM STRONGER AND WOOD AND
THINGS WE CAN POSSIBLY USE.
WITH THIS
THIS FUNDING THAT WE GET FROM
FROM DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
ADAM FOR THE INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS SO.
OKAY SO.
JUSTICE JUST OF THEM TO ME IT'S
VERY.
VERY VALUABLE AND AND.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK UP TO GET THIS
FOR US AND AND.
LET YOU KNOW THAT IS NOT BEING
WASTED BUT WE REALLY NEED MORE.
OF OF.
THIS FUNDING TO BE INCLUDED IN
TWO.
OUR SERVICES
BECAUSE IS IS TO USE.
I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE.
YEAH THAT WITH OTHER INDIAN
HEALTH CLINICS IN OUR IN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE ALL RULE. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE TRIES BUT THERE'S NO
TRIBES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CITY.
WE'RE WAY OUT THERE IN THE
HILLS.
SO WERE WAY IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF TIME.
TO TO.
.
GO THERE TO TAKE CARE ONE
PERSON.
WHERE IT AND AND BUT BUT DO IT?
SO.
WE WE HAVE OUR.
LOT OF WORK TO DO YET.
AND.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ.
NEXTBUS KRESKIN.
GOOD EVENING UP MY NAME IS
VANESSA YET PRESCIENT THEM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RULE INDIAN
HEALTH BOARD.
I'M A CORPORATE IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE THE CALIFORNIA RULE
IN THE HEALTH BOARD IS
SANCTIONED BY FORTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA TRIBES. TO OPERATE
UNDER THE INDIAN SELF
DETERMINATION ACT AS THE TRIBAL
ORGANIZATION.
OUR MEMBERSHIP CONSISTS OF
FOURTEEN TRIBAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE FORTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR TRIBES.
WE HAVE ESTABLISH A RELATIONSHIP
OF TRUST WITH THE AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKA NATIVE PEOPLE
STATEWIDE. AND HAVE AN EXTENSIVE
HISTORY OF PROVIDING CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE TIGHTEN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO TRIBAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND TRIBES
WHERE COMMITTED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICES THAT
WILL ELEVATE THE HEALTH AND
SOCIAL CONSISTENT CONDITIONS. OF
THE INDIAN PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE IN IT HEALTH CLINIC PROGRAM
WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WITH CAL WORK FUNDS
PARTIALLY REIMBURSES FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAMS. AND
THIRTY FIVE INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS IN BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS.
TOGETHER THEY COVER TERRITORY
ALL THE WAY FROM THE ORGAN
BORDER IN Y. RICA. DOWN THE
CALIFORNIA COAST THROUGH THE
SIERRAS AND ALPINE IN YOUR
COUNTIES TO SAN DIEGO IN WINTER
HAVEN.
THE PROGRAM ASSISTS WITH
MANAGEMENT AND TREATMENT OF
AMERICAN INDIAN INDIVIDUALS AND
THE CAL WORKS OR TRAVEL TOWN OF
PROGRAM.
TO DEVELOP PERSONAL PLANS THAT
COMPLY WITH WELFARE TO WORK
REQUIREMENTS TO OBTAIN AND
SUSTAIN EMPLOYMENT.
AT A MAXIMUM GRANT AWARD OF JUST
OVER FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR PER CLINIC IT REQUIRES A
FIVE YEAR IMHO YOU. AND IS DYING
AND IS DESIGNED TO OFFSET THE
COSTS OF PERSONNEL SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES TRANSPORTATION
COSTS THAT DOCTOR ARE MISTER
MARTINEZ MENTION. TO DRIVE
PATIENTS TO APPOINTMENTS FOR
TREATMENTS INTO COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS OVER RULED DISTANCES
AND ALSO REFERRAL APPOINTMENTS
TO INCENTIVE TREATMENT INCLUDING
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES.
AFTER THE RECESSION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE HIGHLY VALUED
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION AND IN
HEALTH PROGRAM UNDER THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. WAS STRUCK DOWN
BY THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE BEEN
ONLY MINIMAL CONSULTATION
FUNCTIONS AS A RESULT THE CAL
WORKS FUNDED INDIAN HEALTH
CLINIC PROGRAM. IS THE ONLY BE
ABLE HEALTH PROGRAM THAT REMAINS
IN THE STATE AND IS SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED FOR AMERICAN INDIANS
AND PROVIDES COURTROOM
APPROPRIATE SERVICES AND
TRADITIONAL HEALING PRACTICES.
OUR ORGANIZATION TRIBES AND
INDIAN HEALTH CLINICS ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN INCREASING THIS
BUDGET LINE ITEM.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE HIGH
SUBSTANCE USE RATES IN THE I OP
WOOD EPUB EPIDEMIC THAT IS
DEVASTATING THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND RECENTLY WITH THE CLARITY
NATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
THE OPEN ROAD EPIDEMIC IS HAS
PARTICULARLY SEVERE AND
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
AMONG CALIFORNIA INDIANS FROM
TWO THOUSAND SIX TO
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE BURDEN
OF OPIOID DEATHS WAS HIGHEST
AMONG THE FORTY FIVE TO FIFTY
FOUR YEAR AGE GROUP. WHICH WAS
TEN POINT TWO PERCENT COMPARED
TO THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE OF FOUR
POINT NINE.
WHICH IS MORE THAN DOUBLE.
WE ARE SEEKING A REASONABLE
INCREASE OF TWO POINT ONE FIVE
MILLION AND SUCH AUGMENTATION
WOULD TRANSLATE TO ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND PER CLINIC BASED ON
THIRTY SIX INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS.
THIS AUGMENTATION WOULD ALLOW
THESE CLINICS TO COVER THE COSTS
OF.
ONE FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
POSITION WITH BENEFITS
AND THIS WOULD GREATLY HELP
ADDRESS THE INCREASING CASELOAD
CARRIED BY DRUG AND ALCOHOL
COUNSELLORS SUCH AS MISTER
MARTINEZ. ORCHID ALSO FREE OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR EACH CLICK HAS
BEEN MORE ON CASE WORKER
SERVICES FOR OPIATE USE
MANAGEMENT OR GROUP THERAPY
SESSIONS.
SUPPORTED THIS BUDGET ACTION
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT STEP
PROPER FILLING IN A POOR AND
STATE GOVERNMENT RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROVIDE HEALTHCARE AND OTHER
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA INDIANS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
DOCTOR LIKE WHEN.
ACTUALLY KIM JOHNSON WHOSE ARE
CAL WORKS CHIEF IS END OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DOING T. A
WITH COUNTIES TODAY ARM SO I
JUST WANT TO SORT OF. OFFER HER
APOLOGY ARM ANTI WE WE DO VALUE.
OUR OUR RELATIONSHIP OF WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD I THINK YANG HAS IMPACT.
PERMIT FINANCE WE HAVE BEEN.
CONVERSATIONS WITH.
PROPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
WE'VE YOU KNOW LOOK AT THEIR
ESTIMATES IT SEEMS REGIONAL BASE
OF WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR. BUT
I'VE BEEN THERE IT'S JUST MATTER
PRIORITIES.
LEN INCOME.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
ELEVEN AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT UP TO
THE DIET SYSTEM THE MORE MATHIS.
MISTER MARTINEZ SIR MARTIN.
THE VENEZIA SANTA CORRECTLY.
THANK YOU BOTH ARM I COVER BOTH
THE.
SHOWN A PIE YOU'D OUT OF BISHOP
IN THE TO THE RIVER TRIBE AND
TULARE.
I'VE SEEN BOTH CLINICS.
THEY DO A TREMENDOUS JOB.
I MEAN ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AROUND
THE MIDDLE OF NO WHERE YOU GUYS
ARE THE ONE STOP WE HAVE A HUGE
HUGE LP ONLY. EPIDEMIC PLAGUE.
ON TOP OF DEALING WITH PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WITH.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
STUFF TRYING TO POLICE OF THINGS
TO IT TO KEEP BAD ELEMENTS OUT
OF OUR TRIBAL LANDS.
WERE YOU GUYS DO IS PHENOMENAL
WORK.
FOR. YOUR PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE.
.
SO KEEP IT UP YOU DO HAVE MY
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE.
AS FAR AS THAT THE CONCERN IS
PRIORITIES.
WE'VE JUMPED.
TWO NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE HAVE
PLENTY OF MONEY ACCORDING TO THE
LA THOUGH REPORT SO I THINK WE
CAN FIND SOME ROOM.
THAT'S ALL I LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING WITH THE ELMORE. THING.
THANK YOU SOME WOMEN MATHIS.
BEFORE WE CLOSE TODAY'S HEARING
I WANTED TO.
SHARE AS WELL HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS FOR A RURAL COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE THAT WE INCREASE ACCESS
AND TREATMENTS TO ALL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WANTED TO THANK BOTH OF YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD.
I WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN FOR NOW AND CONCLUDE
TODAY SOMEONE HEARING THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH THANK YOU